Previously on N24.
Über das, was er geschaffen hat, was er hinterlässt, darüber sprechen wir. Im Studio begrüße ich Tim Pridloff, Computerexperte. Schön, dass Sie da sind. Guten Morgen.
Schönen guten Morgen.
Wir haben gestern ja nun die Vorstellung des iPhone 4S gehabt. Enttäuschung war die erste Reaktion.
Ich kann nicht sagen, was für eine wirkliche Enttäuschung ist. Also wo ich echt wirklich enttäuscht werde. Und das ist einfach das Thema Podcasting auf dem iPhone.
Heißt konkret was?
Sind wir den Journalisten? Dass wir ja immer alles genau recherchieren müssen?
Eigentlich hatte man ein bisschen Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Na gut, also so viel zur Steve-Enttäuschung. Wir haben eine Sendung von einer Enttäuschung vorbereitet. Ich würde sagen, kommen wir zur furchtbaren Apple-ID-iCloud-Desaster. Ja, das ist eine Enttäuschung ist das. Das ist eigentlich schon eine Katastrophe.
Danke schön für die Erschätzung, Herr Warnz.
Herzlich willkommen bei BUMZACK RETURN! Pfeifen wir uns doch einfach was. Ich pfeif drauf. Mobamex, 75. Ausgabe, wo andere Leute anfangen, Ehrenringe zu verteilen. Gehen wir einfach ganz straight in die Sendung ohne viel Tammtamm. Ja, Mobamex, willkommen. Willkommen in der Post-Steve-Ära und...
In der Post-Pizza-Ära.
In der Post-Pizza-Ära auch. Heute gab es keine Pizza, warum auch immer. Das ist für mich... Also es geht auf mich.
Ich bin kein Huckel.
Dennis, du hast recht.
Oh, die Pizza ist nach der Pizza, nicht andersrum.
Du hast recht, ich hab deinen Default missachtet. Aber du darfst auch meine Defaults nicht missachten. Also wenn du den Kalender abonnierst, dann ist auch das Pizza-Abo jetzt klar. Aber da müssen wir uns irgendwie was einfallen lassen. Das Maß an elektronischer Organisation dieser Sendung, das hinkt einfach hinter unserem Anspruch gegenüber allem anderen deutlich hinterher. Verstehst du immer, auf alles einpacken?
Also dieser iCar zum Beispiel, der springt mich ja nicht an. Weißt du, so ein... Obwohl, Twitter springt mich auch nicht an. Aber so eine iMessage, die würde mir direkt ins Gesicht springen.
So ein iCar, so ein Kalendereintrag, den siehst du auch auf dem iPhone.
Ja, wenn ich mir den gemacht habe.
Ja, du brauchst den Kalender zu abonnieren. Ja, du abonnierst den einmal.
Hab ich den nicht?
Ich hab's dir schön einfach gemacht. Ich hab ja viel Energie investiert hier in die Webseite, wenn ich dir das mal kurz zeigen darf.
Warum ist da oben so eigentlich so ein weißer Rand und ich sehe gar nichts? Warum ist da oben so ein... Da wo Mobile Max steht. Da steht zweimal Mobile Max, einmal weiß auf blau und einmal schwarz auf weiß.
Warum? Weil das so ist.
Schwarz auf weiß, blau...
Wie, weil das so ist? Das ist ja nun mal eine tolle Aussage.
Ja, was ist das Problem?
Max hatte mal ein Kind raus in die Welt.
Warum ist das so doppelt gemobbelt?
Genau.
Weil das Theme nun mal so ist. Ist nicht so, dass ich das designen hätte oder so. Ich hab es genommen.
Stehe.
Das war eine Abwägung.
Kann ich dir mal Zugang zuhaben? Wozu? Zu dem Block da.
Zu dem Theme.
Nee, nicht zu dem Theme, sondern zu dem Block, damit ich mich da einloggen kann. Kommentare freischalten und sowas.
Musst du dir nur ein Garen klicken.
Sind wir schon live jetzt eigentlich?
Ja, wir sind total mega live, was du wahrscheinlich gemerkt hast an dem Intro und so.
Stimmt. Ja, und dem Schimmel.
Ja, das auch. Na, wie auch immer. Trotz alledem, diese Webseite enthält so einiges, auch für dich, Dennis. Ich kann dir das ja jetzt mal gleich zusätzlich zu den Hörern auch mit erklären. Ich hab also viel Zeit investiert. Viele Dinge, die nicht passiert sind, sind hier hinter den Kulissen gelaufen. Ich hab einfach ganz emsig an den ganzen Webpräsenzen der Metaebene gefummelt. Und ich denke, ich hab's jetzt so im Wesentlichen beisammen, wenn euch also irgendwas fehlt, hier auf der Webseite irgendeine Information oder so. Jetzt wäre der Zeitpunkt da, entsprechendes Feedback zu geben. Denn jetzt kann ich da einfach ein bisschen dran rumfummeln. Also es gibt hier alle Hinweise auf die nächsten Termine. Das steht hier alles im Sidebar. Es gibt einen Kalender zum Abonnieren. Immer die Links auf die Streams etc. Und natürlich auch auf unseren geliebten Chat, der wie immer kluge Anmerkungen macht.
Haben wir schon gesagt, dass der Hochgeleut nicht dabei ist?
Nee, haben wir nicht gesagt. Das wurde bisher nur geahnt.
Das war eine Familientragöde, der kann heute nicht. Nicht wirklich eine Tragödie, oder? Ehmals.
Nein. So, was ist hier mit unseren Rolls-Royce-Pars-Tasten?
Ja, meine geht nicht.
Die Rolls-Royce-Pars nicht?
Meine Rolls-Royce-Pars nicht.
Ah, meine funktioniert.
Meine nicht.
Die ist ja noch am Pairing, wie du siehst.
Ja, das macht das. Hör auf.
Welche Nummer ist das?
Keine Ahnung, das hier ist die 4. Macht es nicht. Das Leben meines Nerds sollte eigentlich Pairing, aber kann ich.
Ja, Steve hat wahrscheinlich das Blutfuß-Pairing auch mit ins Graben genommen. Oh mann, ich freu mich, wie lange man sich jetzt mit solchen Steve-Witzen noch über Wasser halten muss. Ich find ja auch, dass sie... Man denkt ja jetzt auch schon seit längerer Zeit, dass die offizielle Trauerphase beendet ist. Aber es nimmt ja irgendwie so recht kein Ende. Findest du? Ja, es kommen ja permanent immer wieder neue Dinge hoch. Dann erst mal hier diese Remembering Steve-Veranstaltung.
Habt ihr hier angeguckt?
Ja.
Ich find die ganz gut. Also erstaunlich gut, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja gut, ich weiß nicht, ich kann das nicht in gut oder schlecht einkategorisieren.
Also ich hab das Gefühl, ich hab das Elgore irgendwie im NMA genommen hat oder so. Er hat ja nur von Love gesprochen. Ich dachte ja, was ist mit dem?
Ich hab denen das irgendwie echt alles abgenommen, was sie da so erzählt haben.
Ich fand den von Johnny Eaves ganz geil. Der hat das so sehr lakonisch, witzig, unterhaltsam.
Ich fand das voll super.
Ich schlag euch jetzt auch immer dopey Ideas vor.
Guck mal, hier ist deine Rospa-Taste.
Das ist die Anti-Vader-Taste, da liegst du ja auch A drauf. Anti-Vader hier. Nimm Anti-Vader.
Die Leute wollen das so.
Jetzt gib mir mal hier deinen Apparat, das kann ja nichts sein.
Ich dachte, ich muss die letzten Tage sterben. Eigentlich war ich schon drauf und dran, euch abzusagen heute. Sterben, ja. So krank war ich. So schlimmer Schnupfen.
Sollen wir uns noch mal über die Sache unterhalten, über diese Veranstaltung?
Ich hab festgestellt, dass ich Coldplay nicht leiden kann.
Ich hab festgestellt, dass ich Coldplay nicht kenne.
Na gut, das wundert ja keinen mehr.
Das ist ja echt hart.
Hart? Wieso ist das hart? Ich kenn es nicht.
Ich glaub, wir sind eine der bekanntesten Bands der Welt.
Ja, jetzt?
Ich glaub, die kommen nur knapp nach dem Beatles.
Oder sind das die, die es schon seit Ewigkeiten gibt? Oder ist das so wie so eine Erfindung der letzten Zeit?
Zehn Jahre schon locker, oder?
Zehn Jahre ist auch keine Ewigkeit.
Die haben es eigentlich schon lange hinter uns, Mann.
Formed 1996.
Nee, weißt du, das sind da so Hipster-Typen, die Glück hatten an Steve, die anscheinend ganz toll fand. Und dann aber bepinseln sie irgendwie mit Spredosen ihre Instrumente da so ein bisschen und machen alles ein bisschen auch schäbig und dann meinen sie, sie sind irgendwie voll vorne dabei. Ich weiss ja nicht und dann da so ein Geschrommel. Also ich so als Radiohead-Fan kann ja nicht sagen, dass das da toll war.
Ich mag Radiohead auch, aber ich finde auch Coldplay zugegebenermaßen mit ein bisschen Verschränkungen nicht schlecht.
Ich bin da ganz neutral, aber ich hab da bei der Veranstaltung, ich hab die auch gehört, da war ich eigentlich schon total müde, aber es poppte halt so kurz vor dem Schlafengehen, poppte mir diese Veranstaltung ins Gesicht und...
Hat gar schon lange gedauert, oder?...
muss ich mir das eben auch noch geben. Und dann hab ich irgendwie bei diesem Gesinger, hab hier aber nach vorne gespult. Das war für mich so wie bei diesen...
Ach ja, jetzt weiß ich das, ich kann nicht spulen, weil ich hier dieses eine, wie heißt es hier, den Ghostory am Start hatte. Stimmt, hat mir ja schon mal jemand erzählt, dass ich deswegen nicht spulen kann. Ich konnte nicht spulen, ich konnte nicht sehen, wann es vorbei ist und dann war ich da festgenagelt, dass ich kann nicht spulen.
Dann musst du dir das ganze Set geben, ja?
Ja, und als ich auf Toilette musste, bin ich voll gerannt und schnell wieder zurück, damit ich nichts verpasse. Nee, so war es auch nicht, aber... Stimmt, dieses Ghostory sorgt dafür, dass ich keine...
Hast du MacBook einfach mit auf Klo genommen?
Ich hab da mein Riesendisplay dran und das ist halt so ein bisschen Desktop. Aber ehrlich muss ich sagen, dass wenn man sich so Videos anguckt, also bei Apple oder wo auch immer, und die haben keinen Slider, keinen Play, keinen gar nichts, ist fast so ein bisschen wie Fernsehen. Wie Fernsehen. Weil du musst gucken, du kannst nicht anhalten, du kannst nicht vorspulen, das ist ja auch nicht wirklich live, aber es ist so... Ja, wenn du aus Klo willst, musst du dich halt beeilen, sonst verpasst halt das. Also irgendwie, und ich finde, das hat auch so ein bisschen Stil, so ohne diese ganzen Bedienelemente und so. Könnte ja Mausfrühe, müsste man Ghost Stories installieren, habte das auch. Ansonsten über die Veranstaltung, ich weiß nicht, also, naja, die haben jetzt alle gesagt, dass das Stil ganz toll war und so weiter, so wie es sich halt gehört und...
Ja, was sollen sie ja auch sonst sagen, ne? Ja.
Da hat mich schon gewundert, dass wirklich die ganzen Apple-Mitarbeiter, die haben ja ab und zu mal so reingezoomt, die waren ja schon teilweise Leute, die waren ja wirklich richtig am Ende. Also voll standen da die gestandenen Männer heulend irgendwie da.
Das war ja auch alles sehr ergreifend gemacht und so. Ich fand's ganz lustig, wie sie so den quasi, das ist ja bei so einer Veranstaltung auch immer so, gerade bei der Veranstaltung, ja, sehr wichtiger, denn wie geht's weiter danach eigentlich? Und da haben sie ja schon so ein bisschen so, oh ja, Steve hat noch vorher gesagt, wir sollen nicht das machen, was er gemacht hätte, weil das Disney so gelebt hat. Das kam doch da dann vor, oder? Wobei das jetzt ein bisschen so ein Paradox an ist.
Aber ich hätte ja so eine Veranstaltung auch nicht ganz so stark so businessmäßig gemacht, wenn man niemanden da hinterher trauert. Also nur ein ganz bisschen. Aber er meinte ja, dass es halt so ein bisschen da drum ging und ich meinte, dass es ja okay war, dass da nicht so viel von diesem Business war, weil es einfach auch nicht so wirklich dahin gehört, finde ich. Wenn jemand nachtraut, dann redet man nicht gleich, wie kriegt er so ein Business ohne den Film?
Nein, natürlich nicht. Um Himmels willen, das ist ja nicht so, hey guckt mal, Steve ist tot und wir haben trotzdem viele iPhones verkauft. Ich meine, klar, das wär natürlich doof. Aber man muss ja auch schon so den Weg zeigen. Also man kann jetzt nicht so, Steve ist tot, oh mein Gott, wir werden alle sterben, sondern... Man muss ja auch so ein bisschen so eine Perspektive zeigen. Und das finde ich war okay.
Twitter weist mich gerade darauf hin, dass dieser Typ von Coldplay seine Tochter Apple genannt hat. Aber das war schon 2004.
Wieso schon?
Weil Steve die doch vor zehn Jahren schon gedingst hat. Haben die doch erzählt, oder? War das nicht?
Gedingst?
Na, wenn er sich die schon angehört hat, als sie noch irgendwie nicht bekannt waren und denen dann erzählt hier mit dem Song, da wird aus euch nie was. Der erste Song, den die gespielt haben, der ist doch irgendwie von der Zeit, oder? Also muss die ja mit Steve da schon zu tun haben.
Der ist schon deutlich älter.
Oder älter, ja sag ich ja. Also hatten die da schon vorher mit Steve zu tun.
Sagen wir so, wenn...
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob der ist, die deshalb Apple genannt hat.
Steve hat die bekannt gemacht und hat gesagt, aber dafür kriege ich euer Erstgeborenes.
Na toll, das zweite Kind heißt Moses. Du willst mir jetzt nicht erzählen, dass er auch noch mit Moses irgendwie ein Date hatte.
Weißt du uns?
Na, wie auch immer. Ich fand die Veranstaltung auf jeden Fall halbwegs würdig. Und ich hoffe, dass es jetzt alles endlich mal ein Ende findet. Weil jetzt kam auch noch dieser Text von dieser Mona Simpson. Den hast du noch nicht gelesen?
Nee, von seiner Schwester.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann diese Heulerei jetzt einfach nicht mehr.
Ich muss jetzt noch durch die Biografie durchkämpfen.
Ich hab das Buch heute gesehen in so einem Laden, war leider nur in Deutschland, der ist mir ja gleich geschoppt.
Ich hab das jetzt ganz schön fysisch gesehen, das ist ziemlich fett. Ich hab das ja nur auf dem Kindle und da ist es erstaunlich dünn. Ich hab das dann neulich bei Freunden rumliegen sehen.
Und dachte so, oh Gott, muss ich mich da durchliegen sehen?
Nee, da hab ich dann die physische Ausgabe gesehen. Kann man lesen. Der hat schon ein krasses Leben gehabt irgendwie.
Wie viel hast du denn gelesen?
Ich bin noch nicht so extrem weit. Ich bin jetzt gerade da, wo sie quasi Apple gründen, weil danach krank geworden und da konnte ich echt nicht mehr lesen. Da ging gar nichts mehr. Aber ja, also ich meine, das ist echt bizarr. Wann haben die Apple gegründet? Mit 21 haben die Apple gegründet. Also ich meine, ja, die Zahl hatte ich schon ein paar Mal vorher gehört, aber das ist eigentlich so bizarr jung. Der kommt halt gerade irgendwie frisch vom College. Und eigentlich hatte er dafür, dass er 21 ist, zumindest diesen Buch nach, schon sehr viel erlebt. So ein halbes Jahr durch Indien gewandert.
Trips geschmissen, ohne Erinnerung.
Na ja, das sowieso natürlich dann...
Steht das auch drin?
Ja, ja. Karotten, so viele gefressen.
Braucht man sich auch nicht wundern, warum das Apple-Logo dann später so viele Farben hatte.
Der war ja schon offensichtlich als Teenager quasi Frutajaner und so viele Karotten gegessen, dass seine Haut orange wurde, dann irgendwie geglaubt, dass er da umging wirklich zu sagen...
Ja, und die Scheiße hat ihn jetzt auch echt ins Grab getrieben.
Ja, das ist recht bizarr, ne?
Macht ja einen ganz zähen Eindruck, als er selber bereut jetzt.
Na jetzt nicht mehr.
Der wusste 2004 von seinem Krebs leiden. Der hat dann einen Check gemacht auf Nierensteine oder so, und dabei haben sie das zufällig gefunden. Das wäre seine Riesenschance gewesen, weil hätten sie ihn sofort operiert, wäre die Wahrscheinlichkeit auf jeden Fall deutlich größer gewesen, als neun Monate später, wo sie ihn dann operiert haben, dass dieser Tumor sich nicht auf andere Bereiche des Körpers ausdehnt. Und genau das ist dann nämlich passiert. Und wie wir wissen, hat das sozusagen dazu geführt, dass das alles nicht mehr in den Griff zu kriegen.
Ja, was hat das jetzt mit seinem Karotten zu tun?
Weil er halt der Meinung war, er müsse sich jetzt nicht operieren lassen und er würde das mit der richtigen Diät schon irgendwie hinkriegen.
Ja, ja, genau.
Ja, eben, Krebs, Krebs, Diät und so. Da ist ja so ein Superhirn und dann irgendwie dann doch so ein Penner. Und alle haben irgendwie auf ihn eingeredet und er ist dann halt an der Stelle auch nicht lernfähig gewesen. Er ist vielleicht lernfähig gewesen, aber an der Stelle ist es nicht so. Zu langsam lernfähig. Genau, das war dann nicht so mit, naja, ok, der Cube war nix, jetzt machen wir es anders.
Das war einer der Fehler, den man nur einmal macht.
Ja, genau. Und das ist natürlich, ist eigentlich, ist es wirklich mal verdammt schade. Weil, gut, weiß man natürlich nicht, hätte natürlich sein können, dass sie ihn sofort operiert hätten und es wäre trotzdem, hätte es sich trotzdem ausgebreitet, aber es ist sicherlich...
Wesentlich bessere Chancen gehabt.
Es macht so den Eindruck in der Wahrnehmung der Nachrichten, dass er seine Chancen doch deutlich...
Wobei da sicherlich auch die Dramatik von jeder weiteren Nachrichtenquelle, die davon mitbekommt, steigt. Und die Chancen, dass er überlebt hätten, wahrscheinlich.
Ja gut, aber es ist halt jetzt auch über diesen Isaxen da komportiert worden, dass er das eben bereut hat. Tja, das hat ihn unter Umständen jetzt... Ja, mag man alles gar nicht vor Nachdenken eigentlich, ist schlimm.
Wegen Karotten.
Naja, und dieser Text da von seiner Schwester, das war mir auch noch... Also das war so ein Detail, was mir jetzt nicht so bekannt war. Das hab ich irgendwie erst vor kurzem aufgegriffen. Also dass er nicht nur eine Schwester noch hatte von den selben leiblichen Eltern, sondern dass er mit der dann eben auch dicke war. Und die war dann halt irgendwie auch noch im letzten Moment dabei. Und dann schreibt sie halt seine letzten Worte.
Also die letzten Worte hab ich jetzt gelesen, aber die sollen ja irgendwie im Kontext nur Sinn machen.
Ja im Kontext. Naja, der Kontext, also sie beschreibt das recht intensiv. So und im Wesentlichen ist es so, dass er umringt war von seiner ganzen Familie. Und dann irgendwie alle noch mal angeschaut hat. Und dann meinte er irgendwie, oh wow, oh wow, oh wow. Wie das jetzt geklungen haben, Marc, kann man nur spekulieren.
Wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, sondern nicht kraftvoll.
Oder vielleicht sogar doch. Ich musste sofort zu deinem 2001 denken. Ja, warum nicht ey? Ich meine, das ist ja so ein Ableben.
Apropos 2001. Ich ziehe zwar sogar an, es ist über dem Bogen. Also leider gestern, für 40 Jahren, wurde das Pink Floyd Album Echoes irgendwie rausgebracht. Quatsch, Metal heißt es, aber da ist der Song Echoes drauf. Und angeblich, wenn man den zum letzten Ende von 2001 abspielt, dann würde das wohl voll so draufpassen.
Von wem?
Also von Pink Floyd gibt es ein Album, das heißt Metal. Das kam gestern vor 40 Jahren raus.
Metals.
Metal. E-M. Quatsch, M-E-D-D-E-E. Und da ist ein Song drauf, der heißt Echoes und der dauert über 20 Minuten. Das ist halt früher eine Vinylplattenseite gewesen. Das war eine ganze Seite. Und wenn man den Song passend zum letzten Ende von 2001 abspielt, weil der ist ja 2001, das ist ja auch so ein Abschnitt, dann soll das wohl ziemlich gut draufpassen. Das wird zwar von den Pink Floyd Leuten auch nicht bestätigt, dass es so wäre, aber manche Leute sagen, es ist mir auch total egal, ich wollte es nur mal schnell reinschmeißen, weil ich wollte es mal gesagt haben. Na, da hab ich das ja auch hier, Mann.
Ach so.
Ich hab hier mit Roger Waters irgendwie geschnackt, per iMessage.
Was weiß ich?
Der ist von Pink Floyd. Der hat, klar, hast nicht mit ihm gechattet, darum hat er es auch nicht bestätigt, dass er gerade gesagt hat, das ist nicht bestätigt.
Okay, also Pink Floyd hat das jetzt wieder bestätigt noch.
Genau.
Das heißt doch, hier steht immer, sie meinten...
Fun-Fact, genau, das ist ein Fun-Fact. Jetzt einfach weitermachen, nicht so drauf eingehen und alles ist gut.
Fun-Fact, Fun-Fact, Fun-Fact. Schneller, schneller, schneller, schneller, schneller. Siri, wie sollen wir weitermachen?
Warte, warte.
Wie sollen wir weitermachen?
Entschuldigung, ich verstehe. Wie sollen wir weitermachen? Nicht.
Mach mal lauter.
Jetzt darf Siri sagen. Und, was jetzt auch noch was?
Das soll das revolutionäre neue Interfell sein.
SMS an Tim. Das funktioniert so halbwegs.
Was möchtest du Timbriedlowe sagen?
Mach dich nicht über Siri lustig, Ausrufezeichen.
Okay, ich hab deine Nachricht aktualisiert. Jetzt lautet sie. Mach dich nicht über sie lustig. Soll ich sie senden?
Senden.
Okay, ich habe die Nachricht abgeschickt.
Der versteht Siri nicht.
Ist geil.
Siri versteht Siri nicht. Das ist echt. Also es ist...
Frag doch mal Siri, wie sie heißt.
Wie heißt du?
Mein Name? Der ist Siri.
Das ganz cool ist so, Stell den Wecker auf 9.
Es ist schon ein Wecker gestellt für 9 Uhr und ich habe ihn jetzt für dich aktiviert.
Stell den Wecker für 9 aus.
Gut, der Wecker für 9 Uhr ist aus.
Das funktioniert echt gut. So Wecker stellen, rauskriegen, wie spät es ist.
Und jetzt haben wir ja Halloween. Hier klingelt es schon an der Tür. Kannst du jetzt auch einen Halloween-Witz machen?
Knock-knock? Können wir mal auf Englisch umstellen. Englisch, glaube ich, will sie nicht besser als Deutsch.
Entschuldigung, ich verstehe.
Wir machen ja mal Englisch.
Was sagt man denn bei Halloween immer, dass man irgendwie Trick or Treat oder sowas, ne?
Ich glaube, meine Freundin hat sich sofort mit Siri angelegt.
Was sagen die denn? Süßigkeiten oder Behandlung?
Süßes oder saures. Ich hatte vorhin schon zwei Mal irgendwelche Kinder da.
Sorry, Max, I can't look for places in Germany.
Aber die Stimme war im Deutschen eigentlich klarer als das hier gerade, oder? Das war so verrauscht. Die Qualität war nicht so gut.
Who I am isn't important.
Ja, die ist so...
Von wegen.
Nicht so kraftvoll, die ist so so verrauscht.
Das stimmt, aber ich finde es so ein bisschen... also die deutsche Stimme ist so so sehr Ding Ding Ding Ding, so wie man sich als Amerikaner Deutsch vorstellt.
Ja, auch wenn man sich als Deutscher Deutsch vorstellt, das ist ja auch so.
Aber es ist halt mit dieser Wolfram-Alpha-Integration viel geiler.
Ja, aber ich mach doch mal irgendwas Sinnvolles mit diesem Telefon. Ehrlich gesagt, mein Incentive, mir dieses Telefon zu kaufen, ist...
Singt gerade.
Nein, war noch nie sehr hoch. Also das Einzige, was mich an diesem Telefon interessiert ist, dass es schneller ist und dass es eine bessere Kamera hat. Aber ehrlich gesagt, mit meinem Computer reden, das verabscheu ich nach wie vor.
Das ist auch total bekloppt, weil du stehst nicht in der U-Bahn und quatschst in deinem Telefon.
Nee, in der U-Bahn macht man sowas vielleicht nicht. Wobei das ist, was echt cool ist, du kannst das so nehmen und mal gucken, ob es jetzt geht. Und dann hältst du es so ans Ohr. Und wenn dieses Log-Screen aktiviert ist, und mal gucken, ob es jetzt geht mit Kopfhörer drinnen, aber dann erkennt er, du kannst einstellen, dass er das erkennt, und dann geht er in Siri-Modus. Da brauchst du gar nichts mehr zu machen. Und dann sprichst du da die Nachricht rein, als ob nichts wäre. Und dann kannst du dich quasi so telefonisch mit Siri unterhalten. Und wofür ich es jetzt mal genutzt habe, ist so, um so auf dem Fahrrad mit einem Headset auf, was ich da eh immer die ganze Zeit aufhabe.
Der ist so schmatz. Drück die Schmatz-Tasse, wenn du schmatzst.
Weil ich da... Ja, ja.
Nehmen wir gleich die Süßigkeiten weg hier. Mach doch mal was Sinnvolles mit dir. Weiß ich nicht. Irgendwas Sinnvolles.
Was ist denn was Sinnvolles?
Ja, was weiß ich, was sinnvoll sein könnte damit? Ich verstehe das alles nicht. Brauche ich einen Regenschirm in Dresden? Ich meine, das kann ja wohl nicht die Antwort sein.
Okay, das ist die Frage, aber... Aber ein Bäckerstellen ist doch was Sinnvolles.
Ja, okay, gut, aber dafür muss man ja nicht Millionen Data Center hinstellen, damit wir irgendwie so einen scheiß Bäcker haben.
Stell einen Timer in 10 Minuten. T fertig. So, und das ist, dass es viel schneller, als ich jetzt in der App drin gewesen wäre, Timer gestellt hätte, Timer richtig eingestellt hätte. Und jetzt kann ich noch so einen kleinen Timer laufen.
Und fertig.
Timer abbrechen.
Der Timer wurde zurückgesetzt.
Damit er jetzt nicht in 10 Minuten drin, ja, plötzlich der Timer losgeht.
Warum nicht? Wahrscheinlich funktioniert's am Ende gar nicht.
Timer in einer Minute.
Ohne Begründung?
Okay, der Timer ist auf eine Minute eingestellt.
Und hätte er vorhin T fertig gesagt?
Ich hab bei Timer nicht, Timer hab ich bisher noch nie probiert. Erinnerung hab ich bisher immer gesagt. Dann setzt er so einen Reminder in der Reminder-App und dann sagt er auch, was fertig ist.
Genau.
Okay, aber ich meine irgendwann ist doch diese Phase, dass man vor seinem neu gekauften Gerät devot niederkniet und die ganze Zeit versucht, ihm irgendwas beizubringen mit 30 Versuchen, bis er es dann endlich mal versteht.
Vorbei.
Denkst du, dass dieser Punkt kommen wird, dass du das Ding einfach nur normal benutzt? So in deinem täglichen Leben und dass das dann deine first choice ist?
Nein, meine first choice wird das beziehungsweise Sicherheit sobald nicht werden. Ich meine, das ist ein touch of the face, das ist dem tausendmal überlegen. Aber in Situationen, in denen man einfach keinen Touch hat, aus welchem Grund auch immer, ist es... also es ist in einigen Stellen... Ich hab am Anfang war ich total entsetzt, wie schlecht die Spracherkennung ist, weil gerade so zum Nachrichtensenden oder sowas geht es nur so mittel. Aber ich hab jetzt schon so Sachen gemacht, also ich hab mich dabei erwischt. Also ich hab... ich wollte jemanden Nachricht schreiben. Oh, Timer geht. Siehst du, der Timer funktioniert. Und ich wollte jemanden Nachricht schreiben, dann hat man ja neben der Tastatur dieses kleine Fenster und dass ich die darauf eingesprochen habe, anstatt sie zu tippen, weil es schneller ging. Und da muss man zwar im Nachhinein noch was korrigieren, weil er hat nicht jedes Wort erkannt, aber ich hab das Gefühl, es geht deutlich schneller als das zu tippen. Und dann so Sachen wie einen Wecker stellen, Timer stellen. Also jetzt zur Erinnerung, erinnere, sag mir in 10 Minuten Bescheid, dass der Tee fertig ist. Ich hab jetzt in den letzten Tagen massenhaft Tee gemacht, da hab ich die ganze Zeit über gemacht. Weil es geht schneller als Homescreen, Clock, Timer stellen. Das dauert einfach länger. Es geht so schneller. Und dadurch, das finde ich, ist echt geil. Und ich glaube, es wird, also das ist noch lang nicht fertig. Das braucht noch Zeit. Aber das wird, ich glaube, ziemlich schnell ziemlich geil werden. Und wenn sie da, wenn sie hier Wolfram Alfer irgendwann reinkriegen und gerade diese witzigen Elemente, klar, die sind, die müssen sie am anderen irgendwie sein. Und ich glaube, die sind im Englischen tausendmal besser als im Deutschen. Gerade weil dann hin und wieder mal auch so ein Nerdwissen aus Wolfram Alfer reinkommt und so. Und dieses Yelp-Zeug und das Ganze. Aber ja, das ist halt, ich finde das...
Ja gut, timer maletwegen, timer wecker, timer wecker, timer wecker maletwegen.
Oder eine SMS schicken.
Ja, aber dann muss man doch wieder rein und korrigieren und...
Nee, das geht da gar nicht. Also das, finde ich, ist so ein bisschen das...
Das geht noch nicht mal.
Na ja, du kannst es halt so machen, du kannst halt über das normale Interface gehen und kannst halt...
In diese Diktator...
Also hast du hier diese Tastatur-Button auf der...
Dann mach mal.
Genau, also was weiß ich was, das hier. So, dann habe ich jetzt hier ja diesen kleinen Button und jetzt kann ja... Wir machen hier eine kleine Testnachricht mit dem Bye Mobile Max.
Das ist gut, wenn man ihn so sauberen, korrekten, schliffen in Deutsch anspricht.
So, und...
Was kam dabei raus?
Wir machen eine kleine Testnachricht mit den beiden Wo Bye Max. So, funktioniert...
Wo Bye Max.
Wo Bye Max, genau. Ihr kennt Mobile Max nicht, klar. Steve, ach ja, Tim.
Wo Bye Max. Aber, so, und dann gibt es halt dieses komplett getrennte Siri-Interface und das finde ich gerade, wenn man da irgendwie einen Fehler drin macht, habe ich zumindest noch keine Möglichkeit, also so Nachricht an Tim, okay, ich stelle einen neuen Nachricht an Tim Priplove. Ja, diese und diese Nachricht. Siri hat das falsch erkannt, liest mir nochmal vor, was es senden möchte und dann kommt halt dieses, ja, liest mir nochmal vor, ich habe einen Fehler gemacht, dann habe ich nicht die Möglichkeit zu sagen, korrigiere das dritte Wort oder irgendwie sowas oder korrigiere die ganze Nachricht meinetwegen, sprich die ganze Nachricht nochmal neu ein, sondern es ist halt, du musst da nochmal komplett von vorne anbrechen, zumindest das, was ich jetzt bisher rausgekriegt habe. Und das ist noch verbesserungswürdig, aber ich habe die paar Fälle, in denen ich es jetzt auch eingesetzt habe, es war halt so, ich habe auf dem Fahrrad gesessen, habe das Headset auf, drücke diese Taste ein bisschen länger, zum Beispiel du hast einen Termin, willst wissen, wie spät es ist, hast jetzt keine Lust, das Telefon rauszuholen, um die Uhr zu gucken, sagst dem Ding, wie spät es ist, und dann sagt sie die Zeit an. Oder, dass man da auch noch eine Nachricht, eine kurze sendet, und dass sie da nicht hundertprozentig richtig geschrieben ist, interessiert ja auch keine Sau. Also, wenn da mal ein Wort drin falsch getippt ist.
Damn, autocorrekt.
Da sind schon Leute umgebracht worden, weil da ein Buchstabe falsch war. Aber echt?
Also ich schicke meine Nachrichten nur an Leute, die mich nicht umbringen, wenn da mal ein Buchstabe falsch ist. Ansonsten bin ich schon lange tot.
Du schickst auch mir Nachrichten.
Ah, du tötest Menschen wegen falscher Buchstabe.
Na, komm mal ganz drauf an, was du mir so schreibst.
Ach so, okay. Erst töten, dann fragen.
Ist so Stiefelstorben? Na ja, wenn du irgend so ein Android-Thema einreichst hier und den falschen Ton triffst. So, das ist alles, oder was? Mehr kann man jetzt nicht demonstrieren. Gibt es da nicht irgendwas Tolles? Ich meine, ich bin nicht...
Ich versuche...
Machst du einfach selber hier.
Die Enttäuschung des Jahres 2011. Ja, was soll da jetzt groß kommen?
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Es ist halt ein bisschen schneller. Dafür ist es langsamer getaktet pro CPU. Dafür ist es der RAM-Speicher, aber... Na, der RAM-Speicher, der RAM. Die Megahertz-Rate doppelt so hoch.
Ja, der System wurde doppelt so schnell, ne?
Genau. Kann man sich das dann auch gleich vorlesen lassen?
Geht das eigentlich? Erst mal diese Textnachrichten, die du da reinsprichst.
Das kann man sich gar nicht vorlesen. Dann muss man hier...
Das hab ich noch nicht probiert.
Im Walde sitzt ein Auerhahn, der schaut mich ganz schön sauer an. Das stört mich nicht, weil ich jetzt penne. Und zwar auf seiner Auerhähne. Eine und zwar auf seiner Auerhenne. Nicht schlecht! Ein Wort falsch, aber das hat er sogar markiert. Warum markiert er das? Blau unterstrichen mit Pünktchen? Heißt das, dass er sich da nicht sicher war?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Drück doch mal drauf, dann kommt die Correction.
Tatsache. Und dann bietet er mir jetzt an Kenne.
Na, Penne gibt's halt nicht.
Na gut, aber immerhin ist er nur noch ein Buchstaben entfernt. Okay, also da muss ich wirklich sagen, diese Diktationsgeschichte, Diktierfunktion, die ja, die könnt's schon bringen.
Und die Diktierfunktion, ist die auch trotzdem noch online oder ist die lokal?
Ist alles online.
Das auch.
Da geht ohne, also ich hab's gemerkt, als ich unterwegs, also wenn ich die unterwegs benutze, wir können auch mal ein bisschen übers O2-Netz randet hier in letzter Zeit.
Was muss man hier drücken, damit dieser Siri aktiv wird?
Die Haupttaste lange drücken.
Ah, lange drücken. Ruf Tim an. Schemm an.
Welchen Kontakt möchtest du? Tim Friedloff oder 10 Basmann?
Jetzt musst du sagen Tim.
Ich bin nicht sicher, was du gerade gesagt hast.
Schreibt er.
Ja, ja, der schreibt. Sie schreibt das. Die merkt sich ja auch so. Die merkt sich ja auch. Also ich weiß jetzt zum Beispiel, ich kann jetzt so was sagen, ruf Mama an.
Ruf den Friedloff an.
Ich finde Tilo Olmar nicht in deinen Kontakten.
Nein, ich meine nicht Tilo. Dummendos.
Ich glaub, schimpfen geht auch.
Ich finde, du bist ne dumme Sau.
Echt?
Ist aber hier nicht mit dem Fragezeichen, sondern mit dem Aus-Er-Zeichen. Also sie haben sich schon so einiges eingestellt hier.
Also was man mitkriegt, Diana hat gefragt, kannst du mir irgendein Rezept mit Blumenkohl empfehlen? Und dann hat sie dann immerhin gesagt, ich kenne noch keine Rezepte. Oder ich kenne keine Rezepte. Was darauf hindeutet, dass sie sowas irgendwann mal vorhaben demnächst. Vermute ich mal. Weil man kriegt so mit an so ein paar Stellen, weiß die Technik schon mehr als man.
Was soll ich mit meinem Leben anfangen?
Und was soll ich mit meinem Leben anfangen?
Nicht.
Na du willst mir helfen, ja? Naja, super. Okay. Ansonsten, wie ist das Telefon sonst so?
Schneller? Also es ist jetzt nicht... Ja, es ist schneller. Es ist jetzt nicht, dass das iPhone 4 langsamer wäre, aber das ist schneller.
Wie, das andere ist nicht langsamer?
Ich finde das iPhone 4 dann schön langsam.
Nee, hab ich nicht drauf. Das ist wie ein 100 Megabyte, das dauert.
Ich muss viel zu lange warten auf alles auf meinem iPhone 4. Also mein iPhone 4 kommt mir nicht... Ich nehm die Dinger da gleich weg.
Hast du schon? Der lag da noch.
Geht Pixi da denn? Ich weiß nicht, hast du irgendeine...
So Benchmarks? Nö. Die Kamera macht... Ich hab das jetzt irgendwie seit, seit wann hab ich das? Letzten Montag und ab Mittwoch war ich da nicht mehr bewegungsfähig größtenteils. Es ist genau das, was beworben wird. Es ist schneller, die Kamera ist besser. Der Vibrationsmotor ist offensichtlich ein anderer.
Ja, hab ich auch gelesen.
Also er vibriert zumindest deutlich anders. Er vibriert leiser, aber dabei schneller. Hab ich das Gefühl.
Kannst du den mal vibrieren lassen.
Ich hab den mal vibrieren lassen. Ich glaub's doch nicht nur neu, Abi, dass die Programmierer jetzt besser einstellen können, wie sie es vibriert haben möchten.
Was kann ich lauter. Mach doch einfach den Buzzer, den Rington-Schalter an und aus, dann vibriert er doch kurz.
Ja und das so beim iPhone 4, das ist ein schön... Das rasselt ganz ordentlich.
Wie ist die Batterielaufzeit?
Batterielaufzeit, würde ich sagen, ist ungefähr so gut wie beim Alten. Also hab ich jetzt auch noch, ich hab jetzt keine Benchmarks gemacht. Ich hab's laufen lassen, es hat irgendwie jetzt immer drei Tage am Stück durchgehalten. Aber das war halt, weil ich in der Wohnung gesessen habe und nur geschlafen habe. Und jetzt Empfang kann ich noch gar nichts zu sagen. Habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass er irgendwie... Achso, also was definitiv nicht mehr geht, wenn man es hier an dieser Stelle zu hält, an das alte zu halten, muss man, damit der Empfang schlechter wurde, das klappt nicht mehr. Also entweder detekten sie jetzt und zeigen die einfach die alten Balken hier an, oder...
Da nützt ja nichts, wenn der Empfang weg ist, dann nützt er auch die Balken und nichts mehr.
Ja eben, aber das muss jetzt auch mehr so ein Witz sein, aber das Gefühl hab ich, dass das irgendwie alles... Achso, was ich noch ein Gefühl hab, und zwar diese Lippe hier, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das diese Gummi-Lippe, die hier an der Seite von dem Display lang geht. Das Display rum ist doch so eine Plastik-Gummi-Lippe. Was? Hier um die Glasscheibe außen. Was? Da ist doch am Rand auch so eine kleine Lippe. Natürlich hier.
Das ist doch keine Lippe.
Natürlich hier. Das ist doch so ein kleiner Absatz direkt um die Glasscheibe drum rum.
Gummi-Lippe.
Na ja, oder Plastik oder was auch immer. Das ist doch nicht die Seite von dem Glas.
Na klar.
Das ist doch steil hart.
Da ist noch mal irgendein Kunststoff drum rum.
Ach so, ja okay, da ist nicht das Glas, da ist noch irgendwas.
Aber das ist keine Gummi, das ist doch hart voll. Was auch immer das ist. Aber auf jeden Fall hab ich das Gefühl, dass das jetzt ein bisschen übersteht. Ich weiß nicht, ob das vielleicht dann... Zeig mal. Was ich vermuten kann, wenn es runterfällt, dass das dann sozusagen als erstes auf die Plastik fällt und nicht gleich aufs Glas, dass das nochmal ein bisschen Bruchssicherheit schafft. Also sie haben total einen Kleinkram natürlich.
Ich glaub, man sieht das bei dem Weiß. Hattest du vorher auch ein Weißes?
Nee, vorher hatte ich ein Schwarzes.
Ich glaub, man sieht es einfach nur besser.
Na, ist mir so aufgefallen, beim Mittag...
Hinten oder vorne?
Auf beiden Seiten.
Also hier hinten hätt ich hier...
Also ich könnte schwören, dass wenn du dir Augen zumachst und ich geb dir beide, du könntest das nicht unterscheiden.
Zeig mal.
Fühl mal. Da ist auch schon so eine Kante.
Experimente im Dunkeln.
Ja, so ein bisschen ist es schon da. Ich hab...
Wir fingern hier gerade an den iPhones rum.
Und ich find das Weiße sehr schick. Ich war ja am Anfang...
Ich find das gar nicht schick.
Ich find das sehr schick. Ich war am Anfang so...
Ich hab so gut...
Ah ja, ich nehm Weißes. Wurde bei uns im Büro umgefragt, wer welche Farbe haben will. Und hatte dann so überlegt, ob ich's bereue. Und ich mag das sehr gerne.
Ich find, die hätten auch mal bunte iPhones rausbringen können. Ich hab langsam die Schnauze voll von Schwarz und Weiß.
Welche Farbe setzt du gerne? Rosa? Orange.
Ja, ich weiß, die Piraten haben mir die Farbe kaputt gemacht. Aber ich lass mir von den Piraten meine Farben nicht kaputt machen. Und ich find ja Orange irgendwie ganz cool. Dieses Neongrün ist ein bisschen... Also wie diese Bumper-Farben. Das Neongrün ist mir ein bisschen zu heftig. So'n Knallrot haben sie ja nicht. Würde ich auch noch ganz cool finden.
Orange ist ja gerade rausgeflogen bei den iPad-Cases, ne? Da ist Orange rausgeflogen.
Revolutionär. Ich hab wieder mal gemerkt, ich bin gar kein Early Adopter manchmal.
Ich soll ja auch mehr, aber wir sind raus.
Ich hab mal so drüber nachgedacht, es gibt verdammt wenig Apple-Produkte, die ich unbedingt sofort haben musste in den letzten Jahren.
Doch, hier meinen.
Und wenn ich es mal gemacht hab, dann bin ich meistens immer so ein bisschen...
Meistens immer.
Immer irgendwo gegen...
Also das iPhone 4 muss ich unbedingt haben. Das war irgendwie cool, es sah total schick aus, es sieht bis heute immer noch schick aus. Es sieht bis heute gut aus. Und zeitlos, würde ich mal sagen.
Zeitlos schick.
Was ich natürlich immer leicht sagen muss, weil das 3S war wahrscheinlich auch schon zeitlos schick, weil, keine Ahnung.
Das 3GS fand ich nie zeitlos schick. Das erste fand ich richtig schick, und das zweite fand ich einen Rückschritt. Und das 4er, das 4er ist wieder ein Fortschritt gewesen.
Dieses Runde fand ich immer nicht so cool. Ich fand das iPhone 4 so geil, weil es eben nicht mehr so rund ist. Ja, und mein Quadcore hier wollte ich auch unbedingt haben. Und ja, war fällig und toll. Aber sonst unbedingt sofort haben.
Na, ich hab jetzt zum Beispiel ein iPod erst 2005 gekauft.
Ja, ich auch erst 2003 oder 2002.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich mir gekauft hab. Da hatte ich allerdings lange an irgendeinem Projekt gearbeitet. Ziemlich viel Geld plötzlich auf dem Konto und wollte mir irgendwas schickes kaufen. Dann hab ich mir so ein iPod 20 GB gekauft, wusste nicht, was ich damit anstellen sollte. Aber war sehr geil.
War sehr geil, ja.
Hab ich dann auch überall mit hingenommen. Der Chat meint, ich soll ein bisschen über O2 ranten.
O2, da bin ich aber sofort mit dabei. Wir hätten nie anfangen sollen, eine iPhones verkaufen zu können.
Das ist echt krass, oder?
Also seitdem ist das Netz eigentlich nicht mehr zuverlässig.
Das ist nicht mehr nicht zuverlässig. Ich bin am Sonnenabend, weil ich einkaufen, da vorne irgendwie hier quasi, wie heißt denn der Platz? Egal, einmal quer durch den Prenzlberg durch. Meine Freundin hat mir da eine iMessage geschickt und die ist angekommen, als wir in unsere Wohnung gekommen sind, weil wir da wieder WLAN hatten. Wir hatten auf der ganzen Strecke war das Netz so scheiße, dass man nicht einmal eine Verbindung hatte, bei der so eine dämliche iMessage durchgegangen ist. Am Sonntag genau das gleiche. Ich war am Sonntag, war mal frühstücken morgens, wir waren im Reichstag einen halben Tag. Ich hatte nicht einmal Empfang.
Also du hattest gar keinen Empfang?
Ich hatte keine Daten. Ich hatte die ganze Zeit vollen Empfang.
Aber keine Daten. Das ist wirklich ein Problem. Und ich frage mich, was sie da tun. Ich frage mich, ob sie überhaupt noch was tun.
Ich habe das Gefühl, man rennt so gegen, da gibt es diesen Twitter-Account, diesen o2.de, wo ich dann irgendwie so, also ich habe dann irgendwie so, O2, wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ihr in Gesamtberlin heute überhaupt keinen Empfang hattet? Oder im Gesamtländer ab, ne? Im Prenzlauer Berg. Und ich habe das getwittert und ich habe bestimmt 10 Replies gekriegt. Ja, in Mitte nicht, in Friedrichshain auch nicht. In Köpenick war gestern kein Empfang. Und dann kriegst du irgendwann, zwei Tage später, kriegst du von o2.de eine Antwort von diesem Account. Ja, das muss an deinen Einstellungen liegen. Wende dich doch mal den Kundensupport. Und ich natürlich frage so, wieso ist dieser Twitter-Account? Ist das nicht Kundenservice?
Oder ist das Presseabteilung?
Ich kann ja keinen Support machen per Twitter.
Warum nicht?
In Wien, mit 100.000 Leuten, die da mitlesen?
Nein, sagen sie, ich followe denen, sollen sie mir eine DM schicken.
Da stehe ich ja richtig drauf, wenn mir Firmen sagen, meine Einstellung stimmt nicht. Ja, vor allen Dingen, meine Einstellung ist völlig in Ordnung. Aber meine Settings sind natürlich viel abseits.
Also ich spiele jetzt mal das Teufels Anwalt an. Ich muss ja schon sagen, bei den meisten ist es wahrscheinlich wirklich so, dass die Einstellungen nicht stimmen, oder?
Ja, Moment mal, aber es ist... Also die soll man nicht so tun. Ich hab zwei SIM-Karten, meine Freundin hat zwei SIM-Karten, wir haben beide keinen Empfang. Dass O2 mittlerweile ein katastrophales Netz hat, das hat sich mittlerweile auch rumgesprochen. Und dann so zu tun, als ob nur irgendwie meine Einstellungen oder Settings im Arsch seien. Also ich bin jetzt, ich hab jetzt...
Aber du hast wahrscheinlich gerade auf dein neues Telefon migriert. Hattest du überhaupt schon mal bei O2-Netz? Vielleicht musst du wirklich deine Einstellnummer setzen.
Jaja, ich hatte schon bei O2-Netz.
Mit dem neuen Telefon?
Jaja, klar.
Hast du denn die tolle O2-Mehr-Netz-Applikation installiert auf deinem iPhone?
Ich wollte die mal runterladen, aber da hatte ich kein Netz. Haha, ist wirklich so.
Das ist ja auch die Software, die man mit dem O2-Mehr-Netz installiert hat.
Ich meine, O2, die waren wirklich... Die hatten mal ein gutes Netz. Ich finde, deren Verträge, die zwingen mich nicht dazu, irgendwie hier zwei Jahresverträge abzuschließen und die behaupten nicht, dass Skype oder vielleicht ist ja, weil alle Jabbas nutzen die ganze Zeit über, vielleicht ist ja deren Netz deswegen so überlastet. Sie sind die einzigen, die es erlauben, dass man Java benutzen kann. Das Einzige mit überlastetem Netz. Ich finde, ich hab bei O2 eigentlich immer...
Sie sind die Einzigen, die man Java erlauben.
Du hast bei allen anderen, wenn du hier Java und Chat... Nee, da steht ein Kleingedruckten drin, dass du es nicht darfst.
Ja, aber es geht.
Bei der Telekom gibt es eine Option, du kannst dir für 5 Euro dazu buchen, dann darfst du es. Die setzen eine Checkbox und buchen dir 5 Euro mehr von Konto ab. Das ist alles, was sie machen. Und darum finde ich O2 eigentlich sehr sympathisch, aber wenn sie sehr sympathisch keine Daten über ihr Netz kriegen, dann hilft mir das nicht weiter. Darum bin ich jetzt gerade aktiv auf der Suche nach einem neuen Provider. Und ich fürchte, ich vermute mal, es wird die Telekom werden.
Ernsthaft?
Ja. Also E+, ich glaube, da kommst du vom Regen in die Traufe?
Ja, da kommst du nicht nur in die Traufe, da wirst du ertränkt.
Vodafone, also von Telekom und Vodafone, wer ist dir da der sympathischere?
Telekom.
Also ich meine, da hat man keine Möglichkeit mehr.
Nö, also ich könnte das auch voll verstehen. Ich meine, ich hab jetzt hier auch irgendwie auch geschmeidige DSL-Experience, also man kann ja gegen Telekom sagen, was man will, aber wir haben zumindest immer noch so ein paar Techniker, die was verstehen von ihr Art. Hab ich so den Eindruck. Na ja, mal gucken, wie sich das so entwickelt. Gibt es sonst noch was zu sagen zum 4S?
Schönes Gerät.
Ich hab's ja nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich glaube, man kann das auch sehr entspannt aussetzen. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Die Kamera ist viel besser. Die Kamera ist auch schneller, wobei... Also, die war ja auf dem iPhone 4 teilweise... Manchmal war sie schnell oder okay schnell und manchmal war sie unerträglich langsam. Und diese unerträglich langsam Momente, die hatte ich bisher noch nicht. Wobei jetzt nach einer Woche, jetzt hab ich auch nicht irreviel telefoniert, weiß man das natürlich nicht. Ich hab gelesen, oh mein Gott, ist die Kamera plötzlich schnell? Das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Sie ist nicht, oh mein Gott, ist die schnell. Sie ist schnell und könnte eigentlich ruhig noch ein bisschen schneller sein. Also das ist jetzt, was weiß ich, was ich starte. Drücke jetzt auf die App und jetzt kann ich fotografieren.
Wo hast du das eigentlich gekauft?
Bei Apple haben wir das bestellt.
So online? Hast du dir nicht so eine schöne Store-Experience gegeben mit Gekreisch und Geklatsche?
Nee, das ist ja Firmen-Handy, das ist ja gar nicht meins. Das ist ja mein neuer Job.
Aber es wurde ja wieder geklatscht und geschrien, ne?
Zu Recht?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich hatte ja neulich diese schöne Mail vorgelesen, so meinte, na ja, hier ist Store-Öffnung. Man bereitet sich da ewig vor und mental aufgeladen und Pipapo geschenkt. Ja, meinetwegen, akzeptiere ich. Aber dann heißt es ja nicht, dass sie jetzt bei jedem neuen Produkt gleich wieder durchdrehen müssen, nur weil sie ein paar iPhone 4S ins Regal eingeräumt haben. Es kann ja jetzt nicht so eine Out-of-Body-Experience sein, da so ein Regal zu bestücken.
Oder? Die haben noch nichts zu tun. Ich meine, sie brauchen die Dinger ja gar nicht erst ins Regal einzuräumen, weil sie ja sowieso direkt weggehen.
Wenn ich zu so Apple Store gehe und die schreien da jeden an oder bejubeln die und machen da einen auf Weisig nicht, ich glaube, Pick würde wieder auf Caret machen.
Ich würde sofort, ich würde aber wirklich echt auf den Fersen einfach umdrehen und gleich wieder weg und dann hier nebenan in irgendein Polo-Löcker.
Dann doch wieder online lieber.
Das ist einfach so aus Protest. Irgendwie ein Nokia-Telefon kaufen oder so. Da seht ihr ja, was ihr davon habt.
Kauft ihr auch so ein schönes Nokia, Luria, Lulu, Lumi... Oder was?
Lumi...
Lumi... Lumi... Das ist ein spanisches Wort für Prostituierte sein.
Hey, und das beschreibt nur Kias aktuelle Position sehr gut.
Ja, auf Spanisch heißt das eigentlich was anderes.
Es ist ja auch nicht so im Standard. Es kommt darauf an, wen du da fragst in der Gegend. Das ist in dem Umgangssprache, deswegen ist es wohl nirgends so richtig vorgekommen, sonst hätten die das ja gemerkt und nicht genommen, das Wort. Aber irgendwo war da so ein Artikel. Was ich aber nebenbei noch erzählen kann, weil wir gerade...
Bin ich hier laut genug?
Oh ja, besser. Ich hab nämlich hier... Bei Hi! sagt man es schon gesehen, dass die wieder ihre Technik-CD haben, also ihre Bastel-CT. Und bei Spiegel war ja dann auch nochmal der Artikel, wie man halt so eine Linse aus einem DVD-Laufwerk irgendwie rausbauen kann. Und dann muss man halt so einen DVD-Laufwerk schlachten. Und dann macht man diese kleine Linse hier auf das iPhone drauf. Man legt die so drauf und klebt die irgendwie so fest, wie man auch immer das macht. Und dann kann man voll schicke Makroaufnahmen machen. Hab ich mal gemacht gestern und funktioniert voll super. Und kann ich mir eben empfehlen, Kamera ein bisschen rumspielen.
Wollen wir mal die Makro-Kameras nebeneinander halten? Weil das hab ich das Gefühl, die ist echt besser geworden.
Na, ich hab jetzt aber diese Makro-Linse nicht dabei.
Ah nee, aber einfach mal vom iPhone 4 und vom iPhone 4S. Weil das hab ich nämlich das Gefühl...
Aber da muss ich noch kurz dazu sagen, mit dieser Makro-Linse, die man bei so einem DVD-Laufwerk ausbaut, da kannst du wirklich mit der iPhone-Linse bis auf einen Zentimeter an dein Objekt ran. Also bist du wirklich verdammt nah dran. So, was willst du jetzt testen? Wie weit man irgendwie hier...
Also ich hab mit der hier immer so ein bisschen, mit der Makro-Kamera hab ich mal so ein bisschen rumgespielt.
Na guck mal, mehr als so 5 cm oder 8 oder so gehen doch nicht, oder? Oder geht bei dir mehr?
Also, mal gucken...
Wenn ich mehr mache, dann wird es unscharf.
Auf dem Display ist es ja auch immer noch eine andere Nummer.
Ich kann noch ein bisschen heller machen hier. Dann kann er sich da besser einstellen.
Also ich hab hier so, was weiß ich, was Tasten fotografiert zum Beispiel von der Tastatur. Und da muss ich so... wie weit bin ich jetzt ungefähr weg? Jetzt würde ich sagen, es ist scharf. Na, jetzt gerade nicht. Die Linse ist wahrscheinlich wieder verdreckt.
Ja, aber man ist schon noch... wo ist das Ding? Also 5 cm ist man schon noch weg. Und das kann man halt, wie gesagt, mit so einer Linse aus einem DVD-Laufwerk, kannst du das noch irgendwie... kommt auf die Linse an wahrscheinlich, aber...
Aber ich hab auf jeden Fall...
Bis auf einen Zentimeter rangehen, und das ist schon echt cool.
Ich hab auf jeden Fall das Gefühl, dass die Makrofunktion vom iPhone 4S doch um einiges besser ist als...
Ja, da ist ja auch wirklich eine viel bessere Linse jetzt bei dem 4S.
Sehen tut man es nicht, wenn man drauf guckt.
Hat sich echt optisch nichts geändert.
Also hier drinnen der eigentliche Linsenbereich, ich glaube der ist etwas größer geworden.
Ja, ich hab jetzt... Ich leuchte mal Licht, um mal genau rein zu gucken.
Das kann man ja dann vielleicht später nochmal nachholen.
Sieht aber eigentlich schon wirklich auch gleich aus. Nö, da hat sich nichts geändert eigentlich.
Die haben in der Präsentation gesagt, dass das alles neu ist.
Ja, haben die gesagt.
Das ist auch neu.
Oh, wer hat hier?
Was? Wer hat hier GSM?
Wer hat hier GSM an?
Ich könnte es sein. Ich mach mich mal aus. Weiß. Sieht so aus. Ja, wollen wir trotzdem noch über diese Nokia-Telefone ein Wort verlieren? Also, ich meine, es gibt dir nicht viel zu sagen, weil es ist ja alles nur wieder angekündigt.
Also, was habt ihr denn gelesen von diesen Dingern? Nur das, was bei Spiegel stand oder noch von woanders?
Also, ich hab ein Video-Review von dem N9, heißt das, glaube ich, von diesem einzigen Memo.
Das ist ja das selbe Telefon.
Genau. Also, davon hab ich mir von dieser Software ein Video angeguckt und die hat der, man konnte fast hören, wie der Sprecher heult, weil dieses Betriebssystem nicht mehr weiterentwickelt wird. Also, es soll wohl ziemlich flüssig oder sehr flüssig laufen, gut zu bedienen sein, sieht hübsch aus, dieses Myemo Zeug. Also klar, wenn es jetzt das erste ihrer Art wäre, dann müsste es sich an den Markt beweisen. Dieses Telefon wird sich niemals auf den Markt beweisen müssen, dann würde es sicherlich ganz anders aussehen. Aber technisch scheint dieses Betriebssystem ziemlich geil zu sein. Migo? Ich weiß nicht, wie das jetzt heißt.
Das, was jetzt nicht mehr rausbringt.
Das, was nicht mehr rausbringt.
Na, das kann jetzt jeder sagen.
Und zu den anderen, ich fand es sieht echt, ich finde dieses N-Luma-Lumio-Lumio 800, das sieht schick aus. Es hat ein paar sehr geile Features. Also das hat zum Beispiel dieses, die haben ja dieses OLED-Display und die können dir zum Beispiel Zeit auch anzeigen, wenn das Display aus ist. Das finde ich ist echt cool.
Das ist in der Tat ein Feature.
Ja, aber das OLED hat doch wieder andere Probleme da.
Das ist klar, von der Farbwiedergabe her nicht so schön wie so ein richtiges...
Aber es hat auch so eine Vorteile, also man kann ja mal erwähnen. Und ich finde das Gerät an sich, finde ich, sehr schick. Ich finde, das hat oben so eine, das finde ich nicht so toll, dass es so eine Klappe hat, also wo man dann so, was dahinter, wo der USB-Anschluss hinter ist.
Eine Klappe.
Naja, so ein Fitzelchen, was abreißt und was da. Aber darüber hinaus, geht auch immer so auf, das ist mein Next oder irgendwie sowas, die haben auch dann immer so ganze Fotosälen, so bei Nokia siehst du auch nichts, auf der Seite.
Aber was war deren Hauptwerbespruch irgendwie, was sie meinten, sie haben jetzt irgendwie auf die Features jetzt mal so ein bisschen verzichtet und versuchen sie jetzt über das Design, ja? Weil sie meinen, dass Apple das ja auch so macht, weil Apple ja Features immer irgendwie sparsam wäre und mehr so aufs Design setzt. Aber es ist doch genau das, was Nokia bisher noch nie konnte eigentlich, oder? Und so sieht es auch aus.
Ich finde, das ist ein extrem schickes Telefon, finde ich.
Das sieht nicht scheiße aus.
Vor allem ist es Plastik, ne? Also es ist ja kein schickes Alubrush-Tralala, sondern es ist irgendwie Plastik.
Das stimmt, aber es ist wohl sehr angenehmes Plastik. Also kann ich nur dann sagen, was die... Oh, sieht's immer noch schick aus? Aber es ist nicht z.B. lackiert, es ist durchgefärbt, sodass wenn es runter schmeißt und eine Schramme drin hast, dann färbt es nicht ab. Na ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das so selbstverständlich ist bei diesen ganzen Dingern. Wo der Linsenteil drin ist, finde ich, hätte das durchaus fast von Apple sein können, ohne mich jetzt zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen zu wollen.
Ja, gewölbtes Glas. Warum ist denn das Glas gewölbt?
Weil es jetzt gewölbt sein muss.
Und die Tasse ist auf der rechten Seite. Und was macht die Tasse da unten? Wie soll ich denn da rankommen?
Das ist die Kameraauslöser-Tasse. Da brauchst du sogar nicht ranzukommen, wie das jetzt hältst. Da willst du nur rankommen, wenn du es so schräg hältst. Und dann hier, das ist gut. Und ich finde die Linse in der Mitte, das finde ich beim iPhone nämlich mittlerweile sehr nervig. Diese Kameralinse am Rand, eine Linse in der Mitte, macht total Sinn. Das ist... Weil ansonsten hält man ständig die Hand da vor oder kriegt sein Ziel... Also gerade bei Makroaufnahmen, wenn man so ein bisschen näher rangeht, du siehst halt... Du hältst es immer irgendwie falsch mit das iPhone. Und ich glaube, das geht bei so einem in der Mitte gelagerten, bei so einer Linse wesentlich besser.
Das stimmt. Das ist ein echtes Argument. Da fragt man sich, warum... Warum Apple das da an diese Stelle gepackt hat. Ist ja überhaupt ein guter Grund für. Außer, dass es jetzt einfach mal ihr Layout ist.
Wahrscheinlich wie es von internen Hardware aussieht, oder?
Ja, in der Mitte ist halt einfach alles Akku.
Genau, damit sie nicht mit dem Akku ein Loch einbohren müssen.
Na ja gut, aber ich meine, solche Zwänge sind ja nicht entscheidend. Wenn Apple immer von technischen Zwängen ausgehen würde, dann würden sie ja nirgendswo hinkommen.
Also ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab mir ein paar mal Gedanken darüber gemacht. Es gab ja auch mal Gerüchte, dass das Kamera, Licht und die Linse auseinander wandern, weiter voneinander entfernt sind. Was ich finde, was auch Sinn gemacht hätte. Weil da nämlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das Licht direkt wieder in deine Linse einstreut, was das Kameralicht macht, reduziert ist. Also ich glaube, da ist noch Potenzial drin, was so die Kamera angeht.
iPhone 5 dann, nächstes Jahr, wieder dabei.
Luneo, naja, aber ich meine...
Also ich hab so ein paar, die Reviews waren ja alle, oh mein Gott, wie toll.
Aber es hat doch jetzt noch keiner mit Windows-Phone in der Hand gehabt, oder doch?
Na doch, die haben das bei der Präsentation in der Hand gehabt. Ja, das Windows-Phone läuft da halt drauf. Das läuft flüssig und das läuft gut und das funktioniert.
Das Windows-OS gibt es jetzt auch schon wieder seit einem Jahr, oder?
Jaja, da gibt es jetzt auch schon dieses Mango, dieses Nachfolgeding mit Multitasking.
Ja, aber es gibt ja dieses Telefon jetzt auch. Ich meine, wir reden jetzt schon wieder über etwas, was es nicht gibt. Ja, es ist angekündigt und es soll im Dezember kommen.
Ja, es ist der iPhone-Killer jetzt.
Im Dezember. Ich glaube, wir haben mich zu viel komprimiert, kann das sein? Ich muss mal hier Kompression rausnehmen. Im Dezember in Europa und in den USA, Anfang nächsten Jahres.
Da noch später.
Ja.
Wir wollen erst mal gucken, ob sie überhaupt in Europa eine Chance hat und dann in Amerika vielleicht gar nicht erst rausbringen.
Na gut, ich meine, Nokia ist in den USA unbekannt. Also die sind da einfach überhaupt nicht vertreten. Die haben da keinen nennenswerten Markt.
Was kaufen die Leute in den USA alle? Moto, Ola und iPhones.
Blackberry.
Die.
Samsung und Tralala und LG und eigentlich alles Mögliche. Nur Nokia hat da eigentlich einen schlechten Stand schon seit Ewigkeiten.
Also bei dem Ding muss ich mal, ich hab eine Kritik heute gelesen und das wird ja von den Tech-Blocks gerne mal ausgelassen, das Ding kostet ohne Vertrag 500 Euro. Und das ist mein ganz schöner Batzen für ein bisschen hübscher Hardware.
Für wie viel Speicher?
Ich glaube die kleinste, wie viel hat das? Wie viel hat denn das? Das ist nicht doll. Also das ist ein sehr, sehr teures Telefon dafür. Das mag qualitativ hochwertig sein. Aber darüber hinaus, mal gucken.
Hier kann man nur mit Vertragsdauer 24...
16 GB. Da gibt es keinen Unlocked?
Das gibt es nicht bei nokia.de. Hier gibt es nur so 24-Monat-Tarife. Das kann man natürlich nicht vergleichen, den Preis.
Nee, also ich hab die offiziellen Preise, der offizielle Preis bei der Telekom, ohne Vertrag, ist 499 Euro dafür. Das ist schon nicht wenig Geld.
Na gut, aber ein iPhone ohne...
Geht bei 629 los.
629.
Ja, dafür hast du aber ein iPhone.
Ja, dafür hast du ein iPhone. Ich würde auch sagen, dafür hast du ein Windows Phone.
Na ja, Windows Phones kannst du aber auch bei HTC haben.
Aber es ist ja jedes Lunio 800, es gibt ja auch noch so ein 710, so eine beschnittene Version.
Genau.
Wobei ich sagen muss, wie kann man auch im Jahre 2011 immer noch mit so komischen Zahlen daherkommen? Ich meine 710.
Vor allem, warum mit der 710 anfangen? Warum nicht mit der 700 anfangen?
Ja, warum heißt es nicht Lumio 1?
Warum wir überhaupt zwei Telefonen auf einer Veranstaltung vorstellen? Ich sage, wir fangen erst mal mit einer an und schicken die andere und das andere leise nach.
Ich weiß nicht, was ist denn mit diesem Lumio, Lunio 110? Lumia.
Das ist deutlich billiger, ist technisch jetzt nicht großartig anders.
Lumia, das geht überhaupt nicht von der Zunge. Lumia, kann ich mal da ein Lumia haben?
Ja, das sagt man ja auch nicht.
Ja, aber es heißt doch so.
Man, das sagt doch eh keiner.
Wie sagt keiner? Wie nennst du denn dein iPhone?
Mein iPhone nenne ich iPhone oder Telefon, aber Nokia-Geräte nenne ich nicht.
Was ist das aktuelle Windows Phone, was gerade so verkauft wird?
Na, das ist es.
Nee, das kommt ja erst raus. Ja, aber dieses Windows-OS gibt es doch seit letztem Jahr. Da musst du als Telefoner gehen, wo das Windows-OS da drauf ist.
Ja, von HTC zum Beispiel. Kannst du mal zu htc.de gehen.
HTC, Ho Chi Minh, tra la la.
Und gibt es da denn schon Leute, die sowas haben?
Ich hab eins zu Hause.
Ich hab eins zu Hause, ja.
iPhone 4S mal nicht geht oder was?
Nein, das muss ich mal in die Telekom zugeschicken. Vergessen zurückzuschicken. Das ist so ein Testgerät und das hab ich. Und das ist, warte mal, musste irgendwie alle Produkte. Gehen wir nicht auf beliebte, weil beliebt ist das nicht.
Also wenn ich Leute sehe, die kein iPhone haben, dann haben die alle ein Android.
Niemand hat einen.
Guck mal, es gibt hier Telefone bei HTC, alle, Touchscreen als zweite Kategorie, die dritte Kategorie heißt Touch und Taste.
Taste.
Genau.
Touch und Taste. Ich dachte Touch und Taste, dachte man, da könnte man dann auch noch dran lecken, ja.
Ich glaub, das ist kein beliebtes HTC-Telefon, dieses Chacha. Guck mal, da kannst du Betriebssystem auswählen. Genau, das HTC Zahn, ich glaube, das ist das aktuelle.
Und Radar.
Und was ich da noch rumfliegen habe, das ist das Mozart. Falls das überhaupt noch auf der Seite existiert.
So, diese Telefone machen ja genau den gleichen Fehler wie diese Android-Telefone am Anfang. Da gibt es eine Windows-Taste drauf. Und so eine Suchtaste und so eine Back-Taste. Das halte ich ja schon mal für den größten Quatsch und Schwachsinn überhaupt. Aber das scheint ja beim Lunion nicht so zu sein.
Doch, die haben eine Windows-Taste haben die alle. Klar. Du weißt, das geht mit deiner Firma ab, wenn plötzlich eine Windows-Taste drauf ist.
Wo war denn der wieder? Da ist noch mal ein Touchscreen.
Da ist eine...
Lumia heißt das, Mann.
Ich sag Lunio. Ich find das viel schöner. Lunio klingt viel schöner.
Da ist eine Windows-Taste drauf.
Wo ist da eine Windows-Taste? Und das ist wirklich... außerhalb des Screens?
Jaja, die dreht sich mit, wenn er so dreht. Also das ist bei den HTC-Dingern. Ich weiß nicht, ob es bei dem auch so ist. Wenn das Display dreht, dann ist da irgendwie so die Technik, der Lichteffekt so hintergelegt, dass sich dann auch die Taste quasi mit dreht.
Wie die Taste dreht sich mit?
Naja, wenn es auf die Seite dreht, dann dreht sich die Lupe, dann ist die wieder so perspektivisch korrekt sozusagen.
Aber sie ist immer noch an der selben Stelle.
Sie ist immer noch an der selben Stelle, ja.
Nein.
Doch.
Was ist das an der Stelle? Also worum handelt es sich?
Naja, LED, vermute ich. Also es ist so kapazitativ, blöd, also es ist quasi das Äquivalent zu einer Taste.
Bei meint einer dreht sich nicht mit.
Dreht sich nicht mit? Bei welchen Warners, wo sich das mitgedreht hat? Ich glaub, das war bei meinem Seil.
Da hast du ja so ein rotierendes Windows-Logo dann auch noch oder was, so ein Propeller.
Nee, so, mann, das dreht sich einfach mit.
Es rotiert nicht.
Skipp, skipp, skipp hier, wir müssen mal wieder über Max reden.
Das ist doch totaler Quatsch. Suchentasten, Backtasten, so ein Blödsinn. Backtasten sind überhaupt der, also das ist der, da fällt mir nichts zu ein.
Achso, eine Sache muss ich mal richtig stellen aus der letzten Sendung, die wir hier behauptet haben. Da haben wir ja über dieses Video geredet bei diesem Samsung Galaxy, Samsung Nexus.
Was, was, was kommt jetzt hier ein, machen wir jetzt Erata oder was?
Ja, weil es mir gerade einfällt.
Echt, ich glaube das machen nur die Fanboys. Die Fanboys geben immer alle Fehler zu. Sowas würden wir doch niemals tun.
Bei uns bin ich derjenige, der Fehler zu gibt. Und du bist derjenige, der keine Fehler zu gibt.
Achso, wessen Fehler willst du denn jetzt einräumen?
Deine? Nein, ich hab das... ja, ich... Deine sind ja eher offensichtlich.
Wir machen keine Fehler, die wir zugeben würden.
Damit hast du einen Fehler zugegeben. Nee, da hatten wir, da war das irgendwie, gab's so ein Video von diesem Galaxy Nexus... Galaxy, nee, Nexus S. Telefon, wo der so einen Browser rumscrollt und das so total ruckelt und fast stehen bleibt. Wo wir uns da, äh, oder wo ich mich fragte, ist das jetzt wirklich so? Und ich hab's jetzt am Wochenende mal, hatte ich mal so ein Samsung Galaxy S2 in der Hand gehabt. Also jetzt nicht genau dasselbe Telefon, aber schon sehr, sehr ähnliches Telefon.
Wie?
Zwei?
Samsung Galaxy S2. Das ist so das aktuelle.
Du hattest es gerade vorgestellt. Jetzt gibt's schon irgendeine Nachfolgerin eine Woche später, oder was?
Das ist das Galaxy Nexus. Das ist neu vorgestellt worden. Jetzt werfen sie diese Produktnamen auch noch zusammen, um die Konfusion einfach komplett zu machen.
Das ist, also mit Nexus drin ist immer das Google-Telefon und Galaxy S2 ist halt Samsung-Zeug.
Und wenn Nexus und Galaxy zusammenkommen, dann machen der Google und der Samsung was miteinander.
Die Tiger-Enter.
Und da hab ich mal den Browser einfach aufgemacht, hab exakt die Seite aufgerufen, die auch in diesem Video aufgerufen worden war. Und das lief snappy und war alles super. Und scrollte super durch. Und das war jetzt von Ruckeln wirklich keine Spur. Muss man sagen. Da hab ich über Android Scheiße erzählt. Oder erzählt dieses Video Scheiße.
Ist ja aber das Nexus wirklich so kacke und das S2 ist gut.
Ja, die Chance besteht natürlich noch. Was?
Das ist ja ein anderes Telefon. Das hat bestimmt wieder eine ganz andere Android-Version drauf.
Na, die Android-Version ist nicht so unterschiedlich. Was natürlich unterschiedlich ist, ist...
Wieso? Die haben doch da ein 4.0 vorgeführt schon.
Das ist das Nexus. Er hat das S2 gehabt.
Ich hab das S2 gehabt. Das hat Android 2, 3, irgendwas. Das ist ja von Samsung dann nochmal angepasst. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Nexus und dieser Samsung-Version. Auf den Samsung-Versionen ist ja immer nochmal diese Oberfläche drauf. TouchWiz, glaube ich, oder irgendwie sowas. Und kann natürlich sein, dass die gesehen haben, oh mein Gott, der Browser ruckelt ja wie Sau. Und dann nochmal jemand dran gesetzt haben, der das nochmal deutlich optimiert hat. Weiß ich nicht. Ich hatte halt nicht die original Google Experience, sondern ich hatte nur dieses Galaxy S2 und kann nur sagen, hat nicht hier ruckelt. Und ich hab mich mit dem Besitzer auch ein bisschen rehalten. Ja, manchmal ist es schon ein bisschen langsam, gibt es so Situationen, aber im Allgemeinen ist es eigentlich schon schnell.
Ok, Android ruckelt nicht.
Manchmal jedenfalls nicht.
Nicht immer.
Meistens nicht.
Trotzdem. Steve wollte Thermonuclear War ausrufen. Es klang ja relativ, also es war relativ ausfallen, dieses Statement, dass er irgendwie Android in Grund und Boden für jemand, der Photajana ist, um Tiere nicht zu verletzen, dass er es schon nicht hat, und Thermonikern kriegt.
Dieser Achsen, wie auch immer der sich da nennt, der kann sich jetzt ja auch wirklich alles aus dem Arsch ziehen, oder?
Wer?
Der Ise Achsen kann sich jetzt auch alles aus dem Arsch ziehen.
Naja, er hat ja Aufnahmen davon.
Ja, die soll er mal publishen.
Die gibt es teilweise schon.
Es gibt hier diese 60-Minutes-Sendung. Ja, da sind Ausschnitte drin. Die habe ich mir auch mal runtergeladen und angehört.
Die war...
Gibt es alles als Audio?
Nein, nicht alles, aber es gibt schon sehr viel.
Es gibt alles als Audio, aber es ist nicht alles veröffentlicht. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass es alles total geheim ist. Also es ist einiges, zum Beispiel, in dieser Fernseh-...
Aber er könnte alles veröffentlichen.
Ja, er müsste das auch mal machen.
Wir wollen ja den Originalstil hören.
Ja, vielleicht findet das ja auch irgendwann noch mal statt.
Na, bestimmt, wenn wir jeder haben.
Gibt es bestimmt als Hörbuch irgendwann einen ganz feueren...
Ich denke mir einfach, dass das eine extrem private Story ist. Da hat einfach dieser Eric Schmidt einfach... Der hat sich irgendwas geleistet, was Steve einfach mal echt getroffen hat. Und dann war's das.
Seitdem ist er einfach zickig.
Wobei Steve sicherlich auch so sehr zickig war.
Ja, aber richtig halt.
Habt ihr die Story mit Steves Auto gelesen?
Ja, das ist krass.
Und zwar hatte Steve ja immer so einen SL55 AMG, also so einen aufgepumpten Daimler für viel Geld. Und der ist hingefahren ohne License Plate, was irgendwie erlaubt ist in Kalifornien. Ohne Nummernschild.
Es gibt seit Jahren immer die Frage, wie schafft der das? Hat der eine Ausnahmegenehmigung? Ja, aber du kommst ja sofort so mit der Poarte rein.
Wie sofort?
Los, lass sie mir erzählen.
Also er hat halt den Daimler und fährt den halt ohne Nummernschild. Und schon seit langer Zeit, obwohl es eigentlich nur ein halbes Jahr lang erlaubt ist in Kalifornien, und zwar auch nur, wenn man einen Neuwagen hat, denn man hat ein halbes Jahr Zeit, sich ein Nummernschild zu besorgen anscheinend. Und Steve macht das schon seit Jahren. Und die Story dahinter ist wohl, dass er halt bei seinem Autohändler alle halbe Jahre halt hingeht und sich halt einen neuen Daimler geben lässt oder hat geben lassen. Und deswegen die ganze Zeit seit Jahren ohne Nummernschild gefahren ist.
Ich hatte das immer so gelesen, dass man das auf Antrag haben kann, wenn man Promi ist, damit man nicht irgendwie solche Antikröte ausnimmt.
Das war wohl früher das Gerücht. Ja, da müssten die Amis jetzt raus. Aber gerade erzählen die das halt. Er bei seinem Händler immer seinen alten Daimler abgibt und sich einen neuen geben lässt und dann wieder ein halbes Jahr ohne Nummernschiff.
Also es wurde eine Menge rumgerüchtet und er hat wohl irgendwann diese Lücke im Gesetz gefunden.
Na er hat die bestimmt nicht gefunden.
Es wurde gesagt, er oder jemand in seinem Umfeld sozusagen und seitdem hat er mit seinem Autohändler dann ein Deal abgeschlossen, dass der Leasing-Vertrag, dass er immer, also alle halbe Jahre eine neue Karre hingestellt kriegt.
Der Händler hat noch Gewinn gemacht und Steven auch. Mit dem Papsmobil.
Ich meine, die sind ja richtig teuer. Ich hab hier die Karre von Steve. Okay, geb dir das dreifacher.
Und MacBook dazu.
Was ist denn da deine Quelle für diese Story?
Du mal mit deinen Quellen, Internet.
Ich kann die hier mal. Ich kann die hier mal aussuchen.
Musst du mal googeln?
Quelle, Icke. Jungs, wir müssen schon hier nicht auf Journalisten machen, aber wir können zumindest ein bisschen...
Er hat das J-Wort gesagt.
Ich hab doch mal schnell gegoogelt.
Ich hab beise Nextweb.
Gizmodo darf doch gar nicht mehr schreiben über Steve.
Und da hat er sich schon ein schickes Auto ausgesucht, das Steve. Nicht so wohl Kreuzscheiß oder so einen dicken Bonsen-Bensen. Nein, sondern so ein relativ sportliches. Und dann noch die AMG-Version. Da geht es ganz schön ab. Angeblich war er ein ganz schöner Flotterflitzer, der Steve beim Fahren.
Der Isaacson hat mir wohl auch gefragt, wieso hast du eigentlich kein Nummernschild? Und dann hat Steve so gesagt, naja, wird man nicht so erkannt wird im öffentlichen Straßenverkehr und so. Naja, wird man nicht ohne Nummernschild noch wesentlich schneller erkannt als mit einem relativ bekannten Nummernschild? Ja, stimmt schon. Eigentlich wollte ich nur nie mit dem Nummernschild durchgegangen.
Wahrscheinlich wollte er, hat er bestimmt auch bei Daimler angerufen und gesagt, macht mir mal ein Auto ohne diesen Nummernschild scheiße. Das sieht nicht aus, das zerstört doch euer Design.
Das sind wohl einfach das Glattes oder wie?
Ja, irgendwie so. Wenn du dir die Werbung anguckst, auch gerade bei Motorrädern, wo ich ja immer gucke, wenn die so ein Motorrad vorstellen oder so ein Auto, ist ja immer irgendwie ohne Nummernschild. Also bei Motorrädern auf jeden Fall ohne, weil es sieht einfach scheiße aus. Und bei Autos ist es ja auch immer so ein bisschen, wenn es geht, ohne oder an einer anderen Fläche drin oder weißt schon.
Richtig Nummernschild. Wobei eigentlich haben sie doch bei Autos, in meiner Werbung, haben sie doch auch immer diese, also dass VWs immer in Wolfsburg gemeldet sind und dann auch immer diese eigenen Nummernschild und sowas. Also da sind sie schon. Und bei so Autos, da sind sie ja zumindest hinten, sind sie ja auch meistens so eingelassen, dass es irgendwie auch was fehlen würde, wenn da plötzlich kein Nummernschild wäre. Bei einer Motorräder ist das total recht, klar.
Also beim Auto geht es natürlich hinten, weil es passt halt so rein, weil es halt so gemacht, aber stell dir vor, wie es aussehen könnte hinten, wenn da kein Schild sein müsste.
Dann müssten sie sich mal echt was überlegen, was sie dahin machen.
Ich glaub, das werden die hinkriegen.
Vermutlich.
So, so viel dazu. Wir wollen ja mal wieder so ein Fun-Fact.
Meine erste, also ich meine... Was? Meine erste, ich hab die erste App, an der ich mitgearbeitet hab, ist im Store. Jetzt kann man runterladen. Soundcloud.
Du bist ja schon so ein richtig guter Objective-C-Coder, ja?
Ja, ich hab da jetzt nur Kleinkram gemacht. Also ich hab so...
Ja, aber bist du schon schnell rein ins Wasser, oder? Schnell ins Room of Acne.
Ja, blieb ja nichts anderes übrig, ne?
Objective-C ist die kommende Sprache, die geht voll ab irgendwie in diesen ganzen Listen und so.
Ja, da könnt ihr ja Soundcloud... Es ist sogar versehentlich... Also da gibt's so eine Tour, wenn man sich anmeldet, man kann sich über die App und Account klicken auch und dann fragt man so eine Hallo, guck mal, wie das hier alles funktioniert, wo man also durchswipe, so eine Tour. Und an der musste ich was machen und weil ich nicht Lust hatte, mir jedes Mal einen neuen Account anzuklicken, hab ich einfach irgendwo im Meme-Menü einen Replay-Tour-Menüpunkt eingebaut, mit dem die dann immer wieder abgespielt wird, damit ich die testen konnte. Und weil ich jetzt krank war, als dann die App eingereicht worden ist im Store bzw. der Urlaub hatte, hab ich vergessen, diesen Menüpunkt wieder auszunehmen und der ist jetzt immer noch drinne. Also das ist so mein kleiner Menüpunkt da in dieser App. Was macht der falsch? Der macht nichts falsch, der ist einfach nur ein Menüpunkt, mit dem man sich die Tour nochmal angucken kann. Diese Werke, das ist nichts Schlimmes, ansonsten, ich glaub, wenn es etwas Schlimmes wäre, dann wäre er auch schon wieder rausgeflogen, aber...
Da wärst du gar nicht erst durch den Store gekommen. Ja, was ist denn da jetzt so neu an dieser neuen Soundtrack?
Es gibt eine iPad-App erstmal, das ist natürlich so ein ganz großes Ding. Vorher war es nur aufs iPhone begrenzt. Die sieht sehr, sehr stark aus, wie so diese Twitter-App, also mit diesen überziehbaren Panels. Da haben wir ein komplett eigenes View-Controller-Modell geschrieben. Jetzt mit iOS 5 geht das ja ein bisschen einfacher. Da kann man ja auch seine eigenen View-Controller in die View-Controller-Hierarchie einhängen.
Und ist die jetzt iOS 5 only oder war es die App?
Nee, nee, die ist iOS 4 und iOS 5.
Aber wie macht ihr das dann mit iOS 4?
Na, wie gesagt, wir haben uns da unsere eigene... Das ist jetzt nicht so dramatisch kompliziert. Du musst halt die ganzen Events, die du oben in der Event-Hierarchie reinkriegst, an den View-Controller musst du halt an die ganzen...
Nein, ich meine, du hast ja gesagt, mit iOS 5 ist es jetzt einfach, aber ihr schreibt ja, ihr targetet ja noch 4.
Genau, das wollte ich jetzt gerade erläutern. Also in iOS 5 gibt es ein Befehl, mit dem kannst du sagen, häng mal diesen View-Controller. Also Views sind Elemente, die man auf dem Bildschirm sieht und View-Controller sind die dazugehörigen Controller, die nicht so viel Speicher verbrauchen. Den View kann man zuerst mal wegschmeißen, wenn das Element gerade nicht angezeigt wird, der View-Controller bleibt erhalten. Und Views kann man schon immer in einer Hierarchie, natürlich, weil man hat ja mehrere Buttons, also jeder Button, jedes Texteingabefeld, mindestens ein View jeweils, tendenziell mehrere. Also die muss man, davon kann man mehrere gleichzeitig haben und von diesen View-Controllern auf dem iPhone braucht man da eigentlich immer nur einen. Also der ganze Bildschirm ist immer ein View-Controller. Und jetzt bei dieser, zum Beispiel auch bei der Twitter-App oder bei der Soundcloud-App, da sieht man mehrere View-Controllers. Also zum einen hat man links eine Navigation und dann hat man zum Beispiel die Activity oder man sieht irgendwie Einträge von irgendjemanden. Das sind jeweils einzelne View-Controllers. Und dafür muss man die ganze, wobei das ist lange vor mir, also ich meine, die arbeiten jetzt die NextBigSing-Leute Gernot und Toto und Konsorten, die arbeiten da seit fast einem Jahr dran an der App. Und ich bin jetzt so auf den letzten anderthalb Monaten damit reingekommen. Also es ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel von mir dabei.
In einer neuen Version arbeiten die seit einem Jahr.
Genau, an der neuen Version, an der 2.0.
Was macht denn diese App überhaupt?
Du kannst sie mit Soundcloud bedienen. Also du kannst Sachen aufnehmen und die hochladen. Du kannst dir Sachen von anderen Leuten anhören. Du kannst dir deine... Du kannst Leuten followen. Du kannst deren Tracks kommentieren. Du kannst eigentlich so alles machen, was man bei Soundcloud auf der Seite machen kann auch.
Also ein kompletter Web-Ersatz?
Das ist bestimmt jetzt nicht 100% komplett, aber so die 99% wichtigsten Features sind dabei. Und es ist schön schnell geworden. Ich weiß nicht, hat ziemlich beeindruckende Download-Zahlen.
Und hat nicht geschmerzt.
Ähm, im Store oder was?
Nee, jetzt so Proamirer werden. iPhone Proamirer werden.
Du hast dich ja mal gewährt und kamst mit deinem komischen Webzeugs an.
Ja, es ist... Es gibt Sachen, die sind total geil. Nach wie vor. Also die Kontrolle, die man über Elemente hat. Also man kriegt alles hin, was man hinkriegen will. Wenn man Webentwicklungen macht, muss man oft auch tierische Kompromisse machen. Also da flackert irgendwas oder in dem Browser sieht es nicht geil aus. Diese Kompromisse muss man auf dem iPhone nicht machen. Da kriegst du die Kontrolle über jeden Pixel auf dem Bildschirm. Du hast die Kontrolle über jeder Zehntelsekunde.
Dafür muss man aber auch manchmal schon ganz schön den Weg...
Da muss man Schweiß und Tränen, total.
Manchmal muss man auch ganz schön was ver tun.
Und man muss sich auch wirklich tief reinarbeiten. Es gibt viele Details, die man wissen muss.
Auch mit dem View-Controller, als ich vor drei Jahren angefangen hab. Also das war nicht so easy, das ganze Konzept da irgendwie sich reinzuziehen. Wer, wann, wie, wo, links, rechts und so.
Also jedes Detail hab ich da immer noch nicht drauf. Weil ich das Gefühl habe, es gibt ja unglaublich viel Magic da drinnen. Und ich find so Magic im Sinne von, dass Dinge z.B. animiert sind. Also das sind Button, wenn du den verschiebst, dass der sich nicht einfach so an der anderen Stelle auftaucht, sondern dass der sich wirklich so langsam rüber bewegt. Das ist ja quasi so ein Automatismus, dass du, wenn du entsprechend über, also wenn Layer-Animation zumindest, die sind immer automatisch animiert. Das ist so das Default-Element. Und es spielt sich an vielen Stellen so eine gewisse Magie im Hintergrund ab, wo du glaubst, er macht was total Einfaches. Aber in Wirklichkeit wäre eine hunderte Reeder in Bewegung gesetzt. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du aus einem View-Controller heraus ein View ansprichst, das erste Mal, dann wird der automatisch geladen. Also du sagst, ja, mach mal hier Hintergrundfarbe von dem View anders. Und in dem Moment wird überhaupt erst der View geladen, weil vorher der gar nicht notwendig war. Und dann wundere ich mich, wieso dauert das jetzt plötzlich so lange, diese Hintergrundfarbe zu ändern? Also sie ist dann irgendwie ein Profiler. Und das fällt einem nur, und so eine Magic finde ich immer aus programmierer Sicht so ein bisschen gefährlich, weil sie neigt dazu, in vielen Sprachen irgendwann mal auf die Füße zu fallen. Und das macht sie bei Coco oder Coco Touch selten.
Ich kann mich nicht einloggen.
Haben wir gerade das Soundcloud gekillt? Sollte eigentlich nicht machbar sein.
Also wir haben noch nicht mal 500 Hörer. Wir blicken hier übrigens gerade wieder auf dieses Spure Audience Meter. Könnt ihr das nochmal holdigen?
Holdigen das Audience Meter. Das Soundcloud hat 15 Gigabit Traffic pro Sekunde.
Was war höher?
Ja, da kam locker Thema und dann ging es ab.
Kann ich noch kurz... Wo war ich gerade stehen geblieben?
Du wolltest doch einen Coco Touch erzählen. Das ist auch diese 2D-Lib, ja?
2D-Lib?
Dieses Coco Touch-Lib.
Coco Touch meinte ich jetzt... Das Coco Touch, das heißt doch so... Die Bibliothek heißt doch so. Die Apple-Bibliothek.
Habs auch so eine 2D-Bibliothek, die einem alles voll erleichtert, was ein Kumpel zwar benutzen muss.
Aber manchmal fällt es einem dann noch auf die Füße. Was zum Beispiel hölle kompliziert ist und wo man echt viel Zeit reinstecken muss, ist, und damit hatte ich vorher nie gerechnet, vernünftige Rotationen. Du musst jeden View... Du hast dein Telefon im Landscape-Modus und im Portrait-Modus. Und du musst natürlich beide Modi vernünftig designen. Das ist schon mal echt Arbeit, klar. Aber du musst auch die Animation, wenn du es drehst, dann sieht man ja, wie dieser Bildschirm so rumdreht. Hier hat man diese Drehanimation. Und die kann schnell scheiße aussehen und die kann vor allen Dingen schnell total ruckeln. Und da muss man echt viel Zeit reinstecken und das kann man auch nicht im Simulator testen, sondern das muss man am Gerät testen, das so hinzubiegen, dass die Animation vernünftig ist. Und weil sich mittendrin das Koordinatensystem ändert und sich eigentlich alles ändert in dieser Drehbewegung, ist das auch wirklich sehr kompliziert. Was dann auch so aus Sicht eines Web-Entwicklers wirklich scheiße ist, ist, es gibt kein vernünftiges Templating über den Interface-Bilder hinaus. Ich finde den Interface-Bilder nicht schlecht, aber wenn du mal irgendwie eine Table-Cell programmierst oder sowas, dann fängst du halt an, die Pixelwerte irgendwo einzutragen. Dann gibt es da ein paar ganz gute Mechanismen, um dir Rechtecke aufzuteilen oder Rechtecke zu Union und sowas. Also ein paar Hilfsmethoden.
Ja, das ist voll der Sack, oder? Weil ich meine, du kannst zwar schön die Tabellen einzeln einladen, nur die, die gerade optisch halt sichtbar sind, aber du kannst die Tabelle selbst nicht im Interface-Bilder irgendwie dir schon vordesignen, weil du die nicht direkt verdraht kannst, weil die ja dynamisch geladen wird. Und anstatt dass du da mal irgendwie...
Also Table-Cells kann man mittlerweile auch über einen Interface-Bilder gestalten.
Ja, aber kannst du dann auch dann schön ordentlich ran kleben in deine dynamische Table-View-Dingens?
Ach so, das geht, ja keine Ahnung, das weiß ich nicht. Aber eben auch so, ja man kann keine eigene Views in Interface-Bilder laden, das stimmt, das ist tatsächlich auch ziemlich doof. Aber ich finde auch, wenn man es programmatisch macht, ich finde da programmatisch ranzugehen, also den Code dafür zu schreiben, finde ich jetzt gar nicht verkehrt. Und ich meine, ich mache sowas auch, ich habe CSS jahrelang geschrieben. Aber so, wenn man aus dieser Webwelt kommt, dann ist das schon dieses, wie man Elemente in Coco platziert, schon, ich nenne es mal, gewöhnungsbedürftig, also das ist schon sehr rabiat. Und wo es dann wirklich anfängt weh zu tun, das sind, wenn man mal eben in einem Text einen Link setzen will. Und das ist nun in HTML, klar, einen Link setzen ist jetzt so ziemlich das Einfachste, was man sich überhaupt vorstellen kann. Und wir haben da dieses, wie heißt denn die, MG Template Engine?
Nee, wie heißt denn das?
MH Attributed Label ist das glaube ich. Nee, nicht NS. Das ist gar nicht, es gibt kein formatiertes Label. Also dieses UI Label, was es von Apple direkt gibt. Das ist halt ein wirklich ein reines Text. Trag deinen Text ein, den kannst du nicht formatieren. Und dann gibt es da dieses, wie heißt denn das? Attributed Label ist das glaube ich. Gibt es eine externe Bibliothek von jemanden, der da mal viel Arbeit geschrieben hat? Und damit wird es dann ein bisschen einfacher. Damit kann man auch sagen, also packst du einen String rein, legst einen Range an, sagst hier pack mal auf Zeichen 8 bis 45, formatiere die mal so und formatiere das mal fett. Und da kannst du dann auch einen Link draufsetzen. Das funktioniert auch alles ganz toll. Das einzige Problem ist, du hast halt, wenn du irgendwie, wenn du eine mehrsprachige App hast, dann willst du ja nicht sagen, mach mal auf Zeichen 8 bis 45 einen Link drauf, weil du weißt ja gar nicht, ist das in einer anderen Sprachversion überhaupt dasselbe. Also braucht man quasi, ja, ich hab jetzt an Markdown gedacht oder irgendwie so was, mal so eine, so eine wirklich, so eine gewisse Formatierungssprache da irgendwie reinpacken. Und das ist, das muss man sich alles selber schreiben. Das gibt's halt alles nicht. Das ist, und ich hab wirklich irgendwie an einen, ich hab einen halben Tag gebraucht, einen Link vernünftig zu setzen. Und das hat, das war schon frustrierend. Also es hat Licht und es hat Schatten.
Es hat Licht und es hat Schatten. Ist gut. Gut zu wissen, dass es Licht und Schatten hat. Zwischendurch wurde auf Twitter gefragt, ob ihr noch Bücher empfehlen kann. Soweit ich weiß, empfehlt man immer noch dasselbe Buch zum Thema. Programmierung, IOS-Programmierung. Ja, oder habt ihr auch andere Tipps auf Lager?
Ich komm mit diesen Büchern nicht klar. Irgendwie steht mir da immer zu viel Geschwafel drin, was ich schon kenne. Und äh, ich bin...
Toll...
.arbeite mich immer gerne komplett durch ein Buch durch und wenn ich da ankomme, also wenn ich das erstmal alles lesen muss, was ich schon kenne, hab ich schon keinen Bock mehr auf den Rest. Und so mittendrin anfangen, dann denk ich immer, ich hab was verpasste.
Trotz dem ist das so eigentlich das, was ich immer höre, was so zu empfehlen sei.
Also gibt's da dann noch eine aktuelle Version, der aktualisiert, wie alt ist der denn gerade?
Jetzt wollte ich hier die Kindle...
Keine Ahnung...
.das Kindle-App auf dem Mac mal starten, jetzt crasht das ungefähr an zwei Sekunden.
Da steht doch bestimmt irgendwo die aktuelle Auflage, da muss ja irgendwo... Ist doch schon die dritte oder vierte inzwischen. Da müssen wir ein bisschen weiter, genau hier, da. Dritte Auflage von Mai 2008. Das ist schon nicht mehr so wirklich aktuell, weil der Xcode 4 ist schon komplett anders. Und da ist wahrscheinlich gerade ein ganz bisschen iPhone noch mit reingeflossen. Ich denke mal, das ist nicht das Wahre. Das Buch ist ein bisschen hinterher.
Also ich habe hier gelernt mit iPhone Programming, The Big Nerd Range Guide.
Das ist auch Aaron Hillegas.
Das ist auch Aaron Hillegas. Da müsste jetzt eine zweite Auflage von rausgekommen. Ich habe noch die erste Auflage. Die ist noch für Xcode 3. Jetzt müsste es eine neue Auflage geben für Xcode 4. Ah, das ist noch die erste Auflage.
Also hier ist zumindest jetzt gerade noch von der die Rede.
Ja, dann will man wahrscheinlich wirklich warten, bis die zweite Auflage kommt.
Ah, guck mal, hier unten, da ist doch die Auflage. Die zweite.
Und das ist sogar billiger als die alte.
Das ist sogar billiger als die alte.
Das ist voll der Trick, um noch irgendwie bücherlos zu werden, schnell.
Und das ist soweit, das ist soweit nicht schlecht. Ich hab, also was mir ein bisschen merkwürdig aufgestoßen ist, der ist so old school drauf. Also zum Beispiel, es gibt ja in Objective-C gibt es ja diese, die klassische Syntax, diese Klammern-Syntax mit den eckigen Klammern. Es gibt die Punkt-Syntax. Und hier Aaron Hillegas schreibt erst mal lange drüber, warum er diese Punkt-Syntax ablegt. Und dass es ja alles Teufelzeug ist, dieser neuemodische Kram. Ich finde die Punkt-Syntax super, die macht total viel Sinn, macht Code deutlich übersichtlicher, hat Apple sich schon viel bei gedacht, dass er das eingeführt hat. Sollten ruhig noch ein paar mehr Stellen einführen, sowas.
Naja, aber die ganzen Apis unterstützen ja die neue Punkt-Syntax aber noch nicht komplett.
Wie? Na, an den Apis hängt das doch gar nicht.
Dazu muss es ja wohl eine Property sein, richtig?
Doch, doch. Also mir ist jetzt tatsächlich keine Api bewusst, bei der man keine Punkt-Syntax einsetzen kann. Also vielleicht auf dem Desktop. Da ist ja noch ein bisschen was anderes, da ist ja noch ein bisschen älter alles, aber das iPhone hier, das ganze iPhone SDK, das ist doch erst...
Das kann schon sein.
Das ist doch komplett kokurt.
Also auch von dem Coco Programming für Macintosh. Also für Mac OS X Entwicklung gibt's demnächst auch eine neue Version, eine vierte Auflage. Ich verlinke auf jeden Fall mal hier beide. Das scheinen schon so die ersten Adressen zu sein, wenn man jetzt mit einem Buch einsteigen möchte, was immer genannt wird. Coco Programming, Aaron Hillegas und iOS Programming, auch Hillegas und Joe Conway, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe.
Ich hab hier taucht auch im Chat, kam auch per Mail, ob ich schon mal dieses App-Code ausprobiert hätte. Das ist, es gibt jetzt nämlich, also Xcode ist die IDE, ist die einzige IDE für Objective-C und für dieses ganze Coco Zeug bis jetzt. Jetzt gibt es halt dieses App-Code von JetBrains. JetBrains, die machen auch die IntelliJ, die sehr gute und sehr bekannte Java IDE. Ich hab mit PHPStorm, wie gesagt, schon mal gearbeitet, was eine sehr, sehr gute PHP-IDE ist. Und jetzt haben die halt eine Objective-C-IDE rausgebracht. Und ich hab die leider nur, als ich in der Beta-Phase war, ich die mal kurz angeklickt und ein bisschen was drin gemacht und ein paar Mal was laufen lassen. Also ich hab jetzt nicht so die krasse Mega-Erfahrung bisher damit und kenne nicht alle Details, aber das macht, auf den ersten Blick machte das einen extrem robusten Eindruck. Es fühlt sich ein bisschen creepy an, sowas Schönes wie Objective-C dann in so einer Java-Umgebung zu entwickeln. Aber wenn man damit leben kann, also die haben eigentlich, also von deren PHP-IDE und von deren Java-IDE, die haben eine extrem geile Code-Navigation drinne, die haben ein wirklich gut funktionierendes Refactoring drinne, was Xcode aus irgendeinem Grund immer noch nicht hat. Die haben, was ich echt geil finde, ein Feature drinne, dass du kannst eine Methode, kannst dir zeigen lassen, wo wird diese Methode überhaupt gerufen. Das ist extrem praktisch, wenn du mal, also, ich hab hier eine Methode vor mir und irgendwas funktioniert in dieser Methode nicht. Ich hab einen Haufen Code und ich versteh den teilweise nicht. Und dann guck ich mal, wo wird die überhaupt noch an anderen Stellen benutzt, als an der Stelle, an der ich sie benutze. Weil wenn nur ich die benutze, dann kann ich die auch komplett umarbeiten, ohne dass es Probleme gibt und Refactoren. Und darum ist es oft sehr interessant zu sehen, wo wird diese Methode überhaupt alles gerufen. Und das kann dieses App-Code alles, also insofern.
Die kostet aber auch richtig Geld, ne?
Nee, die kostet nicht viel. Dieses echte Schnäppchen, die kostet irgendwie 160 oder 100...
65, 61 Euro.
131.
131 Euro für die Commercial License.
Ok, aber Personal, ok, Commercial. Na, ich find das schon ganz schön ordentlich Geld heutzutage.
130 Euro für eine IDE finde ich echt absolut in Ordnung. Für irgendwas, was ich jeden Tag benutze und damit Software entwickle und damit mein Geld verdiene.
Du weißt ja, ein bisschen angsthaft bist, wenn du da so nah dran bist an dem Xcode. Also Xcode ist ja schon auch immer, passt dich immer die neuesten Versionen an und alles. Dann ändert Apple irgendwas und dann bist du da mit deinem Appcode und du hast deine ganzen Projekte da drin, bist ja erstmal voll hinterher und am Arsch. Also da hätt ich irgendwie gar nicht so richtig Bock drauf.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine Gefahr, auf die man sich einlässt. Also die Projekte im Augenblick kannst du von Xcode alle einwandfrei öffnen. Du machst einfach dein Xcode-Projekt drauf.
Ja, wie gesagt, aber die ändern irgendwas und dann geht's plötzlich nicht mehr so schnell. Und dann musst du halt bis, kannst du, ja.
Klar. Was die allerdings noch haben, was echt geiles, die haben für TestFlight, also haben die eine direkte Integration drinne. Und zwar du kannst, es gibt einen Befehl, hier, bilde mir den, mach mir das und mach Codesigning-Hell für mich und lad das zu TestFlight hoch und verteile das an meine User. Also TestFlight ist, wenn man mal eine Demo-Version macht von diesem ganzen iOS-Zeug und will das jetzt, also eine Beta-Version, will das jetzt an seine User rausschicken, dann ist das ein wirklich furchtbar komplizierter Scheiß. Weil du musst dieses IPA packen, also so eine Datei packen, die musst du dann signen. Beim Signen geht dann garantiert irgendwas schief und es ist alles nicht gut erklärt. Und das ist, also dieser Teil ist, alle die von, bei Apple keine Ahnung, von User.faces haben, die werden dieses Codesigning-Projekt gepackt, da hab ich das Gefühl, weil das ist wirklich, das ist, das könnte selbst Microsoft besser, sag ich jetzt mal.
Ist aber nicht im App Store der Upcode.
Da ist ja auch in Java geschrieben.
Objective-C-Environment, was in Java geschieht.
Ja, ich hab doch schon gesagt, dass das ein bisschen creepy anfühlt, aber es ist, und mit TestFlight, und dann muss man seinen User dieses IPA zuschicken, diese Beta-Version, dann müssen die das in iTunes irgendwie einspielen, müssen ihr Gerät anschließen, müssen das rüberspielen, und das ist alles wirklich ganz furchtbar. Bei TestFlight legt sich der Account ein, lädt seine User ein, und die kriegen dann eine Mail, und in dieser Mail müssen sie auf dem iPhone direkt nur ein Install-Link klicken, und ihnen wird die neueste Beta-Version installiert, und es funktioniert wie Magic, und man wird von TestFlight informiert, wann sie die App gestartet haben, und wenn das abgestürzt ist, kriegt man sofort das Crash-Log mit dazu. TestFlight ist, Apple sollte TestFlight kaufen, um seinen Entwicklern angenehmer und einfacher zu machen, und die sollten die Jungs nehmen, und sollten sich von denen erklären lassen, wie man so ein Deployment vernünftig macht. Das ist das, was Apple im Augenblick nicht hinkriegt. Und AppCode hat diese TestFlight-Integration direkt drin. Also sie haben direkt einen Menübefehl dafür drin, wo du sagst, schick meine App jetzt auf TestFlight, und du brauchst dir nichts Gedanken zu machen. Und das ist sowas, das gibt es bei Xcode halt nicht, und das nervt total, weil es ist dann jedes Mal für Arbeiter so eine Beta-Version anzulegen. Also kann man sich auf jeden Fall die 30-Tage-Testversion guckt euch die mal an, wenn ihr sowas macht.
Gut, so war das erstmal durch mit dem Thema. Also alle Links in den Show Notes, wie immer. Abcode. Also ich finde das ja generell schon mal gut, dass es da überhaupt Konkurrenz, also dass sich da überhaupt jemand traut, da Konkurrenz zu machen.
Ja, das wundere mich allerdings auch.
Da habe ich wirklich nicht mitgerechnet.
Ich hätte da keinen Dollar reingesteckt.
Ja, aber es ist vielleicht auch, was weiß ich, ich meine, es ist vielleicht auch ein Incentive für Leute, die einfach vorher mit solchen Ideen gearbeitet haben, weißt du, und die dann einfach so iOS als ein neues Deployment ansehen und durchaus auch bereit sind, native zu programmieren, aber nicht jetzt unbedingt auch noch komplett nur für diese eine weitere Plattform, sich auf ein anderes System, also ich unterstelle jetzt mal diesen Abcode, das ist sehr diesem, was heißt das, IntelliJ etc. ähnelt oder wesentlichen dasselbe ist.
Also wenn man einen PHP-Storm oder IntelliJ bedient hat schon mal, dann kann man das auch bedienen. Das ist gar keine Frage.
Ich denke, wir hatten einfach da eine Menge Code und konnten da viele selber wieder re-usen und haben da gar nicht jetzt so doll alles, also es ist wahrscheinlich von Ground abgestimmt.
Genau, aber das ist mir jetzt lieber, als wenn jetzt, weißt du, mit irgendwelchen Translation-Systemen, was weiß ich hier so wie, was weiß ich, dass man Adobe Flash nimmt und dann irgendwie versucht, da mit iPhone Applikationen zu machen, dass du so The Java Style machst. Und dann schon lieber sagen, ok, du machst jetzt zwar native, und bei mir ist es auch the real thing, aber dein IDE ist zumindest so, wie du es gewohnt bist.
Man kann auch On-the-fly wechseln. Ich hab das mal gemacht, als ich dieses Testprojekt aufgemacht hab, hab ich da mal gesagt, das Soundcloud-Projekt einfach reingeschmissen, einen halben Tag nur damit entwickelt und dann bin ich wieder zurückgeswitcht auf Xcode. Man kann beide Ideen offen halten und man kann sich auch entscheiden, so on the fly, um das jetzt zu machen, ist die Idee besser und dafür ist die Idee besser. Die von Netbrands, Jetbrands, keine Ahnung, die werben zwar damit, dass man eigentlich Xcode so gut wie gar nicht braucht, außer eben sie haben keinen Interface-Bilder drin natürlich und sie haben hier diese ganze, wie heißt das, CoreData, diese ganzen Datenbank-Schichten haben sie alle nicht drin. Aber, also dieses Datenbank-Design, aber ich würde sagen, in der Praxis sollte man beide Ideen offen halten und sich je nachdem, was gerade besser ist, immer die jeweils bessere Idee raussuchen. Weil so von der Navigation her und so, also ich finde diese Fingerwischgesten auf dem Trackpad in Xcode sehr angenehm, also man kann so mit zwei Fingerswipes kann man vor und zurück navigieren im Code, also dass er dann zum vorherigen Dokument oder zum nächsten geht. Das kann natürlich so eine Java-App nicht sein, man muss auch auf den Vor- und Zurück-Button klicken bzw. sich einen Shortcut auswendig lernen. Also das sind auch so Annehmlichkeiten, die man erstaunlich schnell zu schätzen weiß. Und haben beide ihre voren Nachteile.
Gut, wir sollten mal mehr über Max reden. Stimmt. Beziehungsweise vielleicht mal so eine kleine Hardware-Sektion mal wieder einführen. Max, aber du kannst gleich weiterreden.
Ich kann gleich weiterreden?
Ja, du hast ja auch neue Hardware gekauft, abgesehen von dem 4S. Du bist doch so ein Fanboy, dass du irgendwie am Laufenden...
Nee, hab ich mir auch kaufen lassen.
Ach so.
Das hör ich jetzt schon eine ganze Weile. Ich hab jetzt schon zwei Sendungen.
Jetzt bin ich ja schon ein bisschen neidisch.
Warum?
Weil ich noch das alte Display hab. Ich mal auf dir, was das alte Display hat, und dann kannst du gleich trumpfen, was dann noch viel geiler ist. Das hat halt, was hat das? Minidisplay-Port, genau. Und da muss ich halt USB extra stecken. Und Strom kommt auch nicht von meinem Display. Genau, da kommt kein Strom.
Da kommt kein Strom?
Nee, und es ist halt auch noch hier so ein Röhrenstrahler und kein LED-Ding.
Oh.
Und so ein 23 Zoll. Ansonsten 1920 irgendwann mal hier, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung, 1080 oder was? Oder 1200.
Nee, das ist schon ein bisschen höher.
Nee, du hast ja ein 27 Zoll, richtig?
Ach so, das ist okay.
Also ich hab einen 23 Zoll. Und es ist schon ganz cool, aber es ist halt jetzt auch schon 4,5 Jahre alt. Aber sonst eigentlich ganz gut. Aber ich würde jetzt, jetzt kannst du erzählen, was wir jetzt gerne haben. Das kann ich erzählen.
Das sieht jetzt quasi ein bisschen aus wie dein 27 Zoll iMac. Außer, dass unten der iMac-Teil halt fehlt. Also man hat nur oben diesen Display-Teil dran. Für Leute, die sich gern ein iMac und ein 27 Zoll Thunderbolt-Display da nebeneinander stellen wollen, die Displays sind nicht auf derselben Höhe. Das Thunderbolt-Display ist halt ein bisschen tiefer, sodass dann auch der Desktop darauf ein bisschen tiefer ist. Man steckt das Thunderbolt-Display hier an der einen Seite vom Rechner dran, vom Macbook hier bei mir. An der anderen Seite stecke ich den MagSafe-Adapter ran. Es ist erstaunlich, die Kabelpeitsche ist gerade so lang, dass es rüber reicht. Also für einen 15 Zoll Macbook Air würde es da schon knapp werden.
Die sind auch auf beiden Seiten, oder wie?
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, wie ein 15 Zoll Macbook Air aussehen würde, aber bei mir ist es hier auf beiden Seiten.
Die werden das so machen, dass es mit dem Kabel reicht.
Natürlich.
Da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher, aber das Kabel kommt bestimmt auch wieder direkt aus diesem Bildschirm raus und hat so eine feste Länge und so. Das ist scheiße.
Das kommt direkt aus dem...
Für mich ist das ein Hauptgrund, diese Variante überhaupt nicht zu erwägen.
Erstaunlicherweise ist es so, dass auf dem Motherboard, also hier iFixit, die haben das natürlich immer wieder aufgeschraubt, das Ding, und die haben sich das Motherboard direkt angeguckt. Und da steckt einfach ein stinknormaler Thunderbolt-Adapter drin. Also man kann das... Kabel ist zumindest für den Apple Support relativ einfach austauschbar. Was ja schon mal was wert ist. Also es ist nicht irgendwie verlötet oder sowas, sondern es ist halt ein bisschen verschraubt, dass man nicht irgendwie die Platine rausreißt versehentlich. Und so, dann hat es eine Kamera drin. Die Kamera ist echt geil. Also die MacBook Air, diese Kamera, diese iSight-Kamera, die ist echt scheiße, das muss man so mal sagen. Und ist halt auch nicht HD und weiß der Teufel was. Aber die eingebaute Kamera, die ist gut. Ich finde, ich hatte vorher so ein Dell-Display und ich weiß nicht, was an diesem Dell-Display ist. Ich meine, die brauchen nichts weitermachen, als digitale Signale zu nehmen und auf ihr Panel zu pappen und irgendwie scheitern sie daran, weil sie die Bildschärfe nachstellen und irgendwelche Weichzeichnungsfilter drüber scheuchen und sowas. Und das ist bei diesem Apple-Display, du kannst da nichts einstellen, sondern das Bild ist einfach von Anfang an geil. Und das ist halt einfach so. Das ist ein extrem guter Kontrast. Ich fand vorher das MacBook Air-Display total toll und mittlerweile finde ich, ja, ist ein gutes Display, aber dieses Thunderbolt-Display ist einfach wirklich nochmal um Dimensionen besser, also was Farben angeht und das Kontrast angeht.
Wie auch der iMac halt.
Ja, dann hat es halt hinten ein Gigabit Ethernet-Port.
Ja, das ist das Allergeilste. Das ist eigentlich eine Docking-Station, oder?
Ja, das ist eine Docking-Station, genau. Jetzt hab ich noch hier für das iPhone...
Und USB und Firewire, oder?
Und USB und Firewire.
Und Audio.
Er hat ein Mikrofon drin, aber kein Kopfhörerausgang. Das hat mich total gewundert. Das wär's noch.
Aber er hat Lautsprecher, mein Display hat zum Beispiel keine Lautsprecher. Die gab es damals auch noch nicht. Die wurden ja ein bisschen jetzt schon vorher eingeführt, aber das hat meins nämlich auch nicht.
Was ich aber ehrlich gesagt total bekloppt finde, wobei das könnte man jetzt vielleicht noch mit dem iPhone 4S ausprobieren. Vielleicht hat sich da ja was geändert. Wenn du dein iPhone über das Thunderbolt-Display lädst und der Mac geht schlafen, dann geht es aus. Dann hört er auf zu laden.
Und das ist bei mir auch so.
Und das finde ich echt doof. Also warum sie da nicht irgendwie mal einfach ein Signal einfügen.
Was, er hört auf zu schlafen?
Zu laden.
Zu laden, wenn er schläft?
Das Display schaltet dann aus, geht dann offensichtlich in Stromsparmodus und schaltet dann die USB-Ports ab.
Das ist auch immer total lame. Ich finde, da könnte mein Telefon sogar laden, wenn der Rechner nicht dran ist. So ist mir doch egal. So lad mein scheiß Telefon. Das ist nur ein B-Port.
Man steckt seinen Rechner an Strom und sobald der Rechner zum Stromsparen sich ausschaltet, wird er nicht mehr geladen.
Nee, der Rechner ist iPhone. Das iPhone, das am Display dransteckt.
Ach so, und wenn du jetzt den Rechner am Bildschirm dran hast und dein Rechner geht schlafen, kriegt er nur noch Strom?
Jaja, Strom gibt, oder? Jaja, der lädt dann weiter.
Aber wenn der Rechner schläft, können die USB-Ports keinen Strom mehr.
Dann wäre ich auch schlafen gelegt. Wobei, was mir aufgefallen ist, ich weiß nicht, ob das nur ein Bug war oder ob das dauerhaft ist, ich hab neulich mein iPhone geladen, als das MacBook geschlafen hat.
Jaja, das geht.
Nee, das geht jetzt einfach so.
Ja, das geht schon lange. Das geht seit irgendeiner OS-Änderung vor einem Jahr.
Ich dachte, man müsste noch irgendeinen Shortcut zum Schlafenlegen drücken. Okay.
Das war so ein Dota-Release, ich hab's total vergessen. Das war irgendwie 10, 6, irgendwas. Und da haben sie das dann geändert. Das mach ich übrigens sehr häufig. Wenn ich unterwegs bin, dann ist quasi mein Air, was ich dabei habe, das ist so meine externe Batterie für das iPhone. Also wenn das Teil irgendwie low ist, dann klapp ich halt kurz mein MacBook auf, mach das iPhone ran mit USB, klapp zu, steck's einfach wieder in die Tasche mit eingesteckten Kabel und dann lädt das. Deswegen hab ich eigentlich nicht immer noch mal einen Akku-Pack dabei, weil ich halt eh in der Regel meinen F-Zoll mit hab. Also auf Reisen jetzt.
Ansonsten... Ich find die Druckerbuchse von so einer Express zu benutzen.
Druckerbuchse, die USB-Port von, ja, nur dass die nicht besonders viel Strom liefern.
Ja, so wenig, dass das iPhone sagt, das würde nicht gehen, aber zumindestens hältst du sozusagen den Stand und macht so ganz minimal, lädt das auch sogar auf, also besser als gar nichts.
Also diese 2A Netzteile, die du heute so mitkriegst mit dem iPad und so, die sind schon die beste Wahl eigentlich, wer du schnell laden willst. Das iPhone, finde ich, lädt auch wirklich rasant, also es ist so schnell voll. Man muss ja nicht wirklich lange das dranhalten, um da was davon zu haben, während so ein iPad... Ich habe ja mein iPad ehrlich gesagt immer noch nicht wirklich in Benutzung. Aber es ist mir ein Rätsel, wie man das on the fly laden soll.
Der Akku hält einfach lang genug, dass man es über Nacht laden kann, dass es reicht.
Die Erfahrung habe ich jetzt so auch nicht gemacht. Ein iPad hält auch nur einen Tag.
Ja, aber den hält es.
Ja gut, aber ich habe das halt immer irgendwie...
Also 10 Stunden hältst du in Benutzung.
Ja, aber es ist dann halt einfach irgendwann leer. Auch wenn ich es nicht benutze, ist es halt irgendwann leer. Dann brauchst du halt Stunden, um das wieder zu laden.
Na ja, das ist halt ein großer Akku. Also ich bin neulich mal wieder längere Zeit, Bahn zu fahren und jetzt mit so einem MacBook Air und so einem iPad dabei, muss ich ja sagen, es wird ja immer toller, mit der Bahn zu fahren. Also so dieses Versprechen, setz dich in die Bahn, fahr los, kümmere dich nicht um Steckdosen, sondern setz dich einfach rein und arbeite direkt... Ich hab, weil ich das Air und das iPad für unterschiedlich... Also ich hatte überlegt, nur das iPad mitzunehmen und hab dann gedacht, dann kann ich noch ein bisschen coden im Zweifelsfall. So war der Gedanke, darum hab ich das Air noch mitgenommen. Also ich hab das Air als Ergänzung zum iPad mitgenommen, nicht umgekehrt.
Bei mir ist es genau andersrum.
Ich mach mittlerweile auf dem iPad, ich...
So dieses...
Also alles was... Also längere Mails... Obwohl nee, ich mach wahrscheinlich alles, was nicht Coding ist oder nicht so komplexere Sachen. Also was Multitasking ist, geh ich dann sofort auf den Rechner. Aber lesen, Filme gucken, surfen, längere Artikel lesen, mach ich alles komplett auf dem iPad. Mails schreiben, Mails lesen.
Vielleicht bin ich echt altschulich, aber mir bietet da einfach das iPad... Also mir bietet das iPad da einfach auch nicht im Ansatz das, was ich erwarte. Es hat im Wesentlichen was mit dem Notieren von Informationen zu tun. Weil wenn ich den Computer benutze, dann bin ich eigentlich die ganze Zeit dabei, mir irgendwas zu notieren. Und bin die ganze Zeit am Drängen und Droppen und Cutten und Pasten und Reinschreiben und mehrere Programme gleichzeitig nach vorne holen und so. Das geht einfach auf jeden Fall.
Vielleicht nutzt du da auch anderen Werk? Also ich benutze halt sehr stark... Was ich halt mache, ist viel Bookmarking und so Sharing-Funktionen. Ach, da sollten wir auch nochmal drüber reden. Da hat auch nochmal ein Hörer darauf hingewiesen.
ifttt.com Hab ich schonmal eingeschaltet und irgendwann vergessen, was das tut und mich immer gewundert, warum sich mein Twitter-Account so erratisch verhält.
Das ist sowas, man kann bestimmte Aktionen in einem Dienst an Aktionen in einem anderen Dienst klöppeln. Und kann bestimmte Aktionen auslösen, wenn das passiert. Also ich nutze das jetzt. Also man hat verschiedene Channels, da gibt es noch viel viel mehr. Klickt mal auf Get More Channels. Da stehen die ganzen Dienste, das ist so ein bisschen, die haben halt ihre Dienste, heißen Channel, also Twitter, Facebook, Also man würde das mal als Event-Quellen bezeichnen. Na ja, Beides. Ereignis-Quellen und Aktions-Bereiche. Und die kann man beliebig kombinieren. Also man kann sagen, wenn ich bei Twitter eine neue Nachricht poste, dann mach damit das. Also es gibt zum Beispiel sowas, so ich lad bei Instagram ein Bild hoch, pack das sofort in meine Dropbox. Es gibt oben diese Recipes, Recipes, wie wird das ausgesprochen? Rezept auf Englisch? Die lohnen sich auf jeden Fall mal anzugucken. Da sind echt ein paar schöne Ideen dabei, was man so anstellen kann. Und wofür ich das zum Beispiel mittlerweile nutze, ist, wenn ich in Google Reader auf den Share-Button klicke, dann wird der Link automatisch in meinen Facebook-Account reingepappt. Und so pump ich sozusagen alle Sachen, also ich lese sehr viel mit diesem Reader, diesem großartigen RSS-Reader. Und wenn ich da auf Share drücke, wandert das automatisch in meinen Facebook-Account und ich brauch mir keine weiteren Gedanken mehr zu machen. Das ist eine tolle Sache.
Wenn du Share machst, und was macht er bei Share?
Na, es gibt halt diese Google Reader eingebaute Share-Funktion.
Ich denke, die ist jetzt ausgeschaltet worden.
Die ist noch nicht, die wird jetzt abgeschaltet, was leider eigentlich ganz furchtbar ist. Google wird mir echt langsam unsympathisch. Wirklich? Ja, das ist so, wir haben ja ein Produkt, wir haben hier dieses Google Plus, dass das so halb angenommen wird. Jetzt werden wir alle zwangsbeglückt mit Google Plus, und das nervt. Und dafür werden die Kunden... Ich meine, ich habe diesen Reader, der ist eigentlich toll. Oder er ist nicht toll, er ist das einzige, was existiert. Man könnte es tausendmal besser machen, als diesen scheiß Google Reader. Und sie haben sich nie Mühe mit dem Ding gegeben. Und jetzt kommt irgendwie ein Marketing-Fuzzi auf die Idee, dass man da jetzt Google Plus reinpumpen müsste irgendwie. Und jetzt wird quasi das Produkt abgeschaltet. Und ich hoffe mal, also hier der Silvio, der Reader macht, wenn er... Also es wäre ein totaler Bold Move, aber jetzt da auch seine eigene Infrastruktur auf die Beine zu stellen und so wirklich so eine richtig geile... Ob ich da einen Google Reader nutze, ist mir eigentlich scheißegal. Ich nutze einen Reader, ich nutze ihn auf dem iPhone, ich nutze ihn auf dem iPad und auf dem Mac.
Da wird es nur ums Synchronien gehen, kann er ja iCloud benutzen.
Er kann iCloud benutzen, da weiß er toll, iCloud wäre gut oder was komplett anderes. Gerne auch einen offenen Standard implementieren, der auch mit mehr Sachen funktioniert. Dass der von mehr Apps, dass da auch meinetwegen noch Instapaper oder sowas sich rein hacken könnten, dass wir also dieser Google Reader, der ist immer total vernachlässigt worden und jetzt wird er noch kaputt gemacht. Das ist wirklich traurig. Shame on you, Google!
Oder Papsap hubbub. Das ist so eigentlich die Eventwelt.
Es ist so, dass dann auch Events verschickt, also das push gepusht wird, wenn irgendwie ein neuer Tick kommt.
Ja, das ist so Java High Performance Notification von allem Scheiß.
Da war Google ja auch extrem hinterher, also das haben sie ja auch ziemlich mit vorangetrieben und sowas. Also sie sind ja, auf der technischen Ebene sind sie ja immer nicht schlecht, aber was dann die Ausführung angeht...
Google ist einfach durcheinander. Dieses Plus, das finde ich auch völlig unattraktiv. Aber bleiben wir mal kurz hier bei diesem If-is-than-that. Ich hab das wie gesagt schon vor einiger Zeit mal entdeckt gehabt und ein bisschen so rum benutzt. Allerdings bin ich jetzt etwas erschlagen hier von der Masse an neuen Kanälen, die da mittlerweile mit dabei sind. Und dieses generelle Problem, dieses in dem einen Dienst entdecke ich irgendwas und ich möchte, dass es woanders auftaucht, das ließe sich in der Tat hier vielleicht auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise ganz gut integriert. Weil ich sehe nämlich hier auch gerade Evernote und ich hab immer so dieses Problem mit meinen Notizen und ich benutze ja derzeit Simplenote und ich bin einfach total angekotzt, weil es einfach überhaupt keinen ordentlichen MEC-Client dafür gibt und das irgendwie alles nicht vorangeht. Also da findet einfach gerade kein Fortschritt statt und ich hasse es mich an Orten aufzuhalten, wo kein Fortschritt stattfindet. Vielleicht sollte ich Evernote nochmal eine Chance geben, weil ich hätte das irgendwann mal, nachdem es durch Sünkereien mir einfach mal wieder alles zerbröselt hat, nochmal eine Chance geben. Vielleicht funktioniert es besser. Aber wenn man über sowas hier auch noch ganz gute Kanäle in Evernote hinein schaffen könnte, ich suche ja immer noch nach dem optimalen Weg, wie wir zum Beispiel unsere Show notes zusammentragen. Klar, wir könnten jetzt so Google Docs benutzen, aber ehrlich gesagt, Google Docs, da rollt ihr doch auch mit den Augen, oder?
Also ich hab mein...
Was hast du hier in so einem Shared Text Dokument Sachen zu erfassen?
Deswegen macht doch so ein Zeug nicht.
Also mein Workflow ist da, ich hab mir irgendwann mal so ein Pinboard-Account gekauft, die kosten ja auch ein bisschen Geld. Und ich geh halt in Reader, sage ich, wenn ich irgendwie eine spannende Story finde, pack das in Pinboard, schreib da als TechMM rein für Mobile Max und dann habe ich hier beim nächsten Mal die Liste mit Sachen, die mir im Laufe der zwei Wochen aufgefallen sind, die ich spannend fand. Das ist so, da ist jetzt noch nichts vorsortiert oder sowas, aber das ist ein...
So benutzt du das jetzt auch?
So benutze ich das, ja. Okay. Und das benutze ich auch für alles, was ich spannend finde. Und ich überlege jetzt gerade, wie ich dann vielleicht noch da...
Das ist gut, wenn es um Links geht, aber es geht ja nicht immer um Links. Das sind manchmal auch einfach nur Ideen, Themen, Programme.
Ja, im schlimmsten Fall, also im schlimmsten Fall, Twitterst du die Idee rasch und dann hast du wieder einen Link.
Weil, will ich ja nicht unbedingt öffentlich machen.
Ja, also es ist nicht die perfekte Lösung. Also gerade das mit den Links, da hast du recht, das geht mir auch mitunter so. Führt dann halt dazu, dass ich manchmal Sachen twittere, die ich eigentlich nur in der Sendung haben möchte. Aber die vorher noch mal so ein bisschen ventilieren zu lassen, ist ja auch nicht so schlecht. Und sich höherer Feedback dazu eignet.
Man kann hier bei Evernote nichts in ein Dokument hinzufügen. Also von daher ist das vielleicht auch nur alles ein Traum. Jetzt kommen natürlich gleich alle wieder hier mit Etherpad. Etherpad höre ich natürlich auch immer so im Hinterkopf. Aber das ist halt auch immer alles nur, das ist alles immer nur Text.
Läuft Etherpad mittlerweile vernünftig auf dem iPad? Werden wir mal versuchen.
Soweit ich weiß, gibt es aber noch keine ordentliche iOS-Unterstützung. Aber ich brauche einfach Native Clients. Ich will nicht in Webseiten rumschreiben. Ich hasse das. Das ist mir einfach zu langsam, zu fehleranfällig.
Und was ist hier mit SubEaseEdit? Ich habe da vor Jahren schon gesagt, die 5Edit sollten mal...
Er arbeitet nicht mit Servern zusammen.
Ja, habe ich vor Jahren gesagt, die sollen nur Server-Apps machen, wo man irgendwie...
Das habe ich denen auch schon...
Warum machen die das nicht?
Weil die jetzt Brettspiele programmieren und glücklich sind.
Immer noch?
Hat manchmal damit zu tun.
Keine Ahnung, die sehen da irgendwie für sich keinen Markt oder keine Herausforderung, ich weiß es nicht. Ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Ich würde es ja geil finden, wenn man auch bei SysSenseit irgendwie seine eigenen Channels reinpacken könnte, weil dann könnte es dann nämlich dann... würde man sich zur Not seinen eigenen Dienst dran klöppeln und alles wäre gut. Und vor allen Dingen wofür es auch geil wäre, weil gerade so iPad-Integration, also genau dieses Problem, das du angesprochen hast, dass man irgendwie einen Workflow hinkriegen kann und da ist das iPad nicht wirklich gut drinne, aber dadurch, dass so unglaublich viele iPad-Apps solche Workflows drinne haben, wie zum Beispiel diese Sharing-Funktion in Reader, könnte man, wenn man hier bei Ipsys, Zensette auch eigene Channels einbauen könnte, könnte man sich dann zumindest einen Workflow anlegen. Also ich hatte das zum Beispiel überlegt für den Fall, ich sitze ja immer an meinem Tabular Taps, was meine Chrome-Taps dann aufs iPhone oder aufs iPad bringt und umgekehrt. Und hätte da gerne so eine Funktion drin, dass ich im Reader direkt sagen kann, ach, dieses Video würde ich mir nachher gerne auf dem Mac angucken zum Beispiel und einfach nur schick das mal rüber auf den Mac und sobald ich am Mac sitze, macht den entsprechenden Tab in Safari oder in Chrome oder wo auch immer auf. Und dann kann ich mir da das Video schön angucken. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Chance, dass ich da irgendwie eine Reader-Integration reinkriege, relativ gering und ich müsste mich halt mit jedem der Autoren von populären Apps zusammensetzen. Oder ich schreib erstmal, das ist natürlich nur eine Zwischenlösung, aber ich schreib erstmal so ein Ifs, Is, and Sets Channel rein und sag, hier kann man es mit Reader verbinden und hier kannst du es mit jedem Dienst verbinden und wärt glücklich.
Na ja, eigentlich will ich ja nach wie vor nur einen Outliner haben, aber scheint ja irgendwie nicht.
Ja, aber das Internet transformiert langsam zu einem Outliner.
Merkst du's? Wo?
Na ja, irgendwann wirst du ja einen Outliner zusammenklicken können. Und der wird kaum mehr als ein halbes Atomkraftwerk Strom verbrauchen.
Ich will nur einen Outliner, der SYNKT in Echtzeit. Mehr will ich nicht. Ich bin nach wie vor der Meinung, das wäre einfach The Note-Taking-Tool TM. Ich verstehe nicht, warum das keiner versteht. Das ist ganz ein Rich-Text-Geschreibe, das ist doch nicht produktiv. Ja guck mal, ich meine wir machen hier Show. Wir wollen hier eine Show fahren. So, wir brauchen Notizen. Wir müssen die in eine hierarchische Struktur bringen. Und in eine Reihenfolge. Ja, das ist auch die Anforderung. Ich verstehe die Problematik. Wir sagen, wir wollen über das iPhone reden. Und dann mache ich da eine Ebene darunter. Und dann trage ich da ein, über welche Aspekte von dem iPhone wir reden würden. Das ist einfach die Hierarchie. Das klappt aus. Und manchmal willst du das eine dann halt dann innerhalb dieser Unterhierarchie irgendwie austauschen. Dann willst du die Reihenfolge ändern. Und dann willst du vielleicht das ganze iPhone-Thema ans Ende oder Anfang stellen. Und solche Umschaufelungen machst du einfach nicht in Textdokumenten. Weil du dann mit diesem ganzen Cut-and-Paste-Scheiß spätestens nachdem es dann auch unter dir, während es irgendwie versucht, sich mit irgendeinem bekloppten Server im Hintergrund unter deinem Arsch wegzusünden, zerstörst du dir einfach das ganze Dokument. Dir gehen einfach entweder Textteile verloren oder du hast sie dann doppelt drin. Das hab ich laufend permanent mit all diesen Diensten. Das ist einfach zu nichts zu gebrauchen. So und wenn du einfach so einen ganz einfachen Outliner hast, und ich finde auch Omni-Outliner so toll ich das Programm finde, ich würde es lieber in der Version 3 benutzen. Ich finde diese ganze Version 4 seitdem, die da mit Rich Text und so weiter angefangen haben und du noch nicht mal mehr sagen kannst, dass irgendwas keine Formatierung haben soll. Ich will keine Formatierung. Ich will einfach nur Text. Kein Font und Italic und Scheiß und Fontgrößen, Brimborium, wo ich dann, wenn ich mir von der Website irgendwas reinkopiere, dann nichts mehr lesen kann. Farben und Quatsch. Einfach nur Text und Hierarchie und Drängen und Droppen und Fertig- und Reihenfolge und ein paar Tastatur-Shotcards. Und dann hängst du da iCloud dahinter oder was weiß ich für einen Server, der einfach von vornherein darauf getrimmt ist, dass er drei Dinge sicherstellt. Es muss scheiße schnell sein, also instantan. Instant Sync. Nichts ist ungesynced. Nicht irgendwie einmal die Minute Sync ich dann mal. Sondern es ist halt einfach, du änderst was und so bang ist es irgendwie draußen. Sofort. Und dann muss es sofort auch in alle anderen Clients sofort hinein populieren. Also wenn du irgendwie noch dasselbe Dokument auf dem anderen Rechner offen hast, paff, sofort.
Naja, aber iCloud würde dafür wieder nicht ausreichen, weil iCloud kann kein Sharing mit anderen Leuten.
Wie auch immer, iCloud oder was auch immer, ist es mir egal. Dann programmiert man da halt irgendwie einen Erlang in seinen eigenen Server und so.
Naja, dann wird schon viel Arbeit. Verdammt viel Arbeit.
Ja gut, was heißt verdammt viel Arbeit? Es gibt genug Systeme, die gezeigt haben, dass das geht.
Ja, also dass das geht, ist gar keine Frage.
So. Und dritte und wichtigste Anforderung ist, es darf nie was kaputt gehen. Informatische Herausforderung.
Ja, aber schnell und es darf nie was kaputt gehen. Also die Anforderung, die echt Zeit kostet, Arbeit und Hirn und weiss ja was. Soll ich hier mal kurz über die TV-Liga ein bisschen rumphilosophieren?
Ich muss mal kurz meine Notizen ein bisschen... Jetzt schon über Fernsehen reden.
Was hast du denn sonst noch?
Weiß nicht. Ich wollte ein bisschen über Podcasting abstrehen. Das kann man auch machen.
Das ist auch gut.
Obbei ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich da wirklich schon so final eine Aussage zu machen kann. Wir sollten vielleicht über Fernsehen reden. Dennis, worüber willst du denn reden? Ich meine, Apple hat hier diesen ALAC., diesen Apple Lossless-Kolik.
Freigeregt nach sieben Jahren.
War das sieben Jahre her?
Also der Decoder haben sie ja sofort reverse-ingeniert. Den gibt es ja schon ganz schön lange. Zum ALAC., also jetzt von anderen, bevor Apple das gemacht hat, weil natürlich wollten viele schon dieses Apple Lossless-Format auch können. Der Encoder kam dann eine Weile später. Also so gesehen ist das alles schon, interessiert das jetzt keinen Schwein mehr, weil eigentlich, das gibt es alles schon. Aber jetzt hat es halt Apple nochmal richtig als Source-Release. Jetzt kann man sich halt das nochmal in richtig, in schneller, vielleicht auch nicht in schneller, wer weiß. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Open Source oder die reverse-ingenierten Dinge, wie die da mithalten können, habe ich nicht geguckt. Aber ja, ist jetzt nicht so, also hat keinen vom Hocker gehauen mehr. War alles schon reverse-ingeniert. Und das soll, also damals habe ich gelesen, dass es wohl auch ziemlich flackähnlich ist. Und zwar haben die mehr oder weniger das gemacht wie Flack, nur nicht flackkomprimiert ein bisschen besser. Braucht dafür aber auch irgendwie nochmal mehr Rechenpower. Und wahrscheinlich hat sich Apple gedacht, naja für die 1% bessere Komprimierung, irgendwie 10-20% mehr Zeit, dann sparen wir uns das. Und dann kostet es halt nicht so viel Batteriepower auf dem iPhone oder wie auch immer. Oder was sie sich damals dabei schon gedacht haben.
Erpotexpress benutzt das doch, oder?
Ja, genau. Das ist das Standardformat für Airplay eigentlich. Wobei ich mir da in der Zwischenzeit nicht mehr so sicher bin.
Ob sie das immer noch machen?
Ja, ob sie es inzwischen vielleicht schon dann doch, das MP3 oder was auch immer, dann direkt da. Oder MP4. Oder MP4 dann direkt schicken, ja.
Kann gut sein. Also so HEAAC ist natürlich da deutlich sparsamer.
Wenn die neueren Chips dann halt so können. Aber so haben sie natürlich auch gesagt, okay, dieses Apple-Loseless ist so die Basis.
Hauen wir es einfach mal raus, weil es natürlich immerhin, was das Gute ist, du kannst halt jetzt wie mit Flagg eben das gut zum Archivieren benutzen.
Ja, also ich bin jeder Meinung, das Losless ist... Ich muss dann nachher gleich noch von meinem Miniprojekt erzählen, ich brauch da glaube ich noch ein bisschen Hilfe oder so. Also, ich hab ja irgendwie noch hier meinen uralt Lieblingsgame, und zwar Lord Runner. Das Scheißding hat 150 Level. Und ich würde gerne von 150 Level kleine Videos machen, wie man die zu zocken hat. Einfach nur so, weil ich Spaß hab, hobbymäßig. Ich weiß nicht, wie man so eine uralte Sache sich noch mal schick macht. So eine schicke Webseite. Bisher hatte ich eine, wo halt nur ein Bild ist, wie die Levels so aussehen, wie die anfangen, damit man schon mal gucken kann. Und ich will aber das gleiche haben mit 150 kleinen Videos, am besten auch im Web. Von mir aus HTML5, wie auch immer. Und jetzt ist es so, dass natürlich, wenn man hier den C64, also das ist ein C64-Game, wenn man das im Emulator spielt, dann kann man da auch mitschneiden, das ist alles gar kein Problem. Und bei so einem Game, weil außer den Figuren, die da so rumrennen, wenn die Leute jetzt so laut dran erkennen, wenn nicht, sondern sie googeln, außer den Figuren bewegt sich ja nichts. Das heißt, es lässt sich eigentlich prima weg komprimieren, wenn man da von Movies macht. Das Problem ist nur, wenn du natürlich einen lossy-Codec benutzt, dann machen die also wieder Rauschen und Komprimieren und Zeug und dann ist doch die Änderung von einem Bild zum nächsten, weil die da so rumrauschen, größer als wenn du einen lossless-Codec hättest. Und was ich gerne hätte, ist, diesen X264 gibt es jetzt seit einer Weile auch mit lossless-Feature, dass du Juf444 irgendwie lossless-encoden kannst und eigentlich müssten dann da ultra kleine Videos bei rausfallen, weil sich ja fast überhaupt gar nichts ändert in der ganzen Zeit und da weiß nicht, wenn da einer noch irgendwie coole Ideen hat, irgendwie coole Tools, weil ich habe es schon mit Handbrake probiert, aber ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob der X264 da drin das schon so richtig kann.
Aber der bewegt sich doch fast nichts bei Loadrunner, ich meine, wo siehst du denn da Artefakte-Probleme, wenn dieser kleine Freak da irgendwie durch die Gegend läuft?
Na ein Problem ist schon, das normale MPEG4 hat halt nicht, die benutzen Juf420, das heißt, dass du nicht für einen Punkt die Farbe setzen kannst, sondern immer nur für, also nicht für einen Pixel die Farbe setzt, sondern für zwei Pixel. Also Helligkeit ist pro Pixel, aber Farbe ist nur pro zwei Pixel, deswegen Juf420. Und es gibt aber halt auch den Juf444-Kodec, wo wirklich alles, du direkt pixelmäßig setzen kannst und dann hast du da keine Verluste mehr, weil...
Du meinst einfach, jeder Pixel soll einfach die Originalfarbe haben?
Genau, sonst gerade bei Rot und Loadrunner ist halt nur, die Steine sind rot. Kannst du das Rot halt nur setzen auf zwei Pixel und dann ist alles, wenn du da einen Punkt setzt oder einen Punkt sehen würdest, in Loadrunner wären auf einmal zwei Punkte.
Aber ist das Loadrunner auf dem C64 nicht sowieso in diesem Doppelpixel-Farb-Modus, wo auf dem C64 sowieso immer nur eine Farbe für zwei Pixel hast?
Nee, nee, nee. Ich hab das gemacht, ganz normal encoded und dann waren bestimmte Sachen, wenn die Figur rüberläuft, dann wabert es da so rum und so und so sah das irgendwie scheiße aus. Deswegen hab ich letztens per Twitter auch schon nach diesem Animation-Codec gefragt. Aufnehmen könnte ich es jetzt erstmal, aber Animation macht natürlich gleich mal 300 MB für 1-2 Minuten zocken oder so, obwohl es auch nur, keine Ahnung, so ein Minischirm ist ja nicht riesengroß. Wenn man das aber wegkomprimieren würde, dann könnte man wirklich sich eine HTML-Seite mit lauter kleinen Minivideos machen, die, keine Ahnung, dann so 50 oder 100 oder von mir aus so ein dicker Level, dann mal ein halbes Megabyte groß ist. Aber es ist ja heutzutage nicht.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich schon einfacher, einen C64-Emulator in JavaScript zu schreiben und es darin irgendwie zu coden. Du nimmst einfach die Engine aus Loadrunner raus?
Diese Engines von heute, die sind Cycle-genau und wenn bestimmte Opcodes, wenn die sozusagen nicht atomar sind, dann emulieren die sogar das ja. Also die sind wirklich perfect. Die programmieren da heute noch an diesem Soundchip rum, weil der Soundchip innen drin ist halt ein Analogchip und das ist halt nicht so easy, den digital nachzukoden, weil der halt so auch so analogisch ist, deswegen ist der ja auch so geil gewesen. Die finden ja alle toll heute, die Musiker, teilweise, und da sind die immer noch am basteln, um noch den Soundchip immer noch zu optimieren, dass sie wirklich den original hinkriegen.
Man kann ernst, es gibt doch diesen Firefox-PC, einen kompletten PC, da kannst du auch Loadrunner einpacken. Es gibt einen JavaScript-PC, komplett, und der läuft nur, lief zumindest damals nur in Firefox so richtig schnell.
Ok, also, Codec gesucht, ja, du willst sozusagen Animated GIF aber in ordentlich.
Ich brauch ein Tool, mit dem ich Quicktime-Videos lossless MPEG-4-Videos wandeln kann, und zwar in ultra-klein. X264 kann ja super komprimieren. Und ich will halt lossless komprimieren.
Du hast ja gesagt, dass X264 hat so ein Feature jetzt.
Ja, schon, das musst du erstmal bedienen können, aber du brauchst ja ein Tool. Ich will ja da nicht mit der Commandline ran.
Ja, aber es gibt doch so X264 Fripper auch für einen Mac, also die auch in Quicktime eingebunden sind, ne?
Ja, da hab ich halt alles noch nicht so genau geguckt.
Hier, es gibt diesen X24, also gibt es die insalierbare Quick...
2006 kannst du voll vergessen, da gab's dieses lossless-Feature noch gar nicht.
Das ist halt so neu. X264 in Corona, der ist auch irgendwie... der update sich am laufenden Meter. Letzte Version ist von... Wo steht's? Warte mal. Eben stand's hier gerade in der Übersicht. Januar 2011.
Ja, das ist aber schon eher so die Richtung, ja. Ja, ich muss halt mal gucken, was die Leute da... Vielleicht haben die ja so Ideen. Also ich will auf jeden Fall, dass da ultra kleine Movies rauskommen und dass ich von dem Originalbild soll alles da sein. Also ich will keinen Rauschen, keinen gar nichts, weil ich denke, das ist eher für die Kompression am Ende, dann nehme ich wieder hinderlich. Also jedenfalls, wenn man so einen Animation, so einen perfekten Content hat.
Dennis2342 auf Twitter. Zum Beispiel. Ich werde mal mein Podcast-Applikations-Review für später machen, weil da bin ich... Aber ich bin gerade... Erstmal schwierig mit den Ankündigungen, aber es schiebt das schon sehr lange vor mir her. Aber iOS 5 hat mich jetzt wirklich ein bisschen fertig gemacht und ich bin ein bisschen sauer. Und ich habe jetzt irgendwie angefangen, ich habe bis vor zwei Wochen irgendwie alle meine Podcasts aus iTunes rausgeschmissen. Also beziehungsweise das Syncing habe ich rausgeschmissen. Ich synke also nicht mehr mit iTunes, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass ich das mal machen würde. Und probiere jetzt so verschiedene Podcast-Apps aus und habe so vor, es jetzt mit jeder App mal so ein, zwei Wochen zu versuchen, um einfach mal ein bisschen Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie es sonst noch so sein könnte und was mir so fehlt. Und ja, ich hoffe, dass ich am Ende mal so ein Big Picture auch erziele, was ich eigentlich gerne hätte. Also, dass man auch mal ein Statement machen kann in der Hinsicht. Jetzt probiere ich es erstmal mit Instacast. Es ist schon ein riesen Vorteil, wenn einfach das Device selber die Podcasts sieht und es ist mir einfach vollkommen unerklärlich, wie man das jetzt in iOS 5 hat, einfach so sträflich ignorieren können. Also es tut sich auch einfach überhaupt gar nichts in diesem ganzen Podcastsektor. Alles, was Apple in letzter Zeit an Verbesserungen gebracht hat, in Anführungsstrichen, waren eigentlich keine. Also es ist eigentlich alles nur irgendwie bekloppter geworden.
Na vielleicht träumen sie es ja mal groß auf.
Ich höre Gerüchte. Ich habe da so Unken-Rufen-Dinge, aber ich glaube, dass erst wenn ich da was Konkretes sehe und bis dahin habe ich da eigentlich nur Angst vor weiteren Verschlimmbesserungen. Ich habe so den Eindruck, dass sie... Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sie jetzt in irgendeiner Form mit Store-Integration, noch mehr Integration in ihren ganzen iCloud-Scheiß und so da versuchen, einem Features zu bieten, in Anführungsstrichen, die dann einfach das noch weiter mit ihrem eingeschränkten Wahn verknüpfen, die aber dann einfach die Freiheit da aus dem Podcasting rausnimmt. Da hab ich wirklich ein bisschen Bammel davor.
Ja, also ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das jetzt, also ich weiß es nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab keinerlei Gerüchte gehört in irgendeiner Richtung. Es gibt ja bei Apple öfters mal sowas, dass sowas längere Zeit still steht, wobei ich finde, dass so auf der technischen Seite im Bereich Podcasting durchaus noch so einiges passieren dürfte. Also das ist so dieses MP3-Datei in einen RSSP3-Knallen. Das ist zwar in sich eine schön einfache Lösung und die lässt sich auch schön einfach implementieren, aber die ist halt vielleicht ein bisschen zu simpel, um den heutigen Anforderungen an ein innovatives Produkt noch gewachsen zu sein. Also ich finde so zum Beispiel Sachen wie man, dass so dieses, ich finde es zum Beispiel schade, dass man immer nur eine Datei reinpacken kann und nicht einfach sagen kann, hier, ich hab so und so viele Dateien und spiele die alle hintereinander ab, als ob das eine Datei wäre. Weil dann könnte man nämlich auch so Sachen machen, wie einzelne Teile auswechseln oder so.
Und du redest jetzt von Podcasts. Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden. Man kann was nicht tun?
Du kannst, ein Podcast ist immer eine MP3, also eine Audiodatei oder eine Mediendatei. Eine Podcast-Folge. Und was ich, also ich persönlich bräuchte das nicht, aber was ich glaube, was so einer Verbreitung von Podcasts ein bisschen im Wege stehen würde, oder ein bisschen helfen würde, wäre, wenn man einzelne Bereiche innerhalb eines Podcasts problemlos austauschen könnte. Also wenn man sagen kann, hier ladet ihr die und die und die Datei runter und spiel sie ab, als ob es da eine wäre. Dann könnte man nämlich sowas machen, wie Werbung auswechseln. Quasi eine Playlist runterladen, genau. Oder was ich halt sehr vermisse, ist das, wobei das vorhin...
Das kannst du aber als Server-seitig alles machen.
Ja, das kannst du server-seitig alles machen, aber zum Beispiel schon allein vernünftig die Gehörermessung. Nehmen wir mal an, du würdest jetzt irgendwie, also dieser Zählpixel, so sehr wie in allen Webseiten, hassen. Das ist sozusagen ein akzeptiertes Instrument der User-Ermittlung. Bau dir unseren Zählpixel ein und wir zeigen dir an, wie viele Besucher deine Seite hast. Sowas könntest du natürlich auch mit einem MP3 machen, in dem du einfach sagst, hier, mach fünf Sekunden, oder mach den Jingle, der kommt von da. Und dann bau das ein und dann hast du, könntest du da dann quasi so einen Zählserver hochziehen. Dann hätte man mal vernünftige Zahlen und könnte einen Server aufsetzen, der vernünftig Podcast-Hörerzahlen ermittelt. Kriegt man so aber nicht hin, weil du musst halt alles über den einen Server scheuchen. Dann ist viel Traffic.
Hörer aushorchen, aber das ist...
Was heißt aushorchen?
Naja, das ist ja im Prinzip dann so eine Hörüberwachung.
Ach komm, wenn man rauskriegt, wie viele Hörer man hat, dann ist das noch keine Überwachung.
Naja, und du weißt ja dann auch wer und so, wenn die sich diese Geräte zurückmelden.
Ja, die sollen, also halt Cookie weiß ja toll was. Also ich meine, es ist ja nur nicht alles per se böse, aber man könnte deutlich mehr machen, wenn dieses Format mehr hergehen würde. Wobei, ein Feature, was ich ja gerne hätte, mal gucken, obwohl so richtig gut kann das leider auch nicht, habe ich das Gefühl, es gibt hier so, mir ist gerade vor der Sendung Pocketcasts empfohlen worden. Für, gibt's für iOS und für Android, offensichtlich. Und es ist auch so eine Software, habe ich überhaupt noch nicht getestet, hatte ein hübsches Alken, mehr kann ich dazu aber im Augenblick noch nicht sagen. Und da, die haben offensichtlich auch eine Sharing-Funktion drin, mit der man sagen kann, guck mal hier, hör dir diesen Podcast an. Wobei, das funktioniert, also die Seite, die mir die Person dazu geschickt hat, wer das auch immer war, tut mir leid, ich hab leider einen Namen vergessen. Ich kann jetzt nicht hier einfach im Webbrowser mal eben reinhören, sondern ich muss das auf meinem iPhone aufmachen, muss mir die Software kaufen, muss dann den Podcast runterladen und das dann machen. Das ist schon mal nicht so, wie ich mir das vorstelle. Also ich finde zum Beispiel andere Hörer auf Stellen hinweisen, finde ich, total sträflich vernachlässig bei Podcasts das Feature. So, haha, hier habe ich gelacht oder da erzählt ja Tim mal wieder Stuss oder da erzählt ja Max eine große Scheiße. So das über Twitter verbreiten. Fände ich toll, wenn das ginge. Geht leider alles nicht. Podcasts, das ist irgendwie sympathisch robuste Technologie, die aber ein bisschen hinter der Zeit ist.
Ja, es könnte da wirklich so viel gehen und ich mache mir wirklich extrem viele Gedanken darüber, was man eigentlich so können sollte und was denn sozusagen evolutionäre Features wären, die man jetzt so problemlos einbauen könnte und was auch revolutionäre Features wären, die derzeit nicht ganz klar ist, wie man die eigentlich realisieren sollte. Also sowas wie Feedback zu einer Sendung geben, während man sie hört. Ich würde ja gerne einen Podcast hören und in dem Moment, wo die Stelle ist, wo mir etwas auffällt, dann würde ich gerne die Feedback-Taste drücken und sofort mein Audiofeedback sprechen.
Ach, sprechen direkt.
Ja, in mein iPhone rein, ohne vom Fahrrad abzusteigen. Ich drücke einfach die fünfte Taste auf meiner Fernbedienung, die heißt Feedback. Früher dachte ich so lange gedrückt halten wäre doch genau das Richtige. Weißt du, ich höre so einen Podcast und dann drücke ich drei Sekunden lang diese Taste, wo jetzt die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Spracherkennungen und Creepy-Scheiße hochkommt. Und ich hätte dann gerne so einen und dann so, ja, unterhaltet euch ja hier bei MobileMax gerade, und ich muss gar nicht mal sagen wann, wo, wie, weil das ist in dem Moment klar, da nämlich, wo ich gerade die Taste gedrückt habe, das ist sozusagen der Bereich, auf den ich mich beziehe. Und wenn da Kapitelmarken drin sind, dann weiß das Telefon auch, auf was es sich bezieht. Und in den Daten können halt auch drin stehen, wie dieses Feedback zurückgeschickt werden soll. Und das Telefon könnte nach dieser Aufnahme das automatisch in irgendeine Outbox packen und mich vielleicht später dann, dann sync das mit Mac und wenn ich da sitze, fragt er mich, naja, willst du das jetzt auch wirklich rausschicken, willst du das nochmal anhören, willst du das ein bisschen schneiden? So wie ich auch, wenn ich ein Video aufnehme mit meinem iPhone, dann kann ich da ja auch den Anfang und das Ende bestimmen und so ein bisschen kroppen. So und dann weiß er auch gleich, wo er es wie hinschickt. Und dann geht das einfach direkt über das Internet, genau an denjenigen, an denen es gedacht ist und der erhält es und der weiß auch sofort, auf welches Kapitel sich das bezieht und so weiter und von wem und mit Bildchen und Hallo und ich bin und du kannst mich hier erreichen. Also das sind so viele, die ich mir denke, das wäre super, wenn es das gäbe.
Bei Soundcloud gibt es so eine Kommentarfunktion halt, also da kann man getippte Kommentare dann rein tippen, aber auch an einer bestimmten Stelle, was ich schon mal ziemlich geil finde. Vor allen Dingen, was ich gerne, ich überlege halt Ewigkeiten, ob ich mal so einen Soundcloud- Podcast-Hörclient schreibe, weil die AP von denen hier jetzt einzubauen, also da gibt es auch so ein Toolkit, so ein Open Source Toolkit, was man sich einfach in sein Projekt, in sein iOS-Projekt reinzieht und dann hat man so einen Soundcloud-Player da drinnen. Das klingt jetzt nicht so, als ob es kompliziert wäre, wollte ich mir mal angucken. Und was ich da halt total geil finden würde, wenn man so einfach nur so ein kleines Bing hört, wenn jemand anders kommentiert hat, an der ich jetzt gerade bin. Ich höre mir so einen Tascherausnehmen. Und nochmal nachgucken. Ich fände es so, die Hörer einzubeziehen, in dem Sinne, die Sendung mitzugestalten, fände ich nach wie vor sehr, sehr geil. Gibt aber leider nichts in dem Bereich. Muss man alles wieder selber machen.
Also Instacast finde ich, in News-Interface fange ich mal nicht mit an. Da weiß man immer nicht so richtig, ist das jetzt hier irgendwie ein Button oder lädt er jetzt runter? Also ich weiß immer nicht, ob die Dateien jetzt da sind oder nicht oder gestreamt werden und wann er die holt und warum er jetzt auf alle Dateien... Ja, dann fängt er irgendwie alle 60 Dateien, die im Feed sind, irgendwie runterzuladen. Also das Maß an Control, was ich da habe, das ist extrem begrenzt. Also diese Software ist sicherlich nicht das Ende vom Lied, aber gegenüber dem normalen Podcasting, so wie es auf dem iPhone drauf ist, hast du zumindest schon mal den Vorteil, das Ding checkt selber. Es benutzt irgendwie Push-Nachrichten, um irgendwie mir zu sagen, was Sache ist, auch wenn ich mit fünf Nachrichten, die mir sagen, dass es neue Episoden gibt, jetzt so auch nichts anfangen kann. Okay, danke, schön, dass du mich darauf hingewiesen hast. Warum musst du mir das fünfmal hintereinander sagen und was soll ich jetzt damit tun?
Ach, Notifications, oder was schickt er dir?
Also das ist alles so ein bisschen würd. Aber immerhin, du hast irgendwie iCloud-Support jetzt drin, das heißt, der synkt ja irgendwie deine Feed-Listen. Ich weiß nicht, ob er auch den Play...
Ich glaube, er synchronisiert auch...
.Marker synchronisiert, ich denke auch, aber ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert. Und vor allem, was so eine glaring omission ist in dem Podcast-Interface auf dem iPhone, was einfach sowieso nur sackt derzeit, du kannst ja halt die Show-Notes der Sendung anschauen, bevor du dir die Sendung abspielst. Auf dem iPhone siehst du ja noch nicht mal den ganzen Titel einer Sendung. Und da viele Leute in ihrem Podcast ja auch immer noch sowas wie Podcast vom Datum bla bla bla und dann irgendwie 10 km weiter kommt dann mal der Titel, was auf dem iPhone halt nicht zu sehen ist, weil er dir immer nur die ersten 30, 40 Zeichen anzeigt, ist natürlich wenig geholfen. Früher auf dem iPod, da haben sie zumindest noch den Titel durchgescrollt. Ja, das ist ja auch nicht mehr drin. Ja, und dann dieser Scheiß mit, das macht Instacast dann aber wiederum auch so, ne? Ist eine Sendung, hast du zwei Sendungen so drin. Weißt du, die eine fertig, dann macht er gleich mit der nächsten weiter. Kann man ausschalten?
Nee, ich weiß nicht, ob man das bei Instacast ausschalten kann. Ich hab, ich, ich...
Das hätte man nie einschalten sollen. Das ist einfach, das ist einfach Bullshit. Ich meine, okay, meinst du...
Hängt immer vom Podcast an.
Ja, genau. Per Podcast-Setting und so weiter geschenkt. Aber der Default hat das nicht zu sein. Und das ist, das ist einfach alles ganz, ganz furchtbar so.
Na ich kann ja, also ich hab Instacast auch lange benutzt. Bin dann irgendwann mal umgestiegen. Also war so halb zufrieden mit. Machte grob das, was ich wollte, nämlich über WLAN Podcast runterladen. Und das funktionierte alle so weit. Dann hab ich jetzt, ähm... Ach genau, als ich dann die iOS 5 Beta drauf hatte, dann hat Instacaster gesponnen. Da kann jetzt Instacaster nix für. Aber dann hab ich mir noch mal Podcast angeguckt, von eben, als die Version 3.0 rauskam. Ähm, das ist vom Interface... Also das ist auch nicht schlecht. Was die machen ist, die können dich daran erinnern, wenn eine neue Sendung rauskommt, so per Push-Notification. Das ist schon ganz cool. Das kann Instacast mittlerweile auch, ne?
Ich glaube ja.
Ähm, und dann war ich erst mal damit ziemlich glücklich so ne Zeit lang. Also das Interface leider furchtbar. Also was ich da zum Beispiel ganz furchtbar finde ist, du hast so ein Download-Fenster, wo du siehst, ja bei Instacast da sieht man nicht so vernünftig, was gerade runtergeladen wird, ne? Bei Podcast, da gibt es dafür einen eigenen View, wo ich sehe, was wird gerade runtergeladen. Und dann ist ja der Podcast drin und dann steht da irgendwann mal fertig runtergeladen. Und dann würde ich jetzt gerne diesen Podcast einfach nehmen und antippen und direkt hören. Nein, muss ich aus diesem Fenster raus, muss zurückgehen, muss den Podcast und erst dann kann ich ihn hören. Also da sind so ein paar Sachen, die echt schlecht durchdacht sind. Und jetzt habe ich, als du nachgefragt hast, welche Clients denn alle so verwenden, da bin ich mal auf Downcast gestoßen und hab den jetzt nochmal probiert. Und mit dem bin ich im Augenblick sehr zufrieden. Der hat eine Option in den Einstellungen, leider nicht auf Podcast-Base, sondern nur global automatisch weitermachen zum nächsten Podcast oder nicht. Der hat, was ja auch immer wichtig ist, wie kriege ich meine Podcasts da rein? Da kann man irgendwie eine OPML-Datei meistens importieren in Dropbox. Das ist jetzt natürlich nicht unbedingt die Schwachstelle des eigentlichen Podcasting-Clients, sondern mehr so die Schwäche von Apple, warum sie da noch nicht so eine vernünftige Möglichkeit geschaffen haben, wie man hier Dateiaustausch macht, aber eben außer iCloud, was jetzt noch zu frisch ist, offensichtlich. Und darum finde ich immer so ein Podcast-Discovery-Feature, also dass man irgendwie anfängt, den Namen eines Podcasts zu finden und der trägt einem automatisch die URL ein. Ganz geil. Und das hat Instacaster, hat das auch für deutsche Podcasts, was sehr angenehm ist. Podcasts leider nicht. Also CAE und Mobile Maps und sowas, kriegt man darüber alles nicht. Und Podcasts, Downcast hat das aber.
Weißt du, was Instacast verwendet, um Podcasts zu suchen?
Ich glaube, die suchen die iTunes-Library ab. Wie denn?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich will mir einen sowas mal gehört zu haben, ich weiß es aber, ich hab mich nie mit beschäftigt. Also dass die quasi den Store absuchen.
Wie kann man den Podcast so absuchen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, aber ich meine, es sind doch... Es gibt doch von allen zu jedem Podcast gibt es auch noch eine Webseite.
Ja gut, aber wie willst du die crawlen?
Ja, keine Ahnung, vielleicht sind die IDs...
Wie willst du die suchen? Du kannst halt nicht die ganzen Webseiten durchcrawlen oder den ganzen... Also du müsstest ja dann all diese Seiten durchspilern und indizieren.
Ja, ich nehme an, das machen die für ihren Index. Ich weiß, wahrscheinlich gibt es einfach öffentliche Podcast-Sammlungen, wo dann doch genug Podcasts drin stehen.
Ach ja? Kenn ich nicht. Also es gibt verschiedenste Verzeichnisse, aber die sind halt alle irgendwie güllehue. Also ich war erstaunt darüber, wie zuverlässig ich bislang zumindest die Podcasts, die ich jetzt bisher gesucht habe, bei Instacast gefunden habe. Aber ich habe noch keine Beschreibung gefunden, wo mal drinsteht, was der eigentlich konsultiert. Also was muss ich dafür tun, um bei Instacast gefunden zu werden? Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht habe ich da irgendwas übersehen, falls irgendjemand das weiß.
Also bei Podcasts war das scheiße. Da funktioniert das hervorragend für amerikanische Podcasts, aber nicht für deutsche. Jetzt ist Instacast von Deutschen, da erwartet man sowas. Bei Downcast funktioniert das auch super. Also da findet man auch alle deutschen Podcasts.
Instacast ist von Deutschen.
Da kannst du bestimmt auch mal nachfragen, dann kriegste garantiert auch Betas.
Na Betas will ich nicht, ich will funktionierende Software haben. Ne, was ich sage ist, Instacast echt, wo sind die denn Jungs?
Genau, so ist es.
Was gekillt? Die Webseite von denen oder was? Der Rest funktioniert noch? Internet? Internet fluppt. Gröbel, wie Media kommen. Gucken wir mal, fragen wir mal hier die Domänen.
Ach, die haben auch dieses Snowtape Radio.
Ludwigsburg. Guck an. Ludwigsburg. So, das ist wieder so weit weg. Ja, naja, also ich kann jetzt hier noch nicht so richtig aus dem vollen schöpfen, aber da muss ich einfach was tun. Und wenn ihr, also bitte flutet mich jetzt nicht mit jedem Scheiß zu, weil mein Mail-Backlog ist eh schon größer als 300 Mails. Aber was will ich eigentlich wissen? Coole Sachen, die wirklich gut sind, die irgendwo gut gelöst sind oder die, sagen wir mal, das Hören von Podcasts einfacher machen. So, wenn ihr da irgendwelche entweder selber gute Ideen habt, wie es sein sollte, wenn ihr Ideen hättet, wie auch das iPhone-User-Interface sich vielleicht ändern sollte, was ihr sozusagen echt vermisst und was euch mehr von Podcasts geben würde und die sich irgendwie realistisch auch vielleicht umsetzen ließen, sowas würde ich gerne da einbauen. Also ich schreib da ein längeres, ich will ein längeres Paper schreiben zu dem Thema.
Und du musst irgendeine arme Sau das umsetzen? Okay, die arme Sau.
Ja oder wer auch sonst. Also es ist mir dann egal, wer das umsetzt. Aber mir geht es jetzt konkret einfach...
Aber es muss dabei was passieren.
Ich schreib es jetzt aber mal mit der Perspektive iPhone. Das kann meinetwegen auch genauso natürlich auf irgendeinem beliebigen anderen Gerät dieser Art, Android, was auch immer es sein soll, Windows als Applikation oder als OS-Feature genützt werden. Klar, kein Problem. Das ist nicht das Ding. Es geht auch mehr so um den Workflow. Und es geht mir auch so ein bisschen darum, das Modell Podcast da ein bisschen weiter zu denken und vor allem auch mal klar zu machen, dass es eben was anderes ist als Musik. Dass man das einfach nicht genauso behandeln darf.
Hier hat gerade jemand im Chat Google Listen empfohlen. Das wird jedes Mal empfohlen, wenn man nach einem gut Podcasting Client fragt. Google Listen ist kein guter Podcast Client. Das ist jetzt zugegebenermaßen schon eine Weile her, aber als ich damals dieses Nexus One hatte, habe ich auch dieses Google Listen ausprobiert. Und Google Listen war ein totaler Pain in the ass. Das ist abgestürzt ohne Ende. Die Reader-Integration ist doof. Es kann nichts, also es ist echt ey. Also, das ist, ich hoffe, es gibt für Android bessere Podcasting Clients.
Ja, ich will das Thema jetzt nicht ewig in die Länge ziehen, aber wenn du sowieso dir Podcast angeschaut hast mit diesem Podcaster, hast du das geschneit? Weil es gibt da einen Podcaster, was sozusagen die Urversion ist, die es von Anfang an gab, weil die waren ja mal die ersten, und dann gibt es einen Podcaster 3 im Store.
Okay.
Die Webseite erklärt dazu wenig, und die Version von dem anderen ist aber vier.
Also ich hab die mit dem blauen Icon, das Ding da hab ich.
Ja, das hab ich auch. Und dann gibt es noch einen Podcaster 3, das hat dasselbe Icon grün. Sieht auch genauso aus, ist auch derselbe Autor und alles. Völlig unklar. Ja, und auf der Webseite.
Vielleicht läuft es noch auf irgendwelchen älteren iOS-Versionen.
Ich hab mal gehört, dass es die neue Version sein soll, aber das kann ich hier irgendwie auch nicht so richtig finden. Ich meine, warum hat er das dann noch?
Also es gibt Formally RSS Player Podcast Client.
For even more features check out Podcaster 4.
Ach, okay.
Schalte da bei Podcaster 3.
Das gibt es auch noch oder was?
Podcaster 4. Ach so, ja weiß ich nicht, wie er das meint.
Also Podcaster 3 erfordert iOS 4 oder neuer und Podcaster 4 erfordert iOS 4 oder neuer.
Wo steht das denn?
Unten links Voraussetzung.
Wo findest du denn Podcaster 4?
Naja der blaue Teil halt. Ich weiß jetzt ja nicht, was du gerade vor dir hast.
Na der heißt Podcaster, aber hat die Version 4.3?
Genau. Also den hab ich ausprobiert, wie gesagt kann man machen, ist aber leider nicht.
Confusing.
Ich vermute mal, dass er aus irgendwelchen Gründen vielleicht auch Geld für die neue Version haben. Und hat darum jetzt Support noch die alte mit und nötigt seinen Usern nochmal 79 Cent an, worüber sie sich wahrscheinlich ganz furchtbar aufregen werden und sofort dafür steinigen werden. Das ist so ein neues Hobby von mir geworden, im App Store bei irgendwelchen Apps nachzugucken, Kritik zu lesen, wie sich Leute darüber aufregen, dass sie dafür 79 Cent ihres Einkommens ausgegeben haben.
Das macht manchmal Spaß.
Soll ich mal so ein bisschen was hier...
Dennis, was ist mit dir?
Habe ich ja nicht mit zu tun.
Und würdest du einen Fernseher kaufen, wenn Apple einbaut?
Na ja, sagen wir mal so. Die bauen ja nicht das, was man sich... Sind wir schon bei dem Thema? Jetzt sind wir bei dem Thema. Voll, ich kann voll einspringen. Geil. Also Fernsehen ist ja... Wenn man sich jetzt so Fernsehen vorstellt, das ist ja irgendwie, machst du an, kommt die Hitparade der Volksmusik. Das ist ja das, was ich mir heutzutage unter Fernseher vorstelle. So, das ist nicht das, was ich mir vorstelle, wenn du sagst, ob ich mir von Apple ein Fernseher kaufe. Ich würde mir... Also was ich jetzt bräuchte sozusagen, wo Bedarf wäre bei mir, wäre für einen großen Bildschirm, wo ich irgendwie meine Movies gucken kann. Und von mir aus kann da auch noch Fernsehen kommen, aber die bringen ja nicht nur ein Fernseher raus, sondern das muss ja irgendwie hier mit meiner... Wie hieß das bei Apple? Der iHub oder überhaupt der Digital Hub irgendwie, das muss ja alles irgendwie eins und integriert, Airplay, tralala, und hast du nicht gesehen, volles Programm, Internet und weißt schon. Und wahrscheinlich sogar Apps und Siri muss ja irgendwie das Ding alles irgendwie können. Würde ich mal behaupten, sonst bräuchten die da gar nicht antreten, weil Fernseher kann ich mir auch billiger von woanders kaufen, wenn die nichts können.
Ach, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass man an dem Konzept Fernseher genug verbessern könnte, dass Apple da durchaus... Also ich glaub auch nicht so richtig dran, dass wirklich ein Fernseher von ihnen kommen wird. Ich find's lustig, wie ihr die Gerüchteküche da so hochschießt aufgrund dieses einen Zitats. Aber, also zum Beispiel ein Fernseher, der selbst von alleine angeht, sobald ein Airplay-Signal bekommt. Also ich fang hier an, ich sag auf meinem iPhone, du zeig mal Fotos und dann geht der Fernseher an. Ich brauch da nicht noch irgendwelche Knöpfe drücken und die Fernbedienung raussuchen und so was. Weil das find ich im Augenblick total nervig, dass dieses Gerät nicht von alleine angeht, sobald der Signal angeht.
Welches Gerät?
Der Fernseher.
Ach so deiner?
Mein Fernseher. Wenn ich auf dem iPhone sage, ich sitze hier mit ein paar Freunden und die wollen gerne...
Wo ist der angeschlossen?
Was? Also mein Apple TV hängt da dran. Und ich hätte jetzt natürlich gerne, dass sobald da ein Signal kommt auf dem... Also ich sitze da, will jemanden Fotos zeigen, so Situation, sage, zeigt das auf dem Apple TV an, passiert erst mal gar nichts. Weil dann muss ich die Fernbedienung für den Fernseher raussuchen und dann muss ich da noch und umschalten. Und das dauert alles und das ist alles furchtbar nervig. Das wäre Fernseher geht an. Das wäre ein tolles Feature. Dann diese berühmten Fernbedienungen mit den unglaublich vielen Buttons. Also ich finde das nach wie vor eine totale Katastrophe, weil die haben... Also wenn man sich so... Stellt euch mal die Fernbedienung von eurem Fernseher vor und jetzt haben die meisten Fernseher nach wie vor brauchen die ja noch irgendwie eine Satbox oder eine Cablebox oder eine weiß der Teufel was Box, gerade in Amerika. Also irgendwas, mit dem man dann das eigentliche HD-Signal empfängt oder eben seine Playstation oder seine Blu-ray-Clair.
Da hast du schon zweifelnde Fernbedienung, wenn dein Fernseher es nicht integriert hat, genau.
Nein, nicht nur das, sondern allein um diese ganzen Geräte zu wechseln, also um die analogen Fernsehkanäle zu wechseln, ist das halbe Interface da, da sind Sendertasten und irgendwas und es funktioniert zwar alles scheiße, aber die 98% der Tastatur sind nur da für die Fernbedienung und dann hast du im Allgemeinen unten eine Taste, dieses Source-Button, mit der du zwischen deinen 128 Geräten durchschalten musst. Und ey!
Ich verstehe das auch nicht, warum dieses HDMI keine Enumeration hat zum Beispiel. Also ich meine, warum sollen die Geräte über HDMI nicht einfach dem Fernseher sagen, wie viele Kanäle sie haben und dann kannst du sie einfach vom Fernseher aus abrufen?
Stimmt, wäre total sinnvoll.
Hab ich noch nie begriffen, aber so denken die halt nicht.
Na es ist, was bei Löwen immerhin geht, da kannst du HDMI-Devices immerhin auf so Nummerntasten legen. Also kannst du sagen, HDMI-Gerät 1 ist meine 1 und dann hast du keinen Fernsehsender auf der 1, sondern hast du da das HDMI.
Na gut, aber du willst ja nicht Geräte auswählen, sondern du willst ja Kanäle haben.
Ja, stimmt, das ist tatsächlich die Nummer nicht stufenlos.
Und nicht einfach sagen, ich hab hier die und die Kanäle und wenn du halt von 17 auf 18 hochdrückst, dann wechselst du halt von der Satbox auf deine Kabel.
Das wäre eigentlich total simpel.
Aber es ist einfach viel zu einfach. Das versteht diese Branche nicht.
Sie können es dann aber nur mit dem Gerät von ihrem eigenen Hersteller und das ist alles Panning.
Ja, und dann müssen auch irgendwelche Panner, die diese Firmware programmieren, das auch zuverlässig hinkriegen. Und das fällt dann wieder alles auf den Fernseherhersteller zurück.
Dann kommt jetzt immer mehr diese Fernseher mit Internet-Integration. Ich weiß nicht, wie die mittlerweile sind. Als das kam, hab ich mir mal ein Video angeguckt. Ich zeig euch jetzt mal das Twitter-Widget hier. Ja, ich ruf jetzt das Twitter-Widget auf. Und dann hat es ohne Scheiß 20 Sekunden gedauert, bis auf dem Bild schon wieder was passiert ist. Und er hat eine Taste gedrückt aus seiner Fernbedienung und hat 20 Sekunden gedauert, bis dieses Twitter-Widget gestartet war. Und die haben sich nicht geschämt, so was auszuliefern. Die haben so was verkauft und es wird wahrscheinlich ein scheiße teures Gerät gewesen sein, weil es hatte ja Internet-Integration. Also ich glaub, dass ist sowas, diese Internet-Integration von diesen ganzen Geräten, ohne es mir angeguckt zu haben. Ich gehe davon aus, dass die einfach nur schmerzt.
Na ja, ist ja klar, dass das schmerzt. Ich meine, eine beklopptere Branche gibt es ja fast gar nicht. Für so Hifi-Komponenten, die sind, sag mal, was die User-Interfaces betrifft, haben sich die ganz gut entwickelt. Da gibt es auch Ausfälle und so, aber eigentlich kommt jeder so mit dem CD-Player mehr oder weniger klar. Aber darauf wollte ich jetzt gar nicht hinaus. Ich meine, ich will jetzt auch nicht so sehr diese Wird Apple einen Fernseher rausbringen? Ich denke, das steht völlig in den Sternen. Die Frage ist halt auch wirklich nur, wie müsste man es denn eigentlich tun? Was will man denn? Ich meine, es gibt ja nun dieses Apple TV, diese kleine schwarze Box. Und ich merke halt, wie wenig ich das benutze, weil es einfach, naja, gut, ich benutze den Fernseher sowieso selten. Insofern benutze ich ihn vielleicht sogar relativ häufig. Weil wenn ich mal mit dem Fernseher was zu tun habe, dann doch eher, weil ich irgendwie von meinem iPhone jetzt einen Film übertrage oder so. Was mittlerweile die einfachste Methode ist, Fernsehen zu gucken. Weil du musstest dir aus der Mediathek irgendwie runterladen und dann schmeißt du es in deine iTunes über Apple TV und kriegst es dann auf den Bildschirm.
Kennst du, nutzt du Plex? Für dich wäre es ja vielleicht zuhause interessant. Ich hab das heute mal installiert.
Also tue ich nicht.
Das ist, also ich bin ja so ein großer Freund von diesem XBMC Zeug. Das ist dieses Media Center, was jedes Format frisst. Und Plex ist so ein Branch davon, nur für ein Mac, zumindest im Original. Und das ist halt dafür gedacht, dass du hast auf deinem Mac, dein Mac ist dein Media Center, und du hast da deine Daten drauf, deine ganzen Filme und dieses ganze Zeug. Und dann hast du eben noch diese Plex-Interface und dann hast du auch iPhoto-Integration. Das Ganze. Das fand ich nie sonderlich reizvoll, weil ich hab jetzt eigentlich nicht vor, mir da so ein Mac Mini hinzustellen. Habe ich jetzt zwar auch zwischendurch mal kurz überlegt, ob ich das mache, aber ist jetzt erstmal doch wieder gestorben. Was die aber mittlerweile haben, ist halt so ein Plex Media Server. Der läuft auf dem Mac, da lässt er sich wahrscheinlich mit Abstand am einfachsten installieren. Ist nicht total trivial. Ist eigentlich relativ simpel, aber hängt an ein paar Stellen ein bisschen. Für Windows und für Linux. Ich hab vorhin unter Linux installiert auf dem Server. Und da gibt's nämlich dann eine entsprechende iPad- und iPhone-App für. Und damit kannst du auf dein Plex Media Server zugreifen. Und du hast halt eine schöne Übersicht. Und wenn irgendwelche Serieninformationen sind, dann lädt dir automatisch die Serieninformationen. Und zu filmen lädt dir die entsprechenden Filminformationen und zeigt dir schön Coverbildchen an und sowas. Und dann kannst du das auf deinem iPhone oder auf deinem iPad eben steuern. Kannst du das da abspielen. Und hat natürlich Airplay. Ist natürlich Airplay tauglich. Das heißt, du kannst das direkt drüber schicken an Airplay. Und hast du da irgendwo auf deinem Mac läuft da dein Plex Media Server irgendwie in der Menüleiste?
Ja, der Media Server heißt, ich muss diese ganzen Filme auch selber vorhalten.
Na ja, das ist dann sozusagen für... Du kannst ja auch die Mediathek da reinschmeißen. Du brauchst es halt nicht über iTunes zu sinken.
Na eigentlich will ich ja sowieso nur... Ich will eigentlich nur den Bildschirm anschalten und sagen, ich will jetzt diese Sendung gucken. So, und entweder ist das ein Film und das soll einfach alles aus dem Internet kommen. Ich will das nicht auf eigenen Festplatten abspeichern.
Das wird noch eine Weile dauern.
Ja, aber das ist das, was ich will.
Ja, das wollen wir alle. Das wird uns aber die Content-Industrie nicht geben, weil das wäre ja alles Robcoup. Da würden wir eine Robcoup her.
Ich weiß nicht, wir wollten auch mal die Musik einfach so eingeben und dann auf dem Computer haben, damit wir die mitnehmen können und immer hören können. Und das haben wir dann auch irgendwann bekommen. Und das ist jetzt schon ganz schön lange her. Acht Jahre.
Also ich bin bei...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt noch wirklich so lange hin ist. Na, iTunes. iTunes Store.
Oder? Aber jetzt so, dass ich Musik mir noch ein zweites Mal runterladen darf, wenn ich mir die erste Kopie versehentlich gelöscht habe, ohne einen Backup zu machen, das ist ja jetzt schon immer noch ein Problem.
Ja, aber es ist jetzt nicht so ein Problem, dass es diese ganze Revolution dieses Marktes verhindert hätte, sondern das hat jetzt stattgefunden. Im Fernsehbereich hat das eben noch nicht stattgefunden. Es ist halt immer noch alles, Domäne von Kabel, Fernseher, Betreibern und so weiter. Die Frage ist, wie kann man an den etablierten Strukturen vorbei ein Fernsehbezugsmodell aufbauen, was attraktiv genug ist? Und wahrscheinlich muss man zwischen zwei Arten den Fernseher zu benutzen unterscheiden. Nämlich das eine ist live Fernsehscheiße gucken, also so diesen ganzen Quatsch, der den ganzen Tag läuft und der Fernseher läuft die ganze Zeit. Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so der Markt. Der andere Markt ist der, ich weiß genau, was ich gucken will, Markt. Ich schau jetzt einen Film. Ich will die neue Folge von der und der Serie sehen. Oder ich suche explizit nach irgendeinem Qualitäts-Content, was weiß ich, Dokumentationen, Film, Noir-Archive, Sachen.
Und wo ist aber dann da der Fernseher? Also dann kaufe ich mir doch irgendwie einen iMac oder weißt schon und dann habe ich das doch irgendwie mehr oder weniger.
Du kaufst ja jetzt einen iMac und dann hast du was? Dann hast du das alles noch gar nicht.
Na, iTunes-Store, Movies, Rentals, Series und so weiter. Das ist doch alle da. Du willst mir nicht erzählen, dass Apple weltweit mit ARD, ZDF, Kanal Plus und was weiß ich nicht, irgendwelche Deals macht, um irgendwie die Sendung da anzunehmen.
Darauf müsste es irgendwann hinauslaufen. Na wie soll es sonst gehen?
So haben sie es mit der Musik auch gemacht. Außerdem, ein Computer ist ein Computer, da ist eine Maus dran und eine Tastatur, das ist nicht Fernsehen. Wenn das Fernsehen wäre, dann gäbe es Fernsehen schon gar nicht mehr.
Aber ich glaube, gerade in Deutschland ist das. Wenn wir jetzt sehen, was hier gerade abgeht wegen der Verlage mit dieser dämlichen Tagesschau-App, stell dir vor, die ARD würde mit Apple zusammenarbeiten, dass man ARD-Sendungen auch über eine iTunes sich angucken darf. Ich sehe jetzt schon, wie haufenweise CDU, CSU, Medienpolitiker knallrot anlaufen.
Das wäre jetzt schon möglich. Ja, Apple könnte problemlos die Mediathek in ihr Apple TV einbauen. Wenn es ein Programm gibt, Mediathek, dann kann das auch auf einem Apple TV sein.
Es gibt ein Programm Mediathek mittlerweile? Von ZDF gibt es eine Mediathek, ne?
Hier auf dem Mac, das Mediathek-Programm.
Mit dem man sich die Folgen immer runterladen kann.
Oder direkt halt los spielen.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt quasi im Graubereich aktiv. Also das ist nichts Offizielles. Das geht nicht an irgendeine offizielle API dran oder so was.
Meines Wissens schon. Ja?
Ich dachte, dass die einfach über die Seite drüber scrapen.
Sie rumscrapen?
Ja, aber ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht gibt es ja mittlerweile sowas wie eine offizielle API. Als ich mal was aus der ZDF-Mediathek runterladen wollte für jemanden, der da ein berechtigtes Interesse dran habe, da war es ein Pain in the ass. Also die machen davon in unserer Mediathek App richtig, richtig viel.
Na gut, an ARD hängt das glaube ich erstmal auch gar nicht. Der Markt, der da irgendwie besiegt werden muss, ist der Fernsehmarkt in den USA. Und wenn das in den USA funktioniert, dann funktioniert das auch schnell auf dem Rest des Planeten, zwals alle hinterherlaufen.
Naja, das ist ja das nächste Problem. In den USA funktioniert das ja so grob wenigstens. Da gibt es ja sowas wie Hulu und Transorten. Also da gibt es ja wenigstens erste Ansätze in der Richtung, die sehe ich hier in Deutschland aber überhaupt nicht. Leider.
Ich wollte noch mal den Gedanken ein bisschen ausführen und ich muss es auch noch ein bisschen erweitern. Ich meinte ja, es gibt so zwei Sachen, ich glaube es sind sogar drei Sachen. Es gibt Sachen, die sind so on demand. Filme, die liegen so rum und warten darauf, bis ich sie irgendwann mal anklicke. Dann gibt es halt dieses Live-Quassel-Programm. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das kategorisieren soll. Also dieser Quatsch, dieser Werbebegleitungskram. Und dann gibt es aber ja auch so die Sachen, wo Fernsehen seine eigentliche Bestimmung, also wo Fernsehkanäle ihre eigentliche Bestimmung haben oder seinen eigentlichen Sinn erfüllen. Nämlich Sachen, die eigentlich nur live interessant sind. Also Sport und Breaking News. Also so 9-Eleven und Fußball. Das sind irgendwie die Sachen, da ist Fußball-Weltmeisterschafts-Finale, das lädst du dir ja nicht auf YouTube an.
Vermutlich nicht.
Also es sei denn YouTube ist irgendwann mal live und so weiter. Das ist ein anderes Ding.
Also das wird hingehen.
Aber das ist halt jetzt kein Download-Kram, das holst du dir ja nicht danach, aber das wird ja auch wieder betorrent und dann sitzt du dich da vorm in der Bierflasche und dann fährst du das an.
Also ich glaube, das macht mehr Leute, als du denkst.
Ja, dann schauen sie sich das aber nochmal an. Aber du willst das live sehen, du rennst dahin, wo es das ist und du suchst dir vielleicht deine Kneipe, wo du es dir anschaust, du rennst danach aus, ob sie irgendwie Kabel- oder Satellitenanschluss haben, weil es darüber entscheidet, ob du zwei Sekunden früher jubelst oder nicht. Darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus, diese Diskussion hier im Apple-Universum mit sind denn Ups vielleicht die Zukunft von Fernsehen? Was ich in dieser ganzen Diskussion immer vermisse, ist, dass das ja auf Apple TV schon so ist. Also da gibt es ja schon diese Ups. Dieses, wie heißt das, MLB?
Naja, es gibt kein App Store.
Es gibt kein App Store, aber es ändert ja nichts an der Tatsache, dass es sich hierbei um Ups handelt. Und die sind da ja irgendwie drauf gelandet. Die hat ja irgendjemand programmiert und ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher. Und es gibt es auch jetzt schon auf dem iPhone. Du hast Kanal und auf dem iPad, du hast was weiß ich hier. Bloomberg TV, aber auch diese ganzen Sportskanäle. Du kannst hier was weiß ich eine ESA ab runterladen und wenn da eine Rakete startet, dann hast du da deinen Livestream. Und die abbietet dir eben genau das User-Interface, was du eben für diesen Content brauchst. Ja, das kann nur Video sein, aber das kann eben auch begleitet mit irgendwelchen Korrelationsdaten, Statistiken für Sport etc., Live-Kommentar, Pipapo. Was auch immer, was du eben brauchst, was du zu diesem Videobild und dem Audio noch ergänzend hinzufügen möchtest oder eben eine spezifische Navigationsstruktur. Und in dem Moment, wo du Airplay hast, kannst du es ja auch auf den Big-Screen bringen. Also geht schon auch irgendwie. Und man könnte sogar fast vermuten, vielleicht ist ja einfach nur das iPad im Zusammenhang mit Apple TV schon irgendwie die Lösung. Weil jetzt bräuchtest du ja nur noch für jeden Sender, den du gerne siehst, eine App.
Das muss schneller gehen.
Es ist halt nicht so dieses Kanäle-Ding.
Wobei, ob man dieses Kanäle-Ding...
Aber wenn du für Newsstand schon so ein Meta-Interface hast für diese ganzen Zeitungen, könnte man natürlich auch genauso so ein Interface-TV-Set für die ganzen TV-Apps machen, die über irgendeinen Meta-API dann auch...
Also ich finde diese Unterscheidung ganz spannend. Also ich bin... Es gibt ja so dieses, was du eben meintest, dieses ich schalte ein Fernseher ein und es sind Leute, die ich habe jetzt Zeit totzuschlagen. Und darum schalte ich jetzt die Glotze ein und irgendwas wird schon kommen, was ich nicht total unerträglich finde und so... So diese Berieselung. Das ist was, was mir total abgeht. Also das mache ich wirklich null. Ich mache es einfach nicht. Das findet bei mir nicht statt. Ich habe nie das Gefühl, dass ich jetzt dringend irgendwie durch schlechtes, durch bewegte Bilder, die Leute ohne Geschmack zusammengestellt haben, berieselt werden müsste. Sondern wenn ich irgendwie was gucke, dann gucke ich immer extrem. Dann sage ich, ich möchte jetzt die neue Folge von der und der Serie sehen. Und darauf habe ich jetzt Bock. Und das gucke ich mir jetzt an. Das gucke ich so lange, wie es läuft. Und danach schalte ich die Glotze wieder aus. Oder wenn ich noch was anderes spannen, dann gucke ich eben das hinterher. Und ich glaube, dafür ist eine App total gut geeignet. Weil da wird man, genau wie du es gesagt hast, sowas in der Richtung wie Newsstand, halt für Kanäle oder wahrscheinlich gar nicht für Kanäle, sondern für einzelne Shows. Jedes Show hat ihren Button. Und jeder Button sieht ein bisschen anders aus, wenn es eine neue Folge gibt. Und man findet seinen Content schnell und einfach wieder. Und die Inhalteanbieter können noch ein bisschen drumherum Prozedere machen.
Können ihre Werbung machen.
Können ihre Werbung machen. Wird wahrscheinlich so ganz furchtbar. Ein DVD mit dem ich abholen... Nee, das wird nicht lange dauern, dann wird es wieder vorbei gehen. Können Videoclips vorher zeigen, dass das Raubkopieren dieser Software eine Straftat ist und dass man sich die Raub kopieren muss, wenn man dieses Video skippen will.
Also Werbung können die gleich voll vergessen. Wenn ich einen Apple TV kaufe, will ich doch keine Werbung.
Na ja, das hast du im Zweifel zwar nicht du zu entscheiden.
Doch. Das hab nur ich zu entscheiden. Also will ich nicht.
Na, keine Ahnung. Also ich meine, wenn man jetzt das so denkt, dass es so einen Fernseher zu kaufen gibt, wo so ein Apple TV mit drin ist, dann ist das wirklich so ein Up-Store, der quasi dann auch so ein Kanal-Store ist, dass du dir so deine Kanäle kaufst, die du auch noch haben willst, die dann irgendwie up sind, die irgendeinem speziellen API noch genügen müssen, damit sie von außen entsprechend da angesprochen werden kann bzw. sich in so eine Menüsstruktur mit auch einbinden lassen. Dann muss es ja irgendeine Möglichkeit geben, da mit Geld zu verdienen. Und warum sollten die dann nicht Werbung machen können, dürfen? Dass du das nicht willst, ist was anderes.
Bei Live kann ja sein, aber wenn ich da irgendwelche Serien mir kaufe, dann will ich da keine Werbung.
Du kannst ja bei deinem Kanal dann auch kaufen. Du kannst dann auch innen absagen und sagen, ich möchte jetzt hier diesen Content haben, aber ich möchte halt keine Werbung haben. Und dann schaltest du die Werbung einfach aus. Dann hast du halt deinen Fußballkanal mit ohne Werbung und der kostet dann, weiß ich, 20 Euro um den Monat. Und dann hast du da in Full HD live alle Bundesligaspieler. Tralala, hast du dann halt einfach.
Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt drauf.
Und das kaufst du dann halt alles über den App-Store?
Ich glaub ja dann ja nicht, dass dann Fernseher kommt. Wahrscheinlich kommt eher eine Apple-TV-Update-Geschichte.
Ja, es könnte mir das auch sehr gut vorstellen, dass sie das erstmal über dieses Device weitertreiben. Und erst ab einem Punkt, wo sie sehen, dass es jetzt wirklich gut funktioniert, dann noch das passende Gerät dazu bauen, wo dann nicht mehr alle danach schreien, wo man denn das Kabel da reinsteckt. Ab dem Moment, wo alle glücklich sind mit Ethernet hintendran, können sie auch ihr eigenes Gerät bauen.
Oder von vornherein richtig. Ich meine, warum nicht auch ein Fernseher bauen? Da kriegst du wenigstens eine große Gewinnspanne raus. Ich meine, das ist so, aus Apple denke ich, ist das eigentlich Design... Also ich meine, Apple-Philosophie wäre, wir bauen eigenen Fernseher. Design deine Hardware, design deine Software, mach alles aus einer Guss, alles aus einer Hand, dann kriegst du auch eine ordentliche Gewinnmarge drauf und hast die gesamte User Experience unter Kontrolle. Das wär eigentlich der Apple Way.
Aber was müsste dieses Gerät halt können? Würden die Leute das kaufen, wenn da kein Kabelanschluss dran ist? Sondern nur Ethernet? Würdest du einen Fernseher kaufen von Apple, der nur Ethernet hat?
Also ich würde das machen, weil ich auf den Kabelanschluss keinen Wert lege. Ich weiß nicht, ob das ausreichend Leute tun würden.
Naja, wenn da nicht ARD und ZDF draufläuft, wenn du auf die 1 und die 2 drückst, dann ist das für die wahrscheinlich kein Fernseher.
Ich drücke nie. Ja, okay, das kann sein. Das hängt natürlich aber, ich meine, das ist ja bei Apple nun auch, dass die Revolution selten in der Hardware steckt. Oder zumindest eigentlich nie nur in der Hardware, sondern es ist immer noch die Software. Was kommt denn über dieses Ethernet oder über dieses WLAN dann drüber? Davon hängt es doch ab. Wenn da spannender Content drinsteckt, klar, dann ist mir doch scheißegal, ob das über Kabel kommt, im Endeffekt, oder über Ethernet. Dann ist mir Ethernet zwar lieber. Wenn da kein spannender Content drinne ist, oder der Content, den die Leute haben wollen, dann werden die natürlich sagen, nee, dann wollen sie es halt nicht. Das hängt doch immer davon ab. Und die Frage ist doch, wie schafft es das?
Die Netzer müssten halt auch mitspielen. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab da auch keine Antworten.
Also ich finde es, ich gebe zu, ich hab keine Antworten. Ich wette, dass auf dem Apple TV Apps kommen werden und dass da einfach in irgendeiner Form, entweder auf dem Apple TV oder auf dem eigenen Fernseher, ich bin bloß nach wie vor sehr gespannt, was das hier in der Face angeht. Weil an dieser Siri-Bedienung, von der jetzt alle mal erzählen, das glaube ich keine Sekunde lang. Siri, Spule, 20 Sekunden vor.
Nein.
Also ein Fernseher, so wie bei Blade Runner halt.
So mit reinzoomen und um die Ecke und so.
Das ist aber kein Fernseher, den er da steuert.
Sondern?
Das ist so ein Foto-Analyseteil.
Ja, mein Fernseher muss ja auch alles können dann. Das muss die Eier legen, wollen mich so werden.
Nein, genau das nicht.
Ist zu klein. Großer Bildschirm.
Kaufe dir einen 27 Zoll Anleck.
Das muss so aussehen, da nur als Schaum.
Dann hängt dir ein Beamer dran. Oder hängt dir einen externen Bildschirm dran.
Steve hat jetzt sein Geheimnis mit ins Grab genommen und wir rätseln jetzt ewig, was er meint, herausgefunden zu haben.
Aber wo war ihr gerade so bei Mediacenter und Zeugsblind? Also kann ich ja noch mal ein kleines Update geben. Wie ich schon erwähnt habe, ich bin großer Freund von XBMC und gucke darüber mein Zeug an. Jetzt habe ich, was allerdings bei XBMC wirklich nervt, ist halt der ganze Installationsaufwand. Weil da muss man sich ein... Ja, nervt halt. Und meine XBMC-Installation neigte dazu, zerschossen zu sein. Linux ist ja nie in so einem eindeutigen Zustand, sondern es gibt ja da unterschiedliche Grade von zerschossen. Ich hatte zum Beispiel das Problem, dass die Kiste anfing deutlich langsamer zu booten und dass irgendwie meine ganzen Filme in der Bibliothek doppelt und dreifach auch getaucht sind, dass auch Bibliotheklöschen nichts gebracht hat und weiß ja toll was. Also ganz merkwürdige Sachen. Ich habe mich schon ewig davor gedrückt, da mal das Ganze neu aufzusetzen und frisch zu machen. Und bin sehr froh, dass ich so lange gezögert habe, weil es gab jetzt was, das heißt OpenELEC oder Open-E-L-E-C.
Das wird bei xbmc.org direkt.
Und das ist so eine minimale Linux-Installation, die ein XBMC mitbringt. Also so ein total kleines Ding. Hat für meinen ACS Bayer Revo hier mit so Ion-Chip-Satz, so diesem üblichen kleiner Atom und eine ok Grafikkarte-Chip-Satz, hat er alle Treiber von vornherein mitgebracht. WLAN-Einstellungen konnte ich direkt übers User-Interface machen. Das war ein bisschen versteckt. Da musste ich bei XBMC in Programs gucken. Da gibt es halt ein Einstellungsprogramm für dieses OpenELEC, mit dem man da die ganzen Einstellungen vornehmen kann. Da sind auch ein paar andere sinnvolle Einstellungen dabei. War installiert so schnell, dass ich dachte, die Installation wäre schiefgegangen, weil das irgendwie nur, ich sag jetzt mal, 30 Sekunden gedauert hat und danach war es installiert. Ich hab's auf einer SD-Karte installiert, hab nicht mal extra die Platte neu formatiert oder sowas. Kann also noch zurückgreifen auf meine alte Installation. Bootet schnell, kann alles, was ich will, ist großartig. Also wenn ihr mal mit XBMC auf einem dedizierten System rumspielen wollt, dann guckt euch auf jeden Fall mal dieses OpenELEC an.
openelec.tv mit einer total mega snappy Webseite. Ich bin gerade total weggehauen.
Jaja, die Webseite ist furchtbar.
Ich find die, also die ist so wunderbar, fluid. Ich wundere mich, was die hier für Frameworks benutzen. Also ich hab, wie gesagt, schnappi.
Ewig gebraucht, um...
Mit Flatterbutton.
Um rauszukriegen... Oh, die haben Flatterbutton. Den, den würde ich dann gerne mal drücken. Ja.
Drück mal.
Mach ich.
Gibt uns die Gelegenheit uns auch nochmal zu bedanken bei allen, die unsere Flatterbuttons hier klicken. Drei um. Das finanziert unter anderem die Pizza, die Dennis heute nicht bekommen hat.
Weil ihr nicht geflattert habt. Nächstes Mal sind wir so richtig doppeltgroß auswählen.
Nächste Woche gehen wir wieder bei Pizza Astral.
Das kann ich gleich schon mal ansagen. Heute ist jetzt auch sowieso der Tag hier, 31.10. des Tages. Da kann man nochmal überlegen, von wem man alles noch so profitiert hat in diesem Monat. Und da auch nochmal vorbeischauen. Da gibt es doch eine Menge. Wie viele Leute habe ich geklickt diesen Monat? Übersicht.
Ach, ich nutze das ja leider viel zu wenig.
74 Klicks habe ich verteilt.
Vorbildlich. Ich bin ja da... Ich vergesse das immer.
Das meiste sind Subscriptions.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal ein paar Subscriptions machen.
Ich hab dich auf Subscription.
Du hast 74, 73 andere Leute auch auf Subscription.
Hast du deine Sachen mal geklämt, Dennis?
Nö, ich muss ja Firefox noch überholen.
Wie du musst Firefox überholen?
Na, mit den meisten unclaimed Dingens da, da gibt's doch so einen Top Ten da. Das ist schon cool, wenn man da ganz oben ist.
Also die Top-Listen, ist das hier die Top-Listen direkt oder?
Weiß nicht, da gibt's noch so eine Liste. Top Ten unclaimed, irgendwie flatter Schnick Schnack. Was ich aber noch zu deinem Ex-BFC sagen wollte, wenn wir wieder zur Hardware-Ecke kurz mal wechseln, es gibt ein kleines, wie soll man sagen, es gibt eine Charity in England, unter anderem gegründet von dem Programmierer, der vor über 25 Jahren mal Elite programmiert hat, nämlich David Braben heißt der, aber auch noch andere Leute, die haben eine Charity gegründet, die dafür sorgen will, dass Kids, Schüler wie auch immer, dass Studenten besser mit Computern umgehen können, also mehr basteln und Hardware und so.
Hörst du uns manchmal zu, wenn wir hier so eine Sendung machen? Willst du jetzt auf Blackberry Pie kommen? Wir haben hier schon mehrfach drüber geredet.
Hat man den schon?
Den hatten wir schon. Vielleicht hast du mehr, vielleicht hast du neue Sachen darüber.
Eigentlich nicht, ich hab den erst gestern oder vorgestern zum ersten Mal von gehört, war das in der Sendung, da brauch ich nicht die Arme bestimmt sagen. Ja, weiß nicht, da hab ich halt nicht so aufgepasst.
Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht aus dem...
Elite-Programmierer Tralala bringen halt so kleines Arm-Bot raus, was halt voll tauglich ist. Das ist halt ganz klein, also ist halt so ein Arm, 700 Megahertz.
HMD-Ausgang?
Genau, 1080p.
Problemlos, genau.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es problemlos ist, aber es ist schon ein bisschen älter Rat. Es ist nicht so top-notch, ist schon ein bisschen alter Schnickschnack, aber halt mit Ethernet-Port nur 35 Dollar, was schon ein ganz schöner Kampfpreis ist. Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. WLAN weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Kampfpreis, was dadurch liegt, dass es eine Charity ist und die gar nicht Geld machen wollen, sondern die wollen halt wirklich dafür sorgen, dass die Kids irgendwie da basteln können. Und das ist ja nicht nur programmieren. Der hat auch General Purpose EO-Pins. Du kannst auch da Zeug anschließen und LEDs an- und ausschalten oder was auch immer du da so anschließt und so weiter und so fort. Und ja, wollte ich mal wehen. Und da gibt es wohl auch schon Interesse, da dieses XBMC drauf zu portieren.
Ja, das ist wieder für gemacht. Ich wollte daraus gerne mein Küchenradio mit diesem Board bauen. Weil Sound auskank, ein bisschen W-Line rein.
War deine Geschichte mit diesem Raspberry Pi schon auch über Küchenradio? Küchenradio kann ich mich erinnern, dass du da irgendwas machst.
Genau, das war mit diesem Raspberry Pi.
Verstehe. Na dann hab ich das verschneitert.
Wobei Max 70 war das wohl, wir das...
So lange ist das schon her, echt? Verstehe. Weil draußen sind diese Dinger noch nicht.
Ja, leider noch nicht.
Es gibt nur Prototypen und das soll irgendwann mal rauskommen.
Ich hoffe mal, dass das keine Vapor wird, oder dass sie sich nachher total vertan haben und es kostet 200 Euro.
Glaub ich nicht. Wie gesagt, das ist eine Charity. Die haben da ganz andere...
Anforderungen?
Die wollen einfach nur ganz viele für einen guten Preis und dann irgendwie die nach Schule da irgendwo einfach abkippen. Und wenn die Kids so ein Ding zerschießen, weil sie da irgendwas rumbasteln, dann legst du halt den nächsten, weil es so billig ist, dass das einfach keine Rolle mehr spielt.
Ja, das wär total geil. Hoffentlich gibt es das auch so für Leute wie mich und dich. Also ich könnte mir ja schon vorstellen, ein kleines Eimerchen vorzubestellen.
Das Ding am Ende kostet 50 Euro anstatt 35 Dollar. Und so unwahrscheinlich ist das nicht. Wenn man sich anguckt, hier Intel verkauft ja halt die Atombords. Wo halt Dual Core Atombords mit 1,8 Gigahertz drauf sind, verkaufen die auch für 65 Euro. Also das ist auch ein richtig komplettes Motherboard mit allem drum und dran. Speicher muss halt noch draufstecken und so. Aber das geht schon.
Ich fand diesen Raspberry Pi halt, weil der ist auch so schön klein. So USB-Stick-Größe und so.
USB-Stick-Größe?
Naja, so ein schmales Händchen.
So klein ist der auch nicht. Also wenn man sich das jetzt mal anguckt, der ist schon eher so...
Das ist doch bestimmt das Alpha-Board von denen, oder?
Doppelte Zigaretten-Schachtel-Größe, oder?
Ich glaube, das ist ja ein Alpha-Board. Die finale Version soll deutlich kleiner werden.
Was willst du da noch viel kleiner machen?
Weiter integrieren. Wo kommt hier Strom? Strom soll halt über Mikro-USB kommen.
Da ist Strom.
Der wird halt wegfallen. Ich glaube, das sollte wirklich so ein schmaler Streifen werden.
Also habe ich nix von gelesen. Ich habe immer nur diese Bilder gesehen, aber es sind halt auch nur Alpha-Boards. Es kann schon sein, dass wir den vielleicht sogar auch noch kleiner machen. Sollte man auf jeden Fall weiter beobachten. Das ist ein interessantes Projekt.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall einen Blog, wo regelmäßig auch mal raspberrypie.org auch regelmäßig mal so Updates draufstehen und auch mal Fotos zu sehen sind, wie der aktuelle Standrad ist.
Das heißt nicht RaspberryPie, sondern RaspberryPie.
Also P-I.
Na ja, man kann es aber auch Pi.
Man spricht es natürlich genauso aus, aber es schreibt sich halt anders.
Wie Pi, genau, P-I.
Ja, aber ich meine ja für die Leute, die da jetzt suchen.
Das Logo ist auch total durchdacht und weiß der Teufel was.
Ja, es ist ja Westminster voller Dingens, oder wie heißt es? Wie heißt dieses Muster? Westminster voller Rehne, oder?
Also auf jeden Fall war das, was war das Logo? Das Logo hat insgesamt 32, also es besteht aus einer Raspberry, was heißt eine Raspberry eigentlich? Was heißt das auf Deutsch? Himbeere. Also aus 32 Himbeeren-Segmenten, weil es ein 32-Bit-Prozessor ist, und davon sind glaube ich 11 jeweils sichtbar. Genau, weil es ein ARM 11 ist. Verstehe. Also total durchdachtes Logo.
Und eine Himbeere, ich meine, das ist jetzt auch nicht so weit weg von Apple.
Zu diesem Plex kann ich ja vielleicht nochmal kurz was erzählen. Also da bin ich nämlich heute nochmal drauf gestoßen, weil iPhoneBlock darüber berichtet hat, das ist echt mittlerweile ganz cool. Also das ist, habe ich ja schon vorhin schon gesagt, gibt halt diesen Media-Server dafür, den man von seinem, der auf Windows, Linux und Mac läuft. Und den kann man dann von Mac von iOS, also von iPad und iPhone aus ansprechen und gerade die iPad-Unterstützung und die iPhone-Unterstützung macht echt einen ziemlich guten Eindruck. Wenn ihr also irgendwie eure Mediendatenbank automatisiert in den Griff kriegen wollt, dann ist das eine großartige Sache, weil der halt auch Serien zuordnen kann, Informationen runterlädt, rauskriegt, welche Folge das ist, Bildchen dazu packt, das ist schon alles extrem schick. L-E-X.
Gut, wir sind jetzt langsam auch am Ende. Kleiner Pro-Tip übrigens noch für dein Flatter-Problem. Falls du schon mal Subscriptions hattest. Weiß nicht, hast du das schon mal benutzt?
Ja, ich glaub, ich hab's schon mal benutzt.
Genau, wenn deine Subscriptions nur ausgelaufen sind, also wenn das jetzt sozusagen der Grund ist, dass du da nicht genug Begünstigte findest, in deinem Dashboard gibt's da unten so einen Tab mit dem Abonnements und da kannst du dir dann auch die abgelaufenen anzeigen. Also alles, was du irgendwann mal abonniert hattest, kannst du dir eben auch das anzeigen lassen, was ausgelaufen ist und gegebenenfalls noch mal durchgehen. So, und dann klickst du halt noch mehr.
Ach so, die abgelaufenen. Ich hab ein aktives Hühe, das bei der Tat.
Diese Mediathek zum Beispiel für den Mac, die ist da ja auch vertreten.
Die nutze ich tatsächlich total, also ich meine, ich hätte jetzt kein Problem damit, die zu unterstützen, aber das nutze ich extrem selten.
Ich nutze das immer häufiger, ich bin ganz überrascht. Also, das ist echt gut und das ist irgendwie prima. Außerdem kann man auch noch den David über Flatter unterstützen, der hier immer diese tollen Intros macht für unsere Sendung.
Den kann man wirklich mal, wie heißt der gleich auf Flatter? Den kann man wirklich mal ein Abo schenken. Denne ich auch. David-17.01 David-17.01, genau wie die Enterprise.
Flatter, findest du auch bei Movamix. Immer an die Show, nur ganz am Anfang.
Die sollt mal ein nicht endendes Abo nachmachen.
Ist in der Diskussion. Da soll sich auch dieses Jahr noch was tun bei Flatter. Es gibt da schon bitter Versionen einer überarbeiteten Webseite und das wird dann alles noch hübscher. Ich bin ganz gespannt, was sich da noch so tut.
Sind wir schon fertig oder was?
Ja, ich denke ja.
Tim schlägt fast ein, ich bin auch ein bisschen am Schwächeln und du machst jetzt auch nicht so Ehrgeiz, als ob du noch großartige Themen hättest, oder? Dann nehme ich jetzt auch nicht so ein Stäbchen.
Was sind das denn?
Hitchies.
Heißen die irgendwie.
Nur die reinsten chemischen Farbstoffe.
Krasses Zeug. Joa, und? Haben wir irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen? O-Chat?
Achso, es gibt einen neuen Google Reader.
Dann können wir uns noch mal kurz über den Google Reader aufregen.
Wie online. Hört auf, um zu schmatzen. Das ist widerlich. Dafür gibt es Schmatztaste. Ich werde das jetzt beenden, aus den Gründen, um unsere Hörer zu schonen. Wir bedanken uns ordentlich, fürs zuhören. Hab ich eigentlich noch irgendwas zum Ausklang? Ich glaube nicht. Es gibt jetzt halt einfach keinen Ausklang. Zumindest keinen richtigen.
Na ja, keinen dramatischen.
Also, nichts.
Nichts, was ihr nicht schon mal gehört habt.